SUB ONE HEARING ON. MARCH NINTH
OF TWENTY TWENTY WE WILL BEGIN
AS A SUBCOMMITTEE UNTIL WE
ESTABLISH QUORUM I'D LIKE TO
INVITE THE PANEL FOR ISSUE ONE.
TO COME FORWARD.
WHEN YOU'RE
READY SURGEON GENERAL AND
APOLOGIES I DID NOT SEE EDUARDO
GARCIA WE WILL- TAKE YOU NEXT
ON THE AGENDA SO. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON. VERY PLEASED TO BE
HERE THIS AFTERNOON TIME DOCTOR
NEEDING BURKE KERIS CALIFORNIA
SURGEON GENERAL. MY NAME IS
MATT SCHILLER ALSO WITH THE
OFFICERS SURGEON GENERAL. FOR
ME TO HAND IN WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. YEAH AMY
BERMAN FINANCE. SONNY BETTER
WITH THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE. WHEN YOU'RE READY. SEC
THE OFFICE OF THE SURGEON
GENERAL HAS- SPENT THE PAST
YEAR WORKING CLOSELY WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICE SAYS ON THE FIRST IN
THE NATION EFFORT TO- TRAIN
PRIMARY CARE CLINICIANS TO
SCREEN. TO SCREEN FOR AT
CHILDREN AND ADULTS FOR ADVERSE
CHILDHOOD EXPERIENCES AND
RESPOND WITH TRAUMA INFORMED
CARE. THIS HAS BEEN AN
EXCITING- INITIATIVE AT WITH A
BUDGET OF ROUGHLY A HUNDRED AND
SIXTY MILLION DOLLARS OVER
THREE YEARS AND REPRESENTS
REALLY THE CORNERSTONE OF
CALIFORNIA'S- TRAUMA INFORMED
CARE- ACES AWARE INITIATIVE.
AND AS WE HAVE MOVED FORWARD
WITH FIRST ESTABLISHING THIS
TRAINING FOR OUR HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS WE RECOGNIZE THAT
ADDRESSING- TRAUMA AN ADVERSE
CHILDHOOD EXPERIENCES DOESN'T
BEGIN AND END IN THE EXAM ROOM
BUT RATHER- WE NEED TO MOVE
FORWARD WITH A PUBLIC HEALTH
APPROACH TO ADDRESSING- ACES
AND TOXIC STRESS AS A PUBLIC
HEALTH CRISIS. AND FOR THAT
REASON- WE HAVE REQUESTED-
FUNDING TO BE ABLE TO DEPLOY A
NUMBER ONE A PUBLIC EDUCATION
CAMPAIGN TO RAISE AWARENESS
AMONG THE GENERAL PUBLIC WHICH
IS A CRITICAL COMPONENT OF
PREVENTION AND- NUMBER TWO TO
BE ABLE TO ENGAGE AND CROSS
SECTOR TRAINING TO TRAIN OTHER-
PROVIDERS OUTSIDE OF THE HEALTH
THE SPECIALTY. INCLUDING EARLY
CHILDHOOD PROVIDERS EDUCATORS
LAW ENFORCEMENT AND- GOVERNMENT
WORKERS TO BE ABLE TO RECOGNIZE
AND ADDRESS- CHILDHOOD
ADVERSITY AS A RISK FACTOR AND
RESPOND WITH TRAUMA INFORMED
PRINCIPLES AND I'LL TURN IT
OVER TO ME NOT FOR THE DETAILS.
SO AS PART OF THE PURPOSE WE'RE
REQUESTING A TOTAL OF TEN
MILLION DOLLARS TO BE SPENT
OVER TWO YEARS EIGHT MILLION OF
WHICH IS- DIRECTED AT THE
PUBLIC AWARENESS CAMPAIGN- TO
REACH THE RESIDENTS OF
CALIFORNIA. AND THEN TWO
MILLION DOLLARS IS A LOT OF FOR
THE CROSS SECTOR TRAINING-
BROADLY ACROSS- FOUR SECTORS-
EARLY CHILDHOOD- WORKERS-
EDUCATION WORKERS LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND THEN MORE
GENERALLY GOVERNMENT WORKERS.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE ILIO. ANY
PUBLIC COMMENT ON IS LA- AS ANY
PARTICULARLY- WE UST HAVE ONE
MINOR ISSUE WITH THIS PROPOSAL
THAT WE LIKE TO REYES- THE
PROPOSAL CURRENTLY INCLUDES
BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE THAT WOULD
EXEMPT ALL OF THE CONTRACTS
ASSOCIATED WITH THIS- FUNDING
FROM THE- ENTIRE PUBLIC
CONTRACT CODE THE- MISTER
SCHULER AND OTHER STAFF OF
OFFERED- GOOD JUSTIFICATION FOR
WHY SOME OF THE FUND. WHITE
MAKE MIGHT MAKE SENSE FOR SOME
OF THE FUNDING EXEMPT FROM THE
CONTRACT CODE- FOR EXAMPLE THE
HOPE TO LEVERAGE- PARTNERSHIPS
WITH PHILANTHROPIC
ORGANIZATIONS LOCAL AGENCIES
AND BUSINESSESTHAT MIGHT NOT.
BE QUITE THE TRADITIONAL
CONTRACTING RELATIONSHIP- AT
THE SAME TIME THEY ALL THEY
WILL LIKELY BE RUNNING AN AD
CAMPAIGN- WHICH- WE THINK
WOULD. BE MORE IN LINE WITH THE
TRADITIONAL CONTRACTING
PROCESS. WE ALSO KNOW THE
PUBLIC CONTRACT CONTRACTING
CODE SERVES AN IMPORTANT PUBLIC
PURPOSE WHICH IS TO ENSURE THE
PROPER USE OF STATE FUNDS SO WE
SUGGEST EIGHTY A MINOR.
REVISION TO THE BUDGET BILL
LANGUAGE- WHICH WOULD SORT OF
DIFFERENTIATE BETWEEN THE TYPES
OF CONTRACTS THEY MIGHT ENTER
INTO AND REQUIRE- THE OFFICE TO
FOLLOW THE PUBLIC COUNTRY CODE
FOR THOSE CONTRACTS THAT ARE
MORE LIKE- TRADITIONAL
COMPETITIVE BIDS. THANK CAN WE
HAVE A REPORT IF I MAY SO THAT
THE LA- DID RAISE THAT QUESTION
EARLIER AND WE ARE CERTAINLY
AMENABLE TO WORKING WITH ALL
THE LA- HAND THE- SUBCOMMITTEE
CONSULTANTS IN ORDER TO BETTER
REFINE THAT LANGUAGE AND REALLY
GET TO THE- TO THE READER THAT
ISSUE THAT SOME YOU JUST.
OUTLINED PERFECT- WITH THAT I
WILL JUST HIT PAUSE AS WE ASK
FOR PUBLIC COMMENT ON ISSUE
ONE. SO THAT WE MAY ESTABLISH
QUORUM. ARAMBULA HERE FRAZIER
MATHIS. PATTERSON RAMOS. RUBIO
WOULD. ANY PUBLIC COMMENT ON
ISSUE ONE. BENJAMIN TREND WITH
THE CALIFORNIA PAN ETHNIC
HEALTH NETWORK IN SUPPORT THIS
PROPOSAL. HEY I RETURN CASKEY
WITH THE CHILD CARE RESOURCE
CENTER IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
SEEING NO FURTHER PUBLIC
COMMENT ON BRING IT UP TO THE
SUBCOMMITTEE AND SEE IF THERE
ARE ANY QUESTIONS. SEEING NONE
I WILL JUMP IN AND JUST ALWAYS
SAY HOW SUPPORT OF WE HAVE BEEN
OF THE OFFICE OF THE SURGEON
GENERAL. AND WANT TO. GET AN
UNDERSTANDING OF HOW THIS TIES
INTO THE ACES AWARE DOT ORG IS
THIS PART OF THAT CAMPAIGN.
WOULD THIS BE THE FUNDS TO HELP
WITH THAT PUBLIC EDUCATION OF
SCREEN TREAT AND HE'LL. THAT
DAY WE'RE- THANK YOU THERE THE
ASUS AWARE DOT ORG INITIATIVE
IS A- HAS IS A BROAD INITIATIVE
THAT HAS BEEN- STOOD UP TO BE
THE UMBRELLA UNDER WHICH
CALIFORNIA'S- TRAUMA INFORMED
CARE INITIATIVE RESIGNS. TO
DATE ALL OF THE EFFORTS OF THE
ASUS AWARE INITIATIVE HAVE BEEN
FUNDED THROUGH THE DEPARTMENT
OF HEALTH CARE SERVICES AS-
USING MEDICAID AND PROP FIFTY
SIX FUNDING THIS WOULD BE
ANOTHER INITIATIVE THAT WOULD
DRIVE THE PUBLIC EDUCATION-
ASPECT OF THAT WORK THAT WOULD
ALSO SIT UNDER ACES AWARE-
UMBRELLA- BUT OBVIOUSLY WITH
THE DIFFERENT. FUNDING SOURCE
YES. THANK YOU- WITH THAT I-
BELIEVE WE WILL HOLD THIS ISSUE
OPENED FOR NOW BUT MAY I ASK
YOU AS THE SURGEON GENERAL TO
STAY FOR THE NEXT FEW ISSUES IF
YOU'RE AVAILABLE TO. AS WE HAVE
A PILOT FOR ALL CHILDREN THRIVE
IN A FEW STAKEHOLDER PROPOSALS
RELATED TO TRAUMA THAT MIGHT
INTEREST SO. WITH THAT I'M
GOING TO HOLD ISSUE ONE OPEN
THANK THIS PANEL AND INVITE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER EDUARDO GARCIA
TO COME UP WITH GUARDING ISSUE
THREE.
YEAH. WHEN YOU'RE READY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR COLLEAGUES. WHAT WAS THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PRESENTING THAT
WHAT I WOULD CALL A MODEST- ASK
FOR THE NATIONAL BUT IS NETWORK
QUESTION TWO MILLION DOLLARS
FOR CALLING FOR CARE AT
TRAINING OF EDUCATORS AND WITH
ME IS BE A THREE ONE SALAS-
EDUCATOR WHO'S A DEDICATED
NEARLY TWO DECADES OF SERVICE
TO THE JOB I UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT. AS A COORDINATOR FOR
EXPANDED LEARNING AFTER SCHOOL
PROGRAMS IN THIS CAPACITY- SHE
SURE IS THE QUALITY PROGRAM FOR
TWENTY ONE SCHOOL SITES AND
OVERSEES THE PROP FORTY SEVEN.
LEARNING COMMUNITIES FOR
SUCCESS GRANT WHICH ADDRESSES
SCHOOL CLIMATE ATTENDANCE
REDUCTION SUSPENSION EXPLOSIONS
IN PARTNERSHIP WITH THE
NATIONAL BY THIS NETWORK IF
THIS IS BEEN ABLE TO UTILIZE
BUT FOR SEVEN DOLLARS
EMPLOYMENT EQUITY A QUORUM
MODEL PROGRAMMING SUCH AS
HOLDEN OVERLY AND SHE NICELY
WITH COACH OF A UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT FOCUSING AGAIN ON
TRUMP REFORM CARE BOTH FOR OUR
EDUCATORS AND OUR STUDENTS SO-
SO I KNOW. SHE IS TO TELL TINA
WOMAN OF THE YEAR. SO YOU ARE
THE GREAT TO WITNESS HERE TODAY
FROM DISTRICTS OF. THE FOR
SERVICE. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS HAS
INTRODUCED BY MY FAVORITE
ASSEMBLYMAN A LOT OF. MY NAME
IS A B. GONZALEZ AND I PLAY
MANY ROLES IN THE COMMUNITY
INCLUDING THAT REPRESENT MEANS
SUPERVISOR MENU PER AS AS A
BEHAVIOR HEALTH COMMISSIONER.
ALSO SERVICE AND ON THE- DOES
OUR BEHAVIORAL HEALTH OARD AND
CHAIR OF THE BOARD OF DIRECTORS
FOR THE RIVERSIDE COUNTY LATINO
COMMISSION. AND SERVING THE
STUDENTS OF THE DISTRICT AS A
COORDINATOR FOR EXPENDED
LEARNING PROGRAMS I COULD TELL
OF A LEE UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT. IT'S MY PLEASURE TO
BE BEFORE YOU. REPRESENTING THE
WORK THAT WE'RE DOING WITH THE
NATIONAL COMBAT IS NETWORK
THROUGH OUR PROP FORTY SEVEN
FUNDED LEARNING COMMUNITYFOR
SCHOOL SUCCESS PROGRAM GRANT.
WE HAVE BEEN ABLE TO. DEVELOP A
DEEP RELATIONSHIP WITH THE
COMBAT ISN'T LIKE. THEY DO WORK
NATIONALLY BUT THERE LOCALLY
SERVING NORTHERN AND SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITIES SUCH AS
THE COACHELLA VALLEY CENTRAL
VALLEY BAY AREA. AND WE ARE
LOOKING TO HELP THEM EXPAND
RIGHT THERE ARE CALIFORNIA.
SINCE NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT THE
NATIONAL COMBAT IS NETWORK HAS
WORKED WITH ORGANIZATIONS AND
SYSTEMS TO TRANSFORM. THE
APPROACH THEY EMPLOY WHEN
DELIVERING SERVICES THAT ARE
OFFERED TO CHILDREN FAMILIES
AND THEIR COMMUNITIES. THEIR
APPROACHES TO WORK ALONGSIDE
COMMUNITIES INCLUDING CHILDREN
EDUCATORS SCHOOL PERSONNEL
YOUTH PARENTS AND COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATIONS INTENTIONALLY
TRANSFORM MEAN AND NOT
TRANSFERRING TRAUMA. BY
FACILITATING THE PROCESS THAT
HELPS THEM RECOGNIZE AND
ADDRESS ENCOUNTER TRAUMA. THEY
ALSO ADVOCATE FOR SERVICES THAT
ARE CULTURAL AND HEALING
CENTER. THIS APPROACH OF
COMMUNITY HERE LEAN EMPOWERS
COMMUNITIES THROUGH SCHOOL
DISTRICTS TO RECOGNIZE AND OR
REDISCOVER THE CULTURAL
TRADITIONS. THEY CARRY WITH
THEM THEM AND HELP THEM TO HE
NOT ONLY THEMSELVES. THE PAST
IN FUTURE GENERATIONS OF. THE
GENERATION OF TRAUMA. THE WORK
FOR THE NATIONAL COMBAT IS
NETWORK IS UNIQUE BECAUSE
TRAUMA AFFECTS NOT ONLY
BUILDER. BUT THE ADULTS AROUND
IN THEM FOR MOST FOR THEIR
YOUNG LIVES. THAT DON'T ACTION
TO STUDENT AB ISM YOUR FAX. IF
YOU'RE IS. THAT IS THE BEGAN
WITH AN OUR SCHOOLS SUSPENSE
AND EXPULSIONS HAVE DECREASED
IN TWENTY SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN WE
HAVE ONE THOUSAND SIX HUNDRED
FIFTY NINE SUSPENSIONS AND
SEVENTEEN EXPULSIONS THE YEAR
AFTER AND SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN WE
HAD ONE THOUSAND FOUR HUNDRED
THIRTY SEVEN SUSPENSIONS AND
ELEVEN NEXT WELL SINCEIN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN NINETEEN WE HAD
ONE THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED SIXTY
THREE SUSPENSIONS AND SEVEN
EXPULSIONS SO DURING THE THREE
YEARS OF THE IMPLEMENTATION SO
PENSIONS WERE REDUCED. BY A
HUNDRED NINETY SIX WE HAD HIM
LESS EXPULSION. AS YOU ALL KNOW
THE EIGHT SCORED IS NOT
DETERMINED BY THE LEVEL OF
ADULT EDUCATION TRAUMA FIX THAT
ONLY ADULTS MENTAL HEALTH BUT
ALSO THEIR PHYSICAL HEALTH. AND
THEN HEALTHY ADULT WILL
TRANSFER TRAUMA TO A CHILD
WITHOUT INTENTION BUT CONTINUE
TO CREATE TRAUMATIZED CHILDREN.
BY ADDRESSING THE DAHLE
REACTION TO STUDENT BEHAVIOR WE
CAN CONTINUE TO DECREASE.
CANADA PUNISHMENT WHEN WE ARE
ABLE TO SECURE TWO MILLION
DOLLAR FUNDING NATIONAL COMBAT
IS NETWORK WILL BE ALLOWED TO
EXPAND TO A HIGHER LEVEL OF
IMPLEMENTATION INCLUDING WHOLE
SCHOOL IMMERSION AND WORKSHOPS
FOR THE SURROUNDING COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATIONS WHO SERVE OUR
STUDENTS AND FAMILIES MORE
ADULTS ADDRESSING THEIR TRAUMA
WILL ALLOW FOR THE HEALING
PROCESS TO TAKE PLACE THIS
CULTURALLY HOLISTIC APPROACH
ADDRESSES ROOTED ISSUES WHICH
EXIST WITHIN OUR EDUCATIONAL
SYSTEM. IT WILL ALSO LEAD TO
TRANSFORM IN TRAUMA AND NOT
TRANSFERRING DRUM. MUCH LIKE A
DOCTOR HARRIS'S STORY WE'RE
ADDRESSING WHAT'S IN THE WELL.
SO I WANT TO THANK ALL OF YOU
IN ADVANCE FOR YOUR DEDICATION
CONSIDERATION IN SUPPORT OF
IMPROVING LIVES THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MA'AM THE SHIRT UP HAPPENED
ANSWERED QUESTIONS- TAKE ANY
COMMENTS YOU MAY HAVE THANK YOU
SIR WE WILL NOW TAKE PUBLIC
COMMENT ON ISSUE THREE. HECTOR
SANCHEZ FLORES EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE NATIONAL
COMPETITORS NETWORK IN SUPPORT
OF AB THREE ZERO SIX THREE
TRAUMA INFORMED TRAINING FOR K.
THROUGH TWELVE- STAFF AND
TEACHERS THANK YOU BE. THANK
YOU SIR. GOOD AFTERNOON
GUARDINO VEGA K. TWELVE CONCERT
OUT OF COACHELLA VALLEY UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT- I AM I DO NOT
SEE A COMMODITY NATIONAL
COMMANDED A FACILITATOR- IN
SUPPORT OF THE WORK AS WELL.
THANK YOU MA'AM. SEEING NO
FURTHER PUBLIC COMMENT I'LL
BRING IT UP TO THE COMMITTEE TO
SEE IF THEY HAVE ANY QUESTIONS.
I DON'T THINK IT'S A SURPRISE
THAT WE'VE BEEN QUITE
SUPPORTIVE OF ACES AND PROGRAMS
THAT HAVE WORKED- I THINK WHAT
YOU WILL HEAR FROM THE
COMMITTEE IN GENERAL IS THAT WE
STARTED A PILOT TWO YEARS AGO
THE ALL CHILDREN THRIVE. AND
REALLY ARE LOOKING TOWARDS THAT
AS WHAT. WILL HELP TO GIVE US
SOME OF THE IDEAS MUCH LIKE THE
ONES THAT YOU'RE PRESENTING
HERE. AND SO I'M MAY ASK THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TO. SEE IF WE
CAN WORK WITH YOU SEE LA TO SEE
IF THIS IS A PART OF THEIR-
PROPOSALS THEY WILL PUT
FORWARD. AS A MODEL FOR SOME
REGIONAL HELP AND- ALSO ASK IF
YOU CAN TRY AND GET THE
ENDORSEMENT OF THE SURGEON
GENERAL IT HELPS TO. WANT TO DO
THIS AS WELL SO- WITH THAT WE
WILL HOLD ISSUE THREE OPEN FOR
NOW AND- MOVED BACK TO ISSUE TO.
AND I APOLOGIZE FOR JUMPING BUT
I UNDERSTAND THERE ARE PEOPLE
WHO WANTS TO COMMENTS REGARDING
ISSUE FIVE. WE WILL HEAR ISSUE
FIVE AFTER WE HEAR ISSUE TO. AT.
NO. MORALES ROM THE DEPARTMENT
OF PUBLIC HEALTH. AND I'M JUST
HERE TO KIND OF GIVE YOU A
LIVER BACKGROUND ON WHERE WE
ARE AT- WITHOUT THE CONSTANT ON
THE PROGRESS OF THE ORCHARD DR
PROGRAM SO JUST AS A REMINDER
THE BUDGET ACTIVE TWENTY
EIGHTEEN ALLOCATED TEN MILLION
IN A ONE TIME BASIS FROM THE
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES FUND TO
SUPPORT THE ORCHARD DR PILOT
PROJECT FROM JANUARY FIRST
TWENTY NINETEEN. TO JUNE
THIRTIETH TWENTY TWENTY FIRST
OF THESE FUNDS THE DEPARTMENT
OF PUBLIC HEALTH WAS ALLOCATED
ONE MILLION DOLLARS TO PROVIDE.
ADMINISTRATIVE SUPPORT AS WELL
AS TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND
EVALUATION THREE MANY NINE
MILLION DOLLARS WAS AWARDED-
VIA- THIRTY MONTH CONTRACT TO
THE COMMUNITY PARTNERS AS THE
FIRST AGENTS FOR THIS PROJECT.
WHAT'S UP CONTRACTS TO PUBLIC
HEALTH ADVOCATES AND UCLA
CENTER FOR HEALTHY CHILDREN
FAMILIES COMMUNITIES TO
IMPLEMENT THE PROJECT. THE ALL
CHILDREN THRIVE CALIFORNIA
PILOT PROJECT WILL TEST THE
PUBLIC HEALTH APPROACH TO
PREVENTING CHILDHOOD TRAUMA
COUNTER ITS EFFECTS AND FOSTER
INDIVIDUAL FAMILY AND COMMUNITY
RESILIENCE. AT THIS POINT I
JUST WANT TO PASS IT ALONG TO
THE FOR FOLKS THAT ARE ACTUALLY
ON THE GROUND DOING SOME OF THE
GREAT WORK. WONDERFUL THANK SO
MUCH IT'S REALLY A PLEASURE TO
BE HERE THANKS- THE OPPORTUNITY
GIVE YOU AN UPDATE ON WHERE WE
ARE- PRETTY MUCH HALFWAY
THROUGH- ARE FUNDING IT GOES
QUICK. SO AS WE JUST HEARD A
AND YOU ALL KNOW WELL AND THIS
IS A ONE TIME ALLOCATION OF TEN
MILLION DOLLARS OF PROP SIXTY
THREE FUNDING. SPECIFICALLY TO
PREVENT. ACES TO COUNTER THEIR
EFFECTS TO PROMOTE HEALING TO
FOSTER INDIVIDUAL AND COMMUNITY
RESILIENCE IN ORDER TO GIVE ALL
CHILDREN. IN CALIFORNIA THE
OPPORTUNITY TO THRIVE-
REGIONALLY WAS THREE YEARS OF
MONEY BUT BY THE TIME WE GOT
IT'S DOWN TO TWO AND A HALF
YEARS. AND SO WE HAVE- WE'RE
JUST ABOUT HALFWAY THERE-
PARTNERS IS AS WE SAID PUBLIC
OUT THAT BUCKETS- DEPARTMENT
PUBLIC HEALTH COMMITTEE
PARTNERS AND YOU SEE LA. HERE'S
I HAVE TO SAY THAT IN MY THIRTY
YEARS OF PUBLIC HEALTH THIS IS%
THE MOST. MEANINGFUL WORK THAT
I'VE EVER DONE. SO I REALLY
WANT TO THANK THE- COMMITTEE
AND LEGISLATURE FOR FUNDING
THIS THE FOCUS IS ON PREVENTION
THIS IS ABOUT COMMUNITY LEVEL
PUBLIC HEALTH STRATEGIES TO
PREVENT TRAUMA. AND PROMOTE
CHILD WELL BEING THERE'S A LOT
OF TALK ABOUT ACES THESE DAYS.
OF MOST OF THE TALK IS ABOUT
MEASURING ACES AND DEALING WITH
THEM ONCE THEY'RE THERE WHAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT IS
PREVENTING THEM FROM HAPPENING
TO BEGIN WITH. OUR FOCUS IS ON
CITIES TYPICALLY IT'S COUNTIES
THAT HAVE RESPONSIBILITY FOR
HEALTH ISSUES AND YET PEOPLE
LIVE IN CITIES. PEOPLE IDENTIFY
IN CITIES AND MUCH OF THE
SERVICES THAT ARE OR ARE NOT
AVAILABLE TO PEOPLE ARE RESULT
OF LET'S THEIR AND WHAT'S
PROVIDED IN THE CITY'S WHAT
WE'RE LOOKING AT AND AGAIN THIS
IS THE PUBLIC HEALTH MODEL
WE'RE LOOKING AT SUSTAINABLE
CHANGE BY ENACTING POLICIES. RE
ENGINEERING SYSTEMS LEVERAGING
NEW AND EXISTING FUNDING
INCLUDING HAT NEW AND EXISTING
FUNDING IS THE PROP SIXTY THREE
MENTAL HEALTH FUNDING THERE IS
FOUR HUNDRED AND FORTY MILLION
DOLLARS A YEAR. THIS DEDICATED
TO PREVENTION- THAT'S A LOT OF
MONEY THAT COULD BE GOING INTO
COMMUNITIES- TO BE DOING THIS
KIND OF WORK THAT'S EVIDENCE
BASED WHAT WE'RE LOOKING TO DO
IS TO CREATE AN ECO SYSTEM IN
COMMUNITIES. THAT MEETS THE
NEEDS OF CHILDREN AND SUPPORT
THIS ISN'T ABOUT ONE. MAGIC I
DON'T WANNA SAY BULLET MAGIC-
ANTIDOTE HELPFUL SAY BUT THE
TERM. MAGIC ONE THANK YOU- THIS
IS ABOUT REALLY CHANGING THE
ECOSYSTEM RIGHT NOW WE LIVE IN
IN COMMUNITIES THAT ARE MOSTLY
BASED ON- ECONOMIC DRIVERS-
POLITICAL DRIVERS MUCH OF
WHAT'S GOING ON IN COMMUNITIES
HAS NOTHING WHATSOEVER TO DO
WITH THE WELL BEING OF CHILDREN
AND WE SEE THE EFFECTS OF THAT.
RESIDENT VOICES WERE REALLY
LOOKING AT TURNING THINGS
UPSIDE DOWN SO THAT RESIDENT
VOICES ARE DRIVING WHAT'S
HAPPENING IN COMMUNITIES THAT
THE PRIORITIES ARE BEING SET BY
RESIDENTS THEMSELVES IT'S THE
RESIDENTS OF THE YOUNG PEOPLE
TO PARENTS YOU KNOW WHAT'S
GOING ON IN COLLABORATION WITH
THIS IS- KEY IS. LEVERAGING
WHAT WORKS TO HELP OTHER PLACES
BUILD ON IT TO DO WHAT WORKS
AND- SUPPORTING EACH OTHER TO
GET EVER BETTER. MANDATED IN
LEGISLATION IS A FIFTEEN MEMBER
EQUITY ADVISORY GROUP I WILL
SAY THIS IS THE MOST IMPRESSIVE
GROUP OF PEOPLE I HAVE EVER
WORKED WITH. THEY REPRESENT THE
DIVERSITY- GENDER DIVERSITY
ETHNIC DIVERSITY- OF CALIFORNIA
ECONOMIC DIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA AND THEY ARE.
THEY'RE DRIVING THE SHIP ON
THIS AND- I LEARNED FROM THEM
EVERY DAY SO THEY ARE GUIDING
THE DESIGN AND THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
INITIATIVE TO ENSURE THAT ACT
NURTURES THE WISDOM AND
CREATIVITY OF THE COMMUNITIES
THEMSELVES- I WILL SAY THIS IS
NOT ABOUT WHAT SIXTY YEAR OLD
WHITE MAN WEARING. NICE SILK
TIES THINK SHOULD BE HAPPENING
THIS IS ABOUT- WHAT
COMMUNITIES- KNOW NEEDS TO
HAPPEN THERE IS A WISDOM AND A
DEPTH OF KNOWLEDGE OF WHAT'S
BEEN GOING ON AND WHAT IS GOING
ON THAT REALLY- NEEDS TO DRIVE
THE SHIP AND IS DRIVING THIS
SHIP- SO THEY'RE MAKING SURE
THAT WE'RE ADDRESSING THE
HISTORICAL AN INSTITUTIONAL
RACISM AND OPPRESSION. THAT
HAS- SO LONG BEEN GOING ON IN
COMMUNITIES AND THEY GET THAT
BY DOING THIS WE'RE GOING TO BE
PROMOTING TRUST AND
TRANSPARENCY IN COLLABORATION.
THAT THE WAY COMMUNITIES ARE
GONNA BE WORKING IN THIS IS IF
THEY KNOW THEIR VOICES MATTER
AND THAT- THE HISTORY OF WHAT
THEY'VE BEEN DEALING WITH- IS
GOING TO BE ADDRESSED. AND ALL
OF THIS IN ORDER TO
PARTICULARLY BENEFIT CHILDREN
FROM THE MOST VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES WHERE THERE ARE THE
GREATEST INEQUITIES. THE FIRST
THING THAT COULD ADVISORY GROUP
DID WAS COME UP WITH THEIR
VALUES AND IT IS THESE VALUES
THAT ARE- AGAIN DRIVING THE
WORK THAT'S HAPPENING
PRIORITIZING CHILDREN AND YOUTH
FOCUSING STRICTLY ON WHAT THE
YOUNG PEOPLE NEED NOTHING ELSE
FOCUSING ON INNOVATION
UNDERSTANDING THAT. THE KIND OF
INEQUITIES AND DISPARITIES THAT
WE SEE IN COMMUNITIES- HAVE
RESULTED FROM THE STATUS QUO WE
NEED TO BE THINKING OUTSIDE THE
BOX IN ORDER TO MAKE THOSE
CHANGES. AGAIN I ADDRESSED-
ALLUDED TO THIS IS POWER
SHIFTING RE ORGANIZING
MUNICIPAL STRUCTURES SO THAT
THEY'RE RESPONSIVE TO THE NEEDS
OF HISTORICALLY- DIS INVESTED
CHILDREN. AND SERVANT
LEADERSHIP- WE HAVE A REALLY
REMARKABLE- POSITIVE WORKING
RELATIONSHIP WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF CITIES. I
KNOW LOTS OF CITY OFFICIALS
THEY WANT TO DO THE BEST FOR
THEIR COMMUNITIES. WHAT WE HEAR
FROM THE EQUITY ADVISORY GROUP
AND FROM LISTENING SESSIONS IS.
THAT CITIES CAN DO A BETTER JOB
OF LISTENING AND- SERVING
RATHER THAN ASSUMING. THEY
ALREADY KNOW WHAT'S BEST
THERE'S NOTHING LIKELY TO CA.
NAM SAY SOME MORE ABOUT WHAT
WE'VE LEARNED FROM THAT- WE
HAVE A NUMBER OF SUBCONTRACTORS
THAT WE HIRED ONE GROSS IS A
HUMAN CENTERED DESIGN FIRM
THAT- ARRANGED FOR A WHOLE
SERIES OF COMMUNITY LISTENING
SESSIONS ALL DESCRIBE THE
FINDINGS OF THOSE- NEXT. WE
HAVE COMMUNICATIONS FIRM WE'VE
WORKED WITH UC DAVIS WE NOW
HAVE CITY LEVEL ACES DATA THAT
WE CAN PROVIDE TO EVERY CITY IN
THE STATE. WE JUST FINISHED A
JOB. ON FRIDAY THE RESULTS FROM
PUBLIC A PUT THAT PUBLIC
OPINION POLLING DATA. SIX
THOUSAND- REGISTERED VOTERS
ASKING THEM WHAT DO THEY SEE AS
THE- PRIMARY ISSUES AROUND
TRAUMA. FACING KIDS- WORKING
VASES CONNECTION LONG LONG
STANDING- WELL RESPECTED
ORGANIZATION- THAT HAS-
COALITIONS THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA THEY'RE GONNA BE
HOSTING OUR OUTREACH. AND
LEARNING NETWORK. AND WE'VE
HIGHER COURT INK TO DO. THE
EVALUATION SO WE STARTED ALL OF
THIS WITH A SERIES OF LISTENING
SESSIONS IN SEVEN COMMUNITIES
IN A SEE THAT THEIR THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA- DIFFERENT SIZE
DIFFERENT GRAPHICS. WE
INTERVIEWED- AND THE
CONSULTANTS WONDERS INTERVIEWED
CITY LEVEL- LEADERS EXPERTS IN
DIFFERENT FIELDS- INDIVIDUAL
COMMUNITY RESIDENTS AND THEN-
IN THOSE FIVE COMMUNITIES WE
HAD COMMUNITY LISTENING
SESSIONS. WHERE RESIDENTS
THEMSELVES TOLD US WHAT THEIR
PRIORITIES ARE AND THIS IS WHAT
WE HEARD. WHAT'S THE MOST
IMPORTANT TO FAMILIES STABLE
HOME LIFE EARLY CHILD IN
RICHMOND FEELING SAFE IN THEIR
CITY AND I WILL SAY I WAS
SURPRISED QUALITY FOOD OPTIONS
ARE ORGANIZATIONS TO WORK IN ON
OBESITY RELATED ISSUES AND- AND
FOOD AVAILABILITY FOR A LONG
TIME- IT IS STILL ONE OF THE
PRIMARY ISSUES THAT IS THAT.
FAMILIES ARE. WHAT'S HOLDING
COMMUNITIES BACK HOW
HOMELESSNESS AND HOUSING CAME
UP OVER AND OVER AGAIN THREATS
OF VIOLENCE LACK OF PROGRAMS IN
SUPPORT FOR YOUTH AND MENTAL
HEALTH CHALLENGES AND THE LACK
OF AVAILABLE SERVICES. WHEN
THEY WANT TO SEE MORE PROGRAMS
AND ACTIVITIES FOR YOUNG
PEOPLE. SERVICES AND HOUSING
FOR HOMELESS FOLKS FOR DOUBLE
HOUSING FOR ALL IN IN GENERAL
HEALTHIER ENVIRONMENT. I'M
THEIR DREAMS HI I WILL SAY THIS
WAS ONE OF THE- IT WAS A REALLY
MOVING- FINDINGS. SOCIAL AND
ECONOMIC MOBILITY NOT WANTING
TO STRUGGLE ACCESS TO COLLEGE
WITH THE ABILITY TO GET BACK TO
THEIR COMMUNITIES WE HEARD THAT
OVER AND OVER AGAIN PEOPLE WANT
TO BE PART OF COMMUNITIES
THAT'S BOTH- A SOURCE OF
HEALING AND IT'S AN OPPORTUNITY
TO PROVIDE HEALING TO OTHERS.
SO THE PRIORITY IN PENSIONS
THAT WE'RE WORKING WITH- AND AT
EIGHT COME UP WITH. THE WITH
CLA IS THIS COMBINATION OF
RESIDENT INTERVIEWS AND
LISTENING SESSIONS INTERVIEWS
THE CITY LEADERS AND THIS
PUBLIC OPINION POLLING. WHAT WE
WANTED TO DO THEIR AT THEIR AND
INFINITE NUMBER OF THINGS THAT
OULD BE GOOD COULD BE GOING ON
IN COMMUNITIES WE WANT TO KNOW
IS WHAT IS IT THAT MOST
COMMUNITIES MOST LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR WHAT IS IT THAT. WHEN I
SEE WHAT IS IT THAT THERE ARE
LEFT SHOWS ARE INTERESTED. WHAT
IS IT NOT IN THESE. CITIES THAT
WE WORK IN BUT OVERALL WHAT IS
IT THAT CALIFORNIANS ARE
INTERESTED IN DOING. AND IF WE
CAN FIND IT IN INTERSECTION WE
CAN FIND SOME SWEET PLACES.
WHERE SOME SWEET SPOTS WHERE
LOTS OF MOMENTUM CAN- BE
DEVELOPED. AND SO WE- WERE
PUTTING TOGETHER A TOOL KIT
WHAT WE'RE CALLING CHANGE
PACKAGES FOR EACH OF THESE
PRIORITY IS. THE MENTAL HEALTH
WHAT WE WHAT WE HEARD OVER AND
OVER AGAIN. IS IT'S NOT SO MUCH
THAT PEOPLE WANT THERAPY WHAT
PEOPLE WANT IS COMMUNITY
SUPPORT THIS IS STUFF THAT'S
NOT TERRIBLY EXPENSIVE IT JUST
TAKES ORGANIZING. SUPPORT
GROUPS NONTRADITIONAL
CULTURALLY- RESPONSIVE SUPPORT
FOR WHAT'S GOING ON IN
COMMUNITIES BEFORE THE TRAUMA
HAPPENS IT COULD BE AFTER THE
TRAUMA HAPPENS TO BUT THIS IS
ABOUT PROVIDING. YOUNG PEOPLE
WITH WHAT THEY NEED ALONG.
REALLY CHILD ENRICHMENT
PROGRAMS THIS IS ABOUT HAVING
PROGRAMS IN NEIGHBORHOODS TO
SUPPORT FAMILIES- SUPPORT
PARENTS IN THEIR RELATIONSHIPS
WITH EACH OTHER. AND WITH THEIR
RELATIONSHIP WITH THEIR
CHILDREN. YES EIGHT HOUSE IN
AUSTIN SECURITY WHEN AND I KNOW
THAT YOU ALL THE LEGISLATURE
DOING A LOT BETTER ADDRESS THE
HOUSING ISSUE RESIDENTS ARE
LOOKING FOR THAT TO PUBLIC
SAFETY WHAT WHAT WE HEARD OVER
AND OVER AGAIN IS- SOMETHING
THAT WE TRANSLATED INTO- WHAT
WE HEARD WAS LOOKING AT PUBLIC
SAFETY IS MORE THAN JUST POLICE
AND FIRE WHAT IS IT THAT CAN
HAPPEN IN COMMUNITIES SO THAT
KIDS FEEL SAFE ARE SAFE. AND
HAVE SUPPORT- TO- TO LIVE IN IN
THEIR COMMUNITIES IN A WAY THAT
IS- THAT IS SAFE AND LOOKING AT
THAT FROM A PUBLIC HEALTH
PERSPECTIVE AND ONE OF THE OVER
ARCHING PIEES IS COMMUNITY
ENGAGEMENT AGAIN IS MAKING SURE
THAT RESIDENTS THAT YOUNG
PEOPLE THEMSELVES ARE INVOLVED
IN THE MAKING FOR THE COMMUNITY.
X. WE'RE NOW IN THE PROP. OF TO
WHAT WITH IN THIS CITIES OF THE
CITIES WERE. WORKING WE OUR
THAT WE DID THE GROUPS AND YOU
CAN SEE THE OF SIT OF SEVEN A-
WE GONNA BE FOCUSING ON HIGH
NEED COMMUNITIES LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES COMMITTEES COLOR WE
HAVE THIS DATA NOW THE ACES HOW
WITH WHAT THE ACES. ARE IN
COMMUNITIES WE'RE GONNA BE WORK
WITH THOSE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT THEIR CITY IN EVERY ONE OF
YOUR ASSEMBLY DISTRICTS WHO WHO
WHO ARE TO BE. YES WORK- AND WE
WANT TO AT LEAST TO START WE
WANT TO WORK IN PLACES WHERE
THERE'S POLITICAL WILL AND WHEN
I SAY POLITICAL WILL I DON'T
MEAN JUST THE ELECTED OFFICIALS
I MEAN ELECTED OFFICIALS AND-
RESTED OF CAN. LEADER WILLING
ABLE ATTY TO WORK TOGETHER.
PHASE ONE. THESE YOU ACTUALLY
HAVE A OUR FIRST MEETING OUR
CITY TO TEAM IN TODAY- IN EACH
CITY WERE IDENTIFYING A
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATION
THAT'S GOING TO TAKE THE LEAD
WE HAVE FUNDING- FROM ALL
CHILDREN CALIFORNIA- TO-
PROVIDE GRANTS TO THESE- TO
THESE TEAMS. JAMES CAN BE MADE
OF ADULTS YOUTH CITY LEADER AND
SOMEONE FROM THE COUNTY MENTAL
HEALTH THIS IS MY PASSION OUR
GOAL AGAIN IS WE- CITIES TO BE
OPENED THESE COLD. IT WITH THE
TAP INTO M. A. S. A. MONEY. THE
VALUES THAT THE EQUITY ADVISORY
GROUP CAME UP WITH HIS VALUES
THAT WE WANT- AND THEY WANT IN
FUSE THROUGHOUT THE WORK SO
WE'RE ASKING THOSE DESIGN TEAMS
TO COMMIT TO- THOSE VALUES THEY
CAN ADD TO THE- AS THEY WISH
AND THEN ESTABLISH THIS IS
SOMETHING WE LEARNED FROM OUR
HEALTHY EATING ACTIVE LIVING
CITIES CAMPAIGN THE FIRST
PERSON HE'S- TO BE. UP THE
TRAJECTORY OF CHANGE IS FOR THE
CITIES TO PASS A RESOLUTION
IT'S NOT JUST HAPPY THURSDAY
RESOLUTION IT'S A RESOLUTION
COMMITTING TO VERY SPECIFIC
STEPS TO IDENTIFY AND IMPLEMENT
A CHANGE IN THEIR COMMUNITIES.
NEXT WITH THAT FUNDING AND THE
TEAM IS GONNA CONDUCT LISTENING
SESSIONS TO IDENTIFY THOSE
COMMUNITY PRIORITIES- THE
CITY'S THEN ONCE THOSE
PRIORITIES ARE SET THE CITIES
THAT ARE WORKING ON SIMILAR
PRIORITIES AND BE A PART OF THE
LEARNING COMMUNITY WHERE THEY
GET TO SHARE THEIR IDEAS
RESOURCE AND APPROACH IS AND
THEN THEY BIG TO X. AND
IMPLEMENTED AND EVALUATE WHAT
THEY PUT FORWARD. TIMELINE
HERE'S WHAT'S GOING ON EXT-
DESIGN TEAMS GOING ON RIGHT NOW
IN IN THOSE CITIES. LAUNCH
WEBINARS SUPPORT FOR CITY
LEADERS AND COMMUNITIES AND-
COME JUNE MONEY'S GONNA BE
GOING OUT THE DOOR TO THESE
COMMUNITIES TO HELP THEM BEGIN
DOING THIS WORK. OF LEARNING
NETWORK STARTING EARLY IN
SUMMER WITH THE END GOAL OF ALL
OF THIS IS JUST THE BEGINNING
CITIES IMPLEMENTING PLANS
TWENTY CITIES ADOPTING
RESOLUTION SIXTY CITIES IN
GAUGING ALL CHILDREN THRIVE BY
THE END OF THE THREE YEAR
PERIOD- I WILL SAY FOR THE
PRESENTATION AND DISCUSSIONS
I'VE HAD WITH THE LEAGUE. OF
WHEN THIS. AS THIS STARTS GOING
THERE ARE CITIES ALL OVER THE
PLACE THIS IS A REALLY A TOP
PRIORITY OF ISSUES THAT CITIES
WANT TO WORK IN AND FOR US TO
FOCUS ON PREVENTION TO FOCUS ON
PUBLIC HEALTH STRATEGIES TO
FOCUS ON BRINGING CITIES
TOGETHER CITY LEADERS ELECTED
OFFICIALS AND RESIDENTS
TOGETHER TO CHOOSE THEIR OWN
PRIORITIES TO DEVELOP THE
ECOSYSTEM OF CHANGE. IT'S
IMPORTANT WORK AND I DEEPLY
APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT OF THE-
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE LA ON.
PUBLIC COMMENT ISSUE. TO SEEING
NONE I WILL BRING IT UP TO THE
SUBCOMMITTEE FOR ANY COMMENTS
THAT PEOPLE MAY HAVE FOR
QUESTIONS. SEEING NONE I HAVE A
FEW IF I MAY UM. THE FIRST I
ENJOYED YOUR COMMENT ABOUT AN
OLDER WHITE GENTLEMAN WITH A
NICE. ALTHOUGH I THINK WE MAY
HAVE A DIFFERENT DEFINITION OF
WHAT A NICE TIE THAT'S OKAY. I
DID WANT TO ABOUT WHICH C. AS A
TEAM LEAD YOU WERE- REFERENCING
THAT YOU MET WITH TODAY IN
FRISCO. IT'S A GOOD QUESTION I
DON'T HAVE IT I I'LL I'LL LET
YOU KNOW PERFECT- YOU'D
MENTIONED THAT THERE'S A CITY
RESOLUTION THAT YOU'D LIKE
MULTIPLE CITIES TO PASS. DO YOU
HAVE A PROPOSED RESOLUTION YEAH
SO WHAT WE'RE GOING WHAT WE'RE
WHAT WE HAVE IS A IS A- A MODEL
RESOLUTION THAT THAT RED
RESIDENTS COMMUNITIES THESE
TEAMS ARE GOING TO MODIFY- AS
THEY AS THEY WANT BUT WHAT WE
KNOW FROM. WORKING WITH TWO
HUNDRED AND FIVE CITIES OVER
THE LAST TEN YEARS ON OBESITY
RELATED ISSUES IS A MODEL IS
REALLY HELPFUL SO THEY DON'T
HAVE TO START FROM SCRATCH
THEIR BLANKS IN THERE THEY CAN
PUT THEIR OWN DATA IN THERE.
AND AGAIN THEY CAN THEY CAN
MODIFY IT AS THEY WILL BUT IT'S
ALWAYS HELPFUL TO HAVE A
TEMPLATE. AND YOU MENTIONED
THAT THERE A- OPINION POLL WHEN
YOU'RE NOT THERE IS A- I WOULD
HAVE. IF YOU COULD SHARE THE
ABSOLUTELY ID SO THAT WE COULD
ABSOLUTE ARE TO UNDERSTAND. YEP
IN THEN LOOK AT YOUR IN SAID.
I'M WANT TO REPRESENT THE I. E.
HERE BUT I DIDN'T SEE A CITY
AND ID. AND WE HAVE TO ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS WHO ARE PRESENTING
REGARDING ACES FROM THE I. E.
AND MAY ASK YOU TO. TAKE A
STRONGER LOOK TO SEE IF.
THERE'S A WAY TO COLLABORATE
ABSOLUTELY ABSOLUTELY AND IF
THERE'S A CITY I MEAN THIS IS
REALLY THIS IS THE BEGINNING OF
THE PROCESS IF THERE'S A CITY
THAT YOU KNOW. I WOULD BE
<c.red>NTERESTED IN WORKING WITH US I</c>
WOULD LOVE TO. INCLUDE THEM.
PLEASE THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
CINEMA RAMOS MEMBERS THE IN
EMPIRE SUMMER DINO IT WILL BE
PRESENTING ONE OF THESE ITEMS
FOR LOMA LINDA ON THE CITY OF
LOMA LINDA IN THERE THAT'S
PROVIDING DIFFERENT SERVICES
FOR THE AREA SO HOPEFULLY WE
CAN- TOUCH BASE AND MAKE AN
APPOINTMENT TO FURTHER THE
DISCUSSION GLOBALD OUT BUILT
GIVE YOUR STAFF A CALL WILL BE
BEATEN SAY THANK YOU. WITH THAT
WE WILL ISSUED TO OPEN AND
AGREE WITH YOU DOCTOR. THIS IS
WORK CALL THANKS SO MUCH.
APOLOGIES BUT WE ARE BRIEF
GOING TO ISSUE FOR BECAUSE ONE
OF THE PRISON HAS A FLIGHT TO
CATCH. FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO
WILL BE GIVING COMMENT ON ISSUE
FIVE WE WILL DO THINGS AND
REFERS. AND INSTEAD WILL HAVE
PUBLIC COMMENT FOR ISSUE FIVE
BEFORE WE HAVE THE PRESENTATION
FROM- THE DEPARTMENTS AS WELL
AS OTHERS SO WITH THAT IF WE
COULD HAVE PANEL FOR ISSUE FOR
POLICE. WHEN YOU'RE READY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. THANK YOU
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
COLLEAGUES SOME. I'M HERE TODAY
AS A CHAMPION FOR LOMA LINDA
UNIVERSITY CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL
FOR REQUEST OF SIX MILLION
DOLLARS OVER A THREE YEAR
PERIOD. WHICH IS ALSO SUPPORTED
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLANCA RUBIO.
THE FUNDING IS FOR THREE YEARS
TO FIND A PILOT TRAUMA INFORMED
MODEL PROGRAM. FOR CHILD ABUSE
VICTIMS IN OUR AREA THAT
ENCOMPASSES THE INLAND EMPIRE.
WORKING CLOSELY WITH LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND THE CHILDREN
WELFARE SYSTEM. THE PROGRAM NOW
SERVES CHILDREN THROUGHOUT THE
REGION AND BEYOND INCLUDING THE
COUNTIES OF SALMON YOU KNOW AND
RIVERSIDE. WE ALSO CONTINUE TO
WORK ON THE PROPOSALS THE
PRESIDENT'S PROPOSAL WILL FUND
AN EXPANSION OF SERVICES THERE
ARE MULTIPLE MULTI DISCIPLINARY
IT WILL HELP ENSURE THAT THE
SUFFERING. AND VIOLENCE THAT
THESE CHILDREN HAVE ENTERED DO
NOT DEFINE THEIR FUTURE.
DECEMBER DINO ALONE. ALTHOUGH
REPORT REPORTED CASES OF CHILD
ABUSE NUMBER APPROXIMATELY A
HUNDRED THOUSAND CHILDREN ONLY
A NARROW SUBSET OF THOSE
CHILDREN THE MOST SERIOUS CASES
ARE REFERRED TO THE SALMON YOU
KNOW COUNTY CHILDREN'S ADVOCACY
CENTER. THOSE ARE CASES OF
RECENT SEXUAL ABUSE AND SEXUAL
ASSAULT OR SPECIFIC INJURIES
SUCH AS BRUISES AND BURNS HERE
WITH ME TODAY. IS DOCTOR AMY
YOUNG SNODGRASS. DIVISION CHIEF
OF THE CHILDREN'S PEDIATRICS
FOR LOMA LINDA UNIVERSITY
CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL. THANK YOU.
I FEEL SO LUCKY TO BE ON NOT ON
SORRY. STERN NOW I AM A KNOW.
THERE I FEEL SO TO BE HERE
TODAY AS A PHYSICIAN MOSTLY
WORKING IN THE TRENCH I AM ONE
OF ONLY LESS THAN FOUR HUNDRED
PHYSICIANS BOARD CERTIFIED IN
CHILD ABUSE PEDIATRICS ACROSS
THE NATION- I'M REALLY IN AWE
TO SEE WHAT'S BEING DONE AT
THIS LEVEL TO TAKE CARE OFTHE
MOST VULNERABLE CHILDREN IN OUR
COMMUNITY. I WILL KEEP THIS TO
ST- I HAVE BEEN A CHILD ABUSE
PHYSICIAN AT LOMA LINDA
UNIVERSITY CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL
FOR OVER FIFTEEN YEARS. AND
I'VE TREATED MORE THAN TEN
THOUSAND VICTIMS OF CHILD ABUSE
AND NEGLECT I AM HERE WITH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RAMOS AND WITH
THE SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RUBIO TO PROPOSE A PILOT
PROGRAM TO DEVELOP A TRAUMA
INFORMED MEDICAL HOME MODEL FOR
ABUSED AND NEGLECTED CHILDREN
IN THE INLAND EMPIRE WHICH IS
THE PLACE I WAS BORN AND RAISED.
THIS PROPOSAL COMES IN GREAT
PART DUE TO MY EXPERIENCES IN
THIS FIELD. NOT LONG AGO I WAS
CALLED TO THE BEDSIDE OF A
CRITICALLY INJURED CHILD A BABY
WHO HAD SUFFERED MULTIPLE
MODALITIES OF INJURY THAT WERE
SUSPICIOUS AND UNEXPLAINED. I
MET WITH THE FATHER AS I
NORMALLY DO TOGETHER HISTORY.
DURING THE HISTORY TAKING IN
ALL TALKING ABOUT HIS BABY'S
INJURIES THE FATHER ENDED UP
TELLING ME THAT AS A CHILD HE
HAD BEEN IN MORE FOSTER HOMES
THAN HE COULD REMEMBER. HE
SUFFERED ABUSE IN FOSTER CARE
AND THROUGHOUT HIS CHILDHOOD.
REPORTED TO ME THAT HE SAW
THERAPISTS AND CONSISTENTLY AND
HAD MANY UNMET MEDICAL NEEDS.
WHEN HE TURNED EIGHTEEN HE WAS
TIRED OF BEING A FOSTER YOUTH
HE LEFT THE SYSTEM BECAME
HOMELESS AND THEN BECAME A
FATHER. WHEN I SAT WITH HIM
SOMETHING WAS VERY FAMILIAR TO
ME. HE EVENTUALLY TOLD ME ABOUT
THE CIRCUMSTANCES THAT LED HIM
TO FOSTER CARE IN THE FIRST
PLACE. IN THE MOMENTS THAT
CHANGED MY LIFE HE SHOWED ME
SCARS ON HIS HANDS FROM ABUSE.
AND THAT'S WHEN I REMEMBERED.
HE WAS FAMILIAR BECAUSE I WAS
THE PHYSICIAN WHO MADE THE
DIAGNOSIS OF ABUSE WHEN HE WAS
A LITTLE BOY. DESPITE TAKING
EVERY ACTION THAT I KNEW TO
HELP HIM AND TO BREAK THE
CYCLES OF ABUSE I WAS NOW THERE
TO WATCH AS HE WAS ARRESTED FOR
FATAL INJURIES THAT HE CAUGHT
CHILD. THIS STORY IS NOT
UNUSUAL OR RARE. CHILD ABUSE IS
A PERVASIVE PREVALENT DISEASE
PROCESS AMONG OUR CHILDREN.
WHEN I HEARD DOCTOR BURKE KERRY
SPEAK SEVERAL YEARS AGO MY
WORLD WAS ROCKED SHE QUOTED A
FELLOW CHILD ABUSE PHYSICIAN
WHO SAID THAT ADVERSE CHILDHOOD
EXPERIENCES ARE THE SINGLE
GREATEST UNADDRESSED PUBLIC
HEALTH THREAT FACING OUR NATION
TODAY. SHE TOOK MY WORK OUT OF
THE DARK CORNERS OF MEDICINE
AND TOLD THE NATION THAT WE ARE
SICK IN PART BECAUSE WE DOT DO
NOT DO ENOUGH TO TAKE CARE OF
CHILDREN WHO HAVE SUFFERED
ABUSE AND NEGLECT. PHYSICIANS
ARE NOW TALKING ABOUT ACES AND
LEARNING HOW TO ASK DIFFICULT
QUESTIONS. WE HAVE NOT
HISTORICALLY BEEN TAUGHT THIS
IN OUR TRAINING. THE SYSTEMS IN
PLACE NOW ARE NOT ENOUGH. THEY
DO NOT SUPPORT THE TIME AND
RELATIONSHIP BUILDING THAT IS
REQUIRED TO DELIVER TRAUMA
INFOMED TO MEDICAL CARE. OR
THE TREATMENT TEAMS NEEDED TO
MEET A CHILD'S SPECIAL NEEDS.
MEDICAL CARE AND MENTAL HEALTH
SYSTEMS EXIST IN SILOS. DECADES
AGO WE PARTNERED WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT AT LIMóN TO
HOSPITAL WITH CHILD WELFARE
PUBLIC HEALTH THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE AND MENTAL
HEALTH PROVIDERS. TO CREATE AN
ADVOCACY CENTER FOR CHILD ABUSE
VICTIMS AND SAMPOERNA DINO. WE
TREAT THE MOST EGREGIOUS OF
CASES. APPROXIMATELY OVER TWO
THOUSAND PER YEAR. THE MULTI
DISCIPLINARY TREATMENT TEAM
PROVIDES COORDINATED BUT
LIMITED AND SHORT TERM FORENSIC
MEDICAL CARE AND MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES AND IS ONLY AVAILABLE
TO CASES READ BY AN
INVESTIGATIVE AGENCY. BUILDING
UPON THIS WE ARE WE ARE
PROPOSING AN EXPANDED PROGRAM
THAT WILL PROVIDE RESILIENCY
INFORMED ONGOING MEDICAL CARE
TARGETING THE SECOND LARGEST
POPULATION OF FOSTER YOUTH AND
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. THE
CLINICAL ENGAGE CARE GIVERS AND
PROVIDE HOLISTIC CARE
CONSISTING OF MEDICAL AND
MENTAL HEALTH DEVELOPMENT
DENTAL CARE NUTRITION ALLIED
HEALTH AND EDUCATIONAL ADVOCACY
WHICH INCLUDES MEANT AND PRE
COLLEGE READINESS AND
SCHOLARSHIP FOR CHILDREN AT
RISK THIS INCLUDES HOMELESS
YOUTH CHILDREN OF INCARCERATED
PARENTS AND FOSTER YOUTH. I'LL
TRADE PROVIDERS TAKES A PLAN
EARNERS ON THIS AND SYMPTOMS OF
ABUSE INCLUDING WAYS TO ACTS
AND DELIVER TO AND CARE. I'M
NOT AFRAID TO A THAT I CAN DO
MORE I KNOW THAT WE ALL CAN DO
MORE AND WHILE IT IS HARD TO
TALK ABOUT CHILD ABUSE MANY
PEOPLE DO NOT WANT TO BECAUSE
THEY FEEL POWERLESS TO DO
ANYTHING ABOUT IT. BUT NOT FOR
YOU AND NOT MYSELF. WE HAVE THE
POWER TO DO TO MAKE CHANGE
THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU
DOCTOR. WITH THAT WE WILL HEAR
PUBLIC COMMENT ON ISSUE FOR.
SEEING NONE WE WILL BRING IT UP
TO THE SUBCOMMITTEE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER REVIEWS. THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
PRESENTATION- OF. WE ARE THE
NEIGHBORS TO THE WEST AND-
LINDA DOES A LOT OF WORK IN MY
AREA AS WELL AND THAT'S WHY I
WAS- WANTING TO PARTICIPATE IN
THIS ASK AND I ALSO HAVE A
REALLY GOOD RELATIONSHIP WITH
THE CHILDREN ADVOCACY CENTER.
NOT THAT A LOT OF WORK AND- I
COLUMN YOU KNOW MY BECAUSE MY
LOCAL CAUSES ANYTHING THAT I
CAN DO FOR THEM- I TRY TO DO.
BYE BUT WITH YOUR HELP I KNOW
THAT YOUR- THIS PROGRAM WILL
REACH ALL THE WAY TO THE WEST
TO AND TO MY AREA TO THE
FOURTEENTH ASSEMBLY DISTRICT
WHICH IS IN. WEST COVINA AREA-
BUT I WANTED TO MAKE SURE THAT
THAT THE COMMITTEE NEW AS WELL
THAT YES IT'S AN PASSED FOR THE
LIFT UP A LIMóN IN STRETCHES
ALL THE WAY. TO PARK AND- IN
BURKE AND APPRECIATE ALL THE
WORK FOR OUR ALL CHILL THAT
BECAUSE HE CENTERS OF THE STATE
BECAUSE I HOWTO. THAT THE YOU
KNOW HAVING TO BE WITH THAT
HAVE TO BE I A T. AND I ONLY
GOT TO SEE A GLOWING OF THE-
THAT I KNOW THAT YOU GUYS FACE
EVERY DAY SO THANK YOU YOUR
WORK AS WELL AND TO THE KNOW MY
FRIENDS OUT IN TILT ABBOTT
CENTER ARENA YOU FOR WHAT YOU
DO THANK YOU SOMETHING. WITH
THAT IN. DOCTOR I TO YOU SO THE
DOCTOR BURKE TERRACE ROCK TO
WITH HER. TO A FEW AGO AND I
ACTUALLY SHE'S GETTING BETTER.
TIME AND- HER ROLE NOW BUT BUT
DO. THAT OFTEN TO OUR SYSTEM
NEED TO BE IN. AND TRAUMA
BECAUSE- YEAH SO HOW WE CAN
HELP TO MAKE SURE THIS MODEL IS
THE BEST MODEL WE CAN USE I
WOULD JUST ASK MUCH LIKE I
ASKED ASSEMBLYMEMBER GARCIA TO
TRY TO WORK WITH YOU SEE LA IN
THE ALL CHILDREN THRIVE AS WELL
AS THE SURGEON GENERAL. TO MAKE
SURE WERE HAVING A
COLLABORATIVE APPROACH THAT
DOES REGIONAL HEALTH REGARDING
ACES SO THAT WE CAN BE
EFFICIENT WITH OUR DOLLARS AS
WELL I AGREE YES WITH THAT WE
WILL HOLD ISSUE FOR OPEN THANK
YOU FOR THE PRESENTATION AND-
THANK YOU MISS A LOT OF
CATCHING YOUR FLIGHT. WITH THAT
WE WILL NOW A FOR. I WILL FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT IN. PREVIOUS TO
HEARING FROM THE PANELISTS
BECAUSE MY UNDERSTANDING IS
THERE'S A FAIR AMOUNT OF PEOPLE
WHO WOULD LIKE TO HAVE A SAY.
SO WITH THAT PUBLIC COMMENT FOR
ISSUE FIVE. MY UNDERSTANDING IS
THERE ARE SOME PEOPLE WHO NEED
TO LEAVE. QUICKLY IF THOSE
PEOPLE CAN. GO EARLIER IN LINE
THAT WOULD BE APPRECIATED JUST
SO THAT THEY MAY- CATCH THEIR
TRANSPORTATION AS WELL.
YEAH.
OKAY. HI THERE SORRY YEAH MEAN
PILOT ON OF HELL ACCESS. WE'RE
HERE IN SOME OF THE CONS IN THE
GOAL OF THE GUY PER OFF OF
HEALTH FOR TO. HEALTHCARE IS.
CRUSHING CONSUMERS AND WORK AND
CAL AND WE ARE PLEASED THE
GOVERNOR FOR. AND LOOKS TO
REVIEW THE TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE AND WORKING WITH THE
LEGISLATURE AND AN
ADMINISTRATION ON THE PROPOSED
OFFICE OF HEALTH CARE
AFFORDABILITY THANK YOU THANK
YOU MA'AM. HI GOOD AFTERNOON
ENTER KEY FOR WITH BLUE SHIELD
OF CALIFORNIA AND- STAND HERE
IN SUPPORT OF- THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL TO CREATE THE OFFICE
OF HEALTH CARE AFFORDABILITY- I
THINK YOU NEED TO GO NO FURTHER
THAN PAGE EIGHTEEN OF THE STAFF
ANALYSIS WERE TALKING ABOUT
THAT. DISPARITIES BETWEEN WAGE
GROWTH AND THE COST OF
HEALTHCARE. AND THE STUNNING
FIGURE THAT- ACOSTA HEALTH CARE
FOR HER FAMILY. I AM
CALIFORNIA'S NEAR TWENTY TWO
THOUSAND DOLLARS- WE AS A
COMPANY HAVE BEEN IMMENSELY
INTERESTED IN FOCUSED ON TRYING
TO BREAK THIS TREND. ALTHOUGH
WE CAN'T DO IT ALONE AND WE ARE
HEARTENED THAT THE GOVERNOR AND
IN PARTICULAR THIS LEGISLATURE
HAS FOCUSED ON THIS OVER THE
YEARS AND THROUGH THIS SO. FOR
I THINK WE'LL TAKE. I
FUNDAMENTAL STEP FOR MAKING
HELLO SYSTEM THAT THE FAN AND
FRIENDS IN SUSTAINABLE
AFFORDABLE WITH FOR TO WORK
WITH THIS CAN. AND THE GUY OFF
AND THANK YOU. FOR YOUR TIME
TODAY. THANK YOU SIR. KELLY BE
MEMBER HAVE OF THE CAL MEDICAL
SO WE ARE SO. IN CONCEPT OF THE
GOVERNOR PROPOSAL TO OF FORTY
FOR HOW CARE CAN. INCLUDING
ADDRESSING UNDERLYING COST
DRIVERS LIKE DELIVERY SYSTEM
CONSOLIDATION. THE STATE KNOWS
WE MUST DO MORE TO PROMOTE
PROMOTE INNOVATION REDUCE WASTE
AND ALLEVIATE ADMINISTRATIVE
BURDENS ON PHYSICIANS AND OTHER
HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS. SEE ME IS
COMMITTED TO HELPING FINDING
WORKABLE SOLUTIONS THAT SERVE
PATIENTS AND ENABLE PHYSICIANS
TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC HEALTH
AND EXPAND ACCESS TO AFFORDABLE
HEALTHCARE. WE LOOK FOR TO THE
DISCUSSIONS DURING THE BUDGET
PROCESS WITH YOU ALL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MA'AM AND IF I CAN
AGAIN JUST HAVE THOSE WHO NEED
TO LEAVE BEFORE THREE THIRTY.
STEP UP TO THE MIKE SO THAT WE
MAY BE ABLE TO GET YOU- WHERE
YOU NEED TO GO. HELLO I'M YOUR
LONG IF YOU WANT TO. AND READ
AS YOU. I WAS ALSO PRESIDENT
FOR THE SCO NOW I AM OF ON FOR
UNITED HEALTHCARE WORKERS
COMMUNITY LATER AND I AM IN
SUPPORT. OF NUMBER FIVE I
STRONGLY IT I'M A MODERATE INK
WE TO. AND ALL I CAN SAY IS I
KEEP A WITH THE HIGH COST
BECAUSE I CHRONICALLY ILL AND
AT PEAK EXIST CONDITION AND
WITHOUT THE SUPPORT OF. AND
SENATOR STYLE I WOULD HAVE BEEN
HOMELESS SO TO THOSE TWO AND
COST AS QUOTE AMADA INCOME NOW
AS I HAVE TO PAY. I FEEL LIKE
I'M BEING PAN BECAUSE I NOT HI
INCOME I'M POOR SOUL AS MY
INCOME IN THE BABY BOOM AS A IN
A LONGER OTHERS WE ARE FEELING
THE CRUNCH OF THE HIGH COST OF
CARE AND PRESCRIPTION DRUGS I
SUPPORT STRONGLY FOR FIVE.
THANK YOU MA'AM. GOOD OUT MY
NAME IS JEFF TAYLOR ON HEALTH
CARE WORKER AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT FIVE OFFICE OF HEALTH
CARE AFFORDABILITY THANK YOU
SIR. THE SON OF ASHER SCA HILL-
HEALTH CARE WORKER I SUPPORT
FIVE. THANK YOU MA'AM. HELLO MY
CHAU CHRIS I'M IN SUPPORT OF
PROP FIVE SEIU HEALTH CARE
WORKER THANK YOU MA'AM. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS KIM SAM
YELL AND I AM A HEALTHCARE
WORKER FOR THE PAST TWENTY FIVE
YEARS AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT
FIVE THANK YOU MA'AM. HI ON
OAKWOOD GROVER AND HEALTHCARE
WORKER ITEMS. FIVE THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME'S FOR HELENA SUPPORT
OF GOVERNOR'S. PROPOSED TO MAKE
HEALTH CARE OF. I BEEN A NURSE
FOR THE LAST TWENTY AND LIKE A
TO SEE IF FIRST. PATIENTS
COMING IN WHERE YOU ASK WHY
HAVE THEY TAKEN SO LONG TO COME
IN BECAUSE THEY CAN'T AFFORD IT
PREVENTION WORKS AND WHAT COULD
HAVE TAKEN THREE DAYS TO HEAL
COULD NOW TAKE THREE MONTHS
BECAUSE THEY CAN'T AFFORD
INSURANCE SO I'M IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF FIVE. THANK YOU
MA'AM. MY NAME IS DEVIN COOPER
AND I WORK FOR GREAT IN RESORT
AND CASINO AND I'M WITH LOCAL
FORTY NINE. MY NAME IS GINA
LONG AGO I'M THE SECRETARY
TREASURER FOR LOCAL FORTY NINE
WITHUNITE HERE. AND WE ARE
SUPPORT OF THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE OF HEALTH CARE. FOR THE-
AND THE COST I'M SORRY THE
STRICT COST TARGETS. THANK YOU
MA'AM. HI MY NAME IS NOT MAGGIE
LARA BUT YET. OF UNION MEMBER
AND A HELP WORK WORKER AND WE
ARE HERE FOR THE RECENT SUPPORT
THE HOUSE OF. HEALTHCARE FOR
BECAUSE THE MIDDLE IN. CLASS
GETTING CRASH WHAT HI BECAUSE
IN COLOR. THANK YOU THANK YOU.
HELLO NANCY NOVAK IRAN AND I'M
HERE IN SUPPORT OF FIVE I'VE
BEEN IN MENTAL HEALTH AS IN
IRAN FOR OVER THIRTY YEARS AND
I'VE SEEN WHAT THE INCREDIBLE
COST OF HEALTH CARE IS DONE TO
ARE MENTALLY ILL- I ALSO WOULD
LIKE TO ADVOCATE FOR
TRANSPARENCY IN THE BILL
BECAUSE I THINK ESPECIALLY
WORKING FOR COUNTIES OVER
THIRTY YEARS. THAT THAT'S
SOMETHING WHEN YOU DON'T HAVE
THAT YOU CAN'T COLLECT DATA AND
THEN YOU CAN'T FIGURE OUT WHERE
CAN WE BE MORE EFFICIENT AND
WHERE CAN WE MAKE THE SYSTEM
BETTER. AND IT TAKES SORT OF
KIND OF A VILLAGE AND NOT A BIG
VILLAGE BUT A LITTLE VILLAGE TO
FIGURE OUT HOW CAN WE MAKE THIS
SYSTEM BETTER AND WHERE IS ALL
THE MONEY GOING TO SO I
DEFINITELY ADVOCATE OR
TRANSPARENCY AND ALSO FOR FINES
FOR COMPANY THAT ARE. KINK IT'S
LIKE USING MEDI SEND OUR MAYBE
DOING SO WITH ME THAT THEY
SHOULDN'T BE DOING SO THANK YOU
AND I'D ANSWER OF THE OP OF
HEALTH CARE. THANK YOU. MY NAME
IS TINA ELEMENT TO IN ALSO A
TALE AND DO SO PROP. THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS SEVEN THREE HE TO
SUIT GO OVER OFF AFFORDABLE.
THANK YOU MA'AM HI MY IS JOANNE
DEAL LIKE WHAT FOR MARRIAGE
WELL SO ARE IT'S A SOME. FOR
THIRTEEN IRIS LATEST SPOT SO
FIVE. HELLO SENATE OF MY NAME'S
CATHY WHO LOOK TO ALL. A SHE-
ON THE ARE YOU YOU ALL
ORGANIZER SORRY I'M LATE BUT
NERVOUS FOR ALL THE YOU GUYS
YEAH BECAUSE- BECAUSE YOU KNOW
WHAT YOU GUYS. WHERE WE TOP
POWER OVER YOU GUYS CHANGE. FOR
OUR A FOR HEALTH OKAY SO ON
HERE AND ALL OUR MEMBER HERE WE
SHOULD YOU CAN SUPPORT THE
GOVERNOR BUDGET PROPOSE FOR THE
OFFICE ALL. THE FOR HEALTHCARE
PLEASE WE NEED YOU. THANK YOU
MA'AM YOU DID GREAT. BECAUSE
O'RYAN AND RIGHT NOW IT IS OUR
TOP PRIORITY THANK YOU THANK
YOU SIR. GOOD AFTERNOON I'M
MARIANNE BRENNER. I WORK AS
CATERING AIRLINE GATE GOURMET
FOR THREE YEARS. AND I SUPPORT.
THE GOVERNMENT BUDGET FOR THE
HEALTH CARE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MA'AM. GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAY ROSELLI JANA I WORK IN A
GAY GOVERNMENT CONFERENCE HE'S
CALL FOR TWENTY ALMOST TWENTY
THREE YEARS. AND I CAN GET FOR
SUPPORT TO THE GOVERNMENT BACK
IN FULL FORCE ON. THANK YOU
THANK YOU. HI MY NAME'S RIZZO
FELL I'VE BEEN A MEMBER OF YOU
KNOW YOUR LOCAL TO IN SAN
FRANCISCO FOR THREE YEARS AND
AM HERE TO VOICE SUPPORT FOR-
THE GOVERNOR'S- OFFICE OF
AFFORDABILITY. THANK YOU. WHEN
I STARTED THIS MY NUMBER IS THE%
LEAST VIA- YOSHI BUT HE AND
THEY SHOWED ME UMBRELLA THEY
LOCAL SHE SAID THAT I SAID
WOULD. YOUR MOTHER TO SIGN A
LEASE YOUR UP ALL YOUR LAW
OFFICE YOU KNOW THAT A FELLOW
OF. GRASS IS NO. WHEN I THOUGHT
MY NUMBER AT LEAST HERE THESES
ALRIGHT MAN BUT I. INTO THE
YEP FOR YOUR- FEES ENOUGH I
LESSEN CLASSIC. GROWTH ON THE-
WHEN I BETTER THEN THE NUMBER
I'M NOT THE NET SO BUT SEE IN
THE- IS SO EASY. SLEEP BUT THE
IN THAT YOU SAY ME. ALL DAY
LONG WOMEN TO DRIVE A LOT I
LIEU YEP WELL YOU'LL- WITH
OTHER GOING. I'M GOING TO GO IN
NEW SO. COULD I IF. NECESSARY
GOOD I. MY AS I. ONLY I WORK ON
THEIR OWN. SELF I WORKING FOR
YEARS ON MEMBER LOOK. TO I. AYE
WE SO. THE GOAL. A PROPOSAL
DOLPH. OF THEIR HEALTHCARE. AND
UP OF A DOUBLE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SIR. COULD HAVE FOR
THE ROOM. EVERYONE MY DO YOU
SEE YOU ARE I WILL BECAUSE IN
THE PALACE HOTEL ALMOST TWENTY
YEARS I'M THE MAN BOTH LOCAL
TOOL. I SUPPORT GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE OF AFFORDABLE HE DID HE
THANK YOU THANK YOU MA'AM.
HELLO MY NAME IS A HOLY ROLLERS
AND I'M I'M WITH THEIR LOCAL
FORTY NINE UNITED HERE. YEAH
IT'S A COLLISION- THAT
SUPPORTS- THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL FOR- TO GRADE- BUT
OFFICE FOR HEALTH CARE OF
AFFORDABILITY. AND OUR ORDER
THE USER SUPPORT TO UP. TO HELP
US- PASSED. WITH GOVERNOR-
PROPOSAL TO GREATER HEALTH CARE
OF AFFORDABILITY. THANK YOU
THANK YOU FOR. GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME IS SERRA PEARSON I'M A
BARTENDER AT CASH BECAUSE IN A
RESORT I'VE BEEN A MEMBER OF
THE NIGHT HERE LOCAL FORTY NINE
FOR FOUR YEARS AND I SUPPORT
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF HEALTH
CARE AFFORDABILITY. THANK YOU
MA'AM. BRETT MARTINEZ WITH THE
CASH YOU CAN LOCAL FORTY NINE
FOR ABOUT THREE YEARS AND WE'RE
HERE FORCING OUR SUPPORT FOR-
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF-
HEALTH CARE AFFORDABILITY.
THANK YOU SIR. MY NAME'S
ADDRESS I'VE WORKED AT THE
GREAT RESORT CASINO IN OUR PARK
FOR TWO YEARS I'M HERE AS A
MEMBER FO THE UNITE HERE LOCAL
FORTY NINE UNION IN SUPPORT OF
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF HEALTH
CARE AFFORDABILITY. WITH STRICT
CROSS TARGETS. THANK YOU. HI
MARIA VASQUEZ. RECORD GRAIN
RESTORING THE SCENE NOW WITH
LOCAL FORTY NINE. AM HERE TO
SUPPORT GOVERNOR OFFICE OF HELP
QUITE A FAILED PART ABILITY
WITH STRICT. TARGET COST THANK
YOU MA'AM. HELLO MY NAME IS
STEPHANIE BANG- I'VE WORKED AT
THE VALLEY FOR FIVE YEARS I
REMEMBER THE NIGHT HERE LOCAL
FORTY NINE- IN IN SUPPORT OF.
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF
HEALTHCARE FOR EVERYBODY THANK
YOU MA'AM. HI MY NAME IS STILL
SENATE THE PM WOULD UNITE HERE
LOCAL FORTY NINE BEEN THERE FOR
TEN YEARS I'M HERE TO SUPPORT
THE GOVERNOR OFFICER OF
HEALTHCARE A FOR DVD WITH
STRICT COST TARGETS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MA'AM. MY NAME IS
NINA A BARTENDER THUNDER VALLEY
AND A MEMBER OF LOCAL FORTY
NINE FOR FOUR YEARS AND I'M
HERE. TO SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE OF HEALTH CARE
AFFORDABILITY WITH STRICT COST
TARGETS. THANK YOU. HI MY
NAME'S PLUS THE COLLEAGUES
THROW I'M A MEMBER OF LOCAL
FORTY NINE BEEN THERE FOR ABOUT
THREE YEARS- IN SUPPORT OF THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF HEALTH
CARE AFFORDABILITY. WAS
STRAIGHT COST TARGETS THANK YOU
THANK YOU SIR. MY NAME IS JOYCE
EIGHT GEORGE- YES YEAH I YOU
COMMUNITY ACTION LEADER. ONE
NINE FIVE EIGHT THREE EIGHT IN-
LIKE ASKING THE GOVERNOR
GOVERNOR. GAVIN TO SUPPORT
STRONGLY SUPPORT THE IDEAL- OF
AN OFFICE OF HEALTH CARE
BOARDED BILLY DEE HEALTH CARE
CALLS- ARE TOO HIGH IN TO KEEP
GETTING HIGH AND KEEP GETTING
HIGHER BUT IS IT THIS IS TRULY
IMPORTANT THAT WE GET THEM THIS
RIGHTS. AND THAT THE OFFICE IS
ACCOUNTABLE TO THE PUBLIC TO
YOU U. S. NOT TO THE
CORPORATIONS AND INDUSTRY IN
TRUTH- SEIU MEMBERS ARE
COMMITTED TO THE OFICE THAT IS
TRANSPARENT AND ACCOUNTABLE TO
THE PUBLIC THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU MY NAME JOIN. THE
MAIN NUMBER IS POWER LIKE OUT
OF THE U. OF ANGLE THEM WHILE
THEY'RE STILL YEP FOR YOUR UP
WITH A LITTLE BIT LOWER BUT I
READ LO FI CENA FOR LESS I LOW.
CRISIS. WELL I WOULD HAVE
THOUGHT OF THIS WILLIAM VOTER
BY THE HAVING OTHER WHILE THEY
STILL YEAH FOR YOUR LOVE FOR
FIRST TIME TO GO IT ALONE. YOUR
ADDRESSES. WHEN I STARTED
LISTENING A LITTLE SOMEBODY
ELSE HOLINESS IS ONE MEMBER OF
THE- THERE WAS THE SURPLUS I
LOSE EVEN WITH A MODEST THOUGHT
YEAH BUT- YOUKNOW I LEGAL THAT
MY LOTUS A LITTLE PLACE THAT
WHICH ADDRESS YES. CRISIS IN
YOUR. BENJAMIN TRYING ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA PAN ETHNIC
HEALTH NETWORK- IN SUPPORT OF
THE CREATION OF THE OFFICE AND
WOOD EMPHASIZED THE NEED TO
KEEP. EQUITY AND QUALITY
STANDARDS HIGH AS WE- LOOK TO
MAKE HEALTHCARE MORE AFFORDABLE
THANK YOU SIR. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR MEMBERS LINDA WAY WITH
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY WE SUPPORT THE EFFORTS
TO MONITOR AND CONTAIN COSTS
WHICH IMPACT THE OVERALL AS
WELL AS THE MEDI CAL BUDGET WE
KNOW THAT RISING HEALTH CARE
COSTS DEEPER IT DEPRESSES
WORKERS WAGES PARTICULARLY
HAVING. A NEGATIVE IMPACT ON
LOW INCOME WORKERS AND FINALLY
WE KNOW THAT AFFORDABILITY
REMAINS TO BE AN ISSUE THANK
YOU THANK YOU. MR TURN MEMBERS
OF AN **** KICKING ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF
FAMILY PHYSICIANS REALLY
APPRECIATE THE GOVERNOR AND THE
LEGISLATURE'S ATTENTION TO THIS
DISCUSSION ON AFFORDABILITY AND
WE ARE SUPPORT OF THIS CONCEPT.
ALL TOO OFTEN OUR PATIENTS HAVE
TO FACE A DECISION BETWEEN
TREATMENT MEDICATION AND GROSS
REASON THAT'S PATENTLY
UNACCEPTABLE WE HOPE THAT SOME
OF THE INNOVATIVE MODELS THAT
WE HAVE LOOKED AT WITH PATIENT
CENTERED MEDICAL HOMES AND
FRESNO. MIGHT BE A PART OF THIS
CONVERSATION WE LOOK FOR THAT
PROCESS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MA'AM. GOOD AFTERNOON CATHERINE
SCOUT THE CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION. WE ARE SUPPORTER
OF THE CONCEPT OF THE OFFICE OF
HEALTH CARE AFFORDABILITY IN
THE WORK. THAT WE NEED TO DO-
TO GET US THERE. I THINK OUR
OUR THOUGHTS ON THIS ARE A
COUPLE OF FOLD- WE ARE AGAIN
COMMITTED TO THIS WORK BUT AS
WE LOOK AT IT WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE WE'RE LOOKING OUT- THE
DETAILS RELATED TO THE WORK- SO
THAT WE CAN UNDERSTAND. HOW WE
CAN PUT THE PIECES TOGETHER-
HANDS. REALLY UNDERSTANDS THE
CONSEQUENCES OF THOSE PIECES AS
THEY COME TOGETHER FOR OUR
PROVIDERS IN ALL OF OUR
COMMUNITIES- IT'S. WE AS WE AS
WE ATTEMPT TO LOOK AT
AFFORDABILITY WE NEED TO MEET
THE MEET MEET THE HEALTHCARE
NEEDS OF THE FORTY MILLION
CALIFORNIANS SO FOR US WE LOOK
AT THIS AS WORK THAT IS GOING
TO CHANGE THE WAY WE DO
HEALTHCARE IN CALIFORNIA SO FOR
US THIS S BIG WORK. WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT AS WE DO IT
WE'RE THOUGHTFUL ABOUT THE
DIFFERENT PIECES AND HEALTH
CARE- AND HOW THEY COINCIDE
TOGETHER IN ORDER TO REALLY
MAKE SURE THAT THE
AFFORDABILITY IS AND THE COST
SAVING THAT SHE WOULD GETS TO
THE CONSUMER SO WE LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE THE LEGISLATURE. TO
REALLY MAKE SURE THAT ALL OF
THOSE PIECES WORK TOGETHER- SO
THAT IT'S NOT JEOPARDIZING
ACCESS IT'S MAINTAINING AND
GETTING TO A GROWTH TARGET TO
ADDRESS AFFORDABILITY- AND FOR
US GETTING TO THE CONSUMER WE
APPRECIATE THE CONSUMERS
CONCERNS AND WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT THIS- AND ALL PROPOSALS
ADDRESS THOSE ISSUES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MA'AM. THANK YOU
MAYOR MARTIN HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA CHILDREN'S
HOSPITAL SAY STATION I WOULD
ALIGN MYSELF WITH THE COMMENTS
OF MY COLLEAGUE AT THE
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION. IS THAT WE ARE
SUPPORTIVE OF THIS AND CONCEPT
WERE VERY AWARE OF THE IMPACT
AFFORDABILITY HAS ON OUR
FAMILIES AND THE ABILITY OF
THEM AND THEIR CHILDREN TO
ACCESS CARE- AND WE WOULD JUST
AND WE KNOW THIS IS THE
BEGINNING OF TE CONVERSATION
WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
EVERYONE TO COME TO THE RIGHT
SOLUTION I WOULD JUST URGE YOU
TO KEEP IN MIND THAT AS WE MOVE
AHEAD WITH. A SOLUTION THAT
USES GROWTH TARGETS WHICH WE
THINK YOU KNOW MAYBE THE RIGHT
SOLUTION WE WANT TO BE CAREFUL
NOT TO INADVERTENTLY CREATE
DISINCENTIVES TO INVEST IN NEW
AND GROWING PROGRAMS LIKE
MENTAL HEALTH FOR WE HAVE A
GROWING NEED. WE DON'T WANT TO
HAVE A HOSPITAL BE PENALIZED
FOR EXPANDING THE SERVICES THEY
OFFER IN THAT AREA. AND WE ALSO
WANT TO WATCH AS A
REPRESENTATIVE OF TERTIARY
CENTERS. THAT WE DON'T CREATE
INCENTIVES FOR COMMUNITY
HOSPITALS FOR EXAMPLE TO CUT
SERVICE LINES THAT DON'T MAKE A
LOT OF PROFIT OR THAT ARE
REALLY COSTS CENTRIC. AND THEN
HAVE CHILDREN'S HOSPITALS AND
OTHER TERTIARY PROVIDERS LIKE
ACADEMIC MEDICAL CENTERS BECOME
IMPACTED BECAUSE ALL THOSE
PATIENTS COME TO THE CENTER SO
THESE ARE. JUST MANY THINGS
THAT WILL HAVE TO BE MINDFUL OF
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
PARTNERING WITH YOU ALL TO.
ADDRESS THIS AFFORDABILITY
SITUATION THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MA'AM. MISTER MEMBERS OF THE
SUBCOMMITTEE MY NAME IS BRIAN
NELSON ON BEHALF OF THE MORE-
NEARLY ONE HUNDRED EIGHTY
THOUSAND MEMBERS ASKED ME
CALIFORNIA- WE ARE PROBABLY
SUPPORTIVE OF THE CONCEPT
BEHIND- THE ESTABLISHMENT
OFFICE OF. HEALTH CARE
AFFORDABILITY. WE THINK IS
CRUCIAL- THAT WE DO TAKE MORE
STEPS AS A STATE TO CONTROL THE
COST OF HEALTHCARE WE KNOW THIS
GROWING AS YOU'VE HEARD- IN
GREAT DETAIL HERE- WE ALSO KNOW
THAT WORKERS WHEN THEY COME TO
THE TABLE BOTH IN THE PUBLIC
AND THE PRIVATE SECTOR- DISS
ACOSTA AS IT GROWS IT TAKES
MONEY OFF OF THE TABLES. OF
WORKING PEOPLE IN THE
COMMUNITIES WE NEED IT- WHO NOW
HAVE TO MAKE DIFFICULT CHOICES
ABOUT- YOU KNOW. WHAT THEIR
PRIORITIES ARE SO WE THINK THIS
IS CRITICAL. AS A UNION THAT
REPRESENTS WORKERS I IN HEALTH
CARE SETTINGS- WE ALSO THINK
THAT IS CRITICAL TO ENSURE THAT
WE- HAVE THE EQUITY AT NIGHT
AND- BUT- THE- GUIDELINES IN
PLACE THAT ENSURE THAT. THE
SAVINGS THAT ARE- THAT COME
FROM A PROGRAM LIKE THIS ARE
BORN ON THE BACKS OF WORKERS-
BUT WE ARE- CONCEPTUALLY REALLY
SUPPORTIVE OF THIS. IDEA AND
THINK THAT IS ABOUT A GOOD STEP
IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION. THANK
YOU SIR. GOOD AT. CHAIR MEMBERS
GEN HAMPTON WITH CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION HEALTH PLANS HERE
TODAY. TO CONVEY THAT
CALIFORNIA'S HEALTH PLANS ARE
COMMITTED TO MAKING HEALTH CARE
MORE ACCESSIBLE AND AFFORDABLE
FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS. WE'RE
PLEASED TO SEE GOVERNOR SOME
CONTINUING TO PLACE A HIGH
PRIORITY. ON THE ISSUE
AFFORDABILITY. AND WE ARE IN
pLANGUAGE CURRENTLY AND LOOK FOR
BEING PART OF THE DISCUSSION
WITH IN PORT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SIR. MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THERESA START WITH
KAISER PERMANENTE A
AFFORDABILITY IS A DISTANT PART
OF OUR MISSION AND IT IS A
PRIORITY FOR US SO WE APPLAUD
THIS WORK HERE TODAY TO TACKLE.
HEALTHCARE COST AFFORDABILITY
FROM ALL ANGLES AND WE DO
BELIEVE THE OFFICE OF HEALTH
CARE AFFORDABILITY- HAS THE
ABILITY TO REALLY GET TO THOSE-
UNDERLYING COST DRIVERS IN THE
SYSTEM WHILE ALSO FOCUSING ON
QUALITY AND VALUE IN THE SYSTEM
WHICH IS- AND AN IMPORTANT
AREA. AND WE ARE STILL
ABSORBING THE TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE THAT WAS POST POSTED
TODAY AS WELL WE HAVE
IDENTIFIED A COUPLE OF AREAS OF
CONCERN SO. WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION AND WITH THE
LEGISLATURE. SO THAT THE OFFICE
REALLY CAN ACHIEVE IT'S
IMPORTANT GOAL WITHOUT AN-
CONSEQUENCES THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MA'AM. GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS GREAT SONG AND WITH
MANY HEALTH COUNCILS BASE LOS
ANGELES AND WE FIRMLY BELIEVE
IN HEALTHCARE SYSTEM THAT IS
EQUITABLE INSERTS ALL
CALIFORNIANS OF THEIR FOR.
REALLY SUPPORT THE OFFICE OF
HEALTH CARE PORTABILITY THANK
YOU THANK YOU MA'AM. MAXINE
INTEL ON BEHALF OF THE NATIONAL
MULTIPLE SCLEROSIS SOCIETY AND
SUPPORT OF THE CONCEPT OF THE
OFFICE OF. HEALTH CARE
AFFORDABILITY- THIS IS A
POPULATION- FREQUENT USERS OF
THE HEALTH CARE SYSTEM. REQUIRE
VERY EXPENSIVE TREATMENTS AND
MEDICATIONS. AND WE LOOK FOR TO
ENGAGING IN THIS CONVERSATION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS ERIC ROBLESS WITH
THE UNITED NURSES ASSOCIATIONS
OF CALIFORNIA UNION OF HEALTH
CARE PROFESSIONALS IN SUPPORT
OF THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
THANK YOU THANK YOU SIR. WELL
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS PRICE
STARKEY ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA AMBULATORY SURGERY
ASSOCIATION VERY SUPPORTIVE OF
THE EFFORTS OF THE
ADMINISTRATION THIS COMEDIAN
MEMBERS TO FINALLY CREATE AN
OFFICE OF HEALTH CARE
AFFORDABILITY. WHOSE TIME HAS
COME WE TALK A LOT IN THIS
BUILDING ABOUT INCREASING
ACCESS BENDING THE COST CURVE
AND MAINTAINING HIGH LEVELS OF
QUALITY CARE THAT'S WHAT
SURGERY CENTERS DO DAY IN AND
DAY OUT WE'VE DONE FOR FORTY
PLUS YEARS. ACCORDING TO
RESEARCH FROM UC BERKELEY EVERY
PROCEDURE PERFORM IN A C. SAVE
THE MEDICARE PROGRAM 40% AND
COSTS AND SAVE MEDICARE
BENEFICIARIES 5260% ON THE
COPAYMENTS. WE JUST WOULD
ENCOURAGE THE COMMITTEE
MINISTRATION TO NOT ONLY LOOK
AT THE CARE THIS BEING
DELIVERED BUT ALSO THE SORT OF
SERVICE WITH THE CARE IS BEING
PROVIDED AND WE LOOK FOR TO
BEING PART OF THE DISCUSSION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SIR. HI
I'M JIM WHEN BURKE ON BEHALF OF
THE FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON
LEGISLATION IN CALIFORNIA-
WE'VE MADE CONSIDERABLE
PROGRESS IN THE STATE. AT
REDUCING THE NUMBER OF
UNINSURED- HOWEVER
AFFORDABILITY IS STILL-A HUGE
BARRIER TO ACCESSING SERVICES
AND SO WE SUPPORT THE PROPOSAL.
THANK YOU SIR. I'M ROBERT FLAT
WITH UNITE HERE LOCAL FORTY
NINE ON THE OUT OF ITS MEMBERS
ACROSS SACRAMENTO REGION- WERE
IN SUPPORT OF CREATING THE
OFFICE AFFORDABILITY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SIR. MY NAME'S
ALEJANDRO RAYBURN WITH UNITE
HERE LOCAL FORTY NINE- IN
SUPPORT OF THE OFFICE OF HEALTH
CARE AFFORDABILITY THANK YOU
SIR. MY NAME'S OFFER WALKER
AND- WAY UNITE HERE LOCAL FORTY
NINE AND I'M IN SUPPORT OF THE
CREATION OF THE OFFICE OF
HEALTH CARE AFFORDABILITY.
THANK YOU SIR. MONICA LOPEZ-
LOCAL FORTY NINE. SUPPORT
HEALTH CARE. THANK YOU MA'AM.
MY NAME IS SAM BUSINESS WORK
GET CASINOS GUEST COULD GUESS
NO RESULTS. LOOK LOCAL FORTY
NINE MEMBERS NOW I SUPPORT THE
HEALTH CARE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU SIR. GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS TO OR ABOUT OF THE
SERVICE EMPLOYEES INTERNATIONAL
UNION WE SUPPORT THE PROPOSAL
YOU SEE BEFORE YOU AND CONCEPT
WE RECENTLY JUST GOT THE VIEW
OF THE GOVERNOR'S TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE A LOT OF GOOD THINGS
ARE IN THAT PROPOSAL AS YOU CAN-SEE BY THE TURN OUT OF MEMBERS
WE HAVE HERE TODAY. WE HAVE AN
ALL IN APPROACH WHERE THE
ENFORCEABILITY THE TARGET
SHOULD IMPACT EVERYBODY WITHIN
THE HEALTHCARE DELIVERY SYSTEM
AND FORTUNATELY IF LOOKING
THROUGH THE TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE WE'VE NOTICED ON
TRANSPARENCY AND PUBLIC ACCESS
TO DATA WE FALL SHORT OF THAT
ALL IN APPROACH WE HOPE TO
CONTINUE WORKING WITH YOU. AND
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE TO ENSURE
AS WE SET CAPS IN TARGET IN THE
MARKET WE CAN SEE IF THERE'S
GAMING IN THE SYSTEM ARE THINGS
HAPPENING IN THE SYSTEM THAT
DISADVANTAGED PEOPLE YOU'VE
HEARD FROM HERE TODAY AND THE
MEMBERS THAT ARE WORKING IN THE
HEALTH CARE SPACE SO WE
CONTINUE- TO WORK WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION ON YOU AND
WORKING ON THAT. THANKS THANK
YOU MA'AM. MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBER SERAPH LOCKS IN THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION. WE
SUPPORT THE IN CONCEPT THAT AND
THE OFFICE OF HEALTH CARE
AFFORDABILITY IN VERY EXCITED-
TO SEE THE STATE TAKING THE
STEPS FORWARD. WE WOULD ECHO-
S. YEAH YOU IN THAT. IN ORDER
TO BE ABLE TO HAVE REALLY
ACCOUNTABILITY AND- HAVE AN
OFFICE THAT TRULY FUNCTIONS. WE
NEED TO HAVE. ADEQUATE DATA WE
NEED TO HAVE TRANSPARENCY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY AND LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH YOU OVER THE
NEXT COUPLE MONTHS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. REBEKAH GONZALEZ
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN
SUPPORT OF THIS SAD THE
CREATION OF THIS OFFICE AND
WITHOUT AFFORDABILITY WE DON'T
HAVE ACCESS THANK YOU THANK YOU
MA'AM. THANK YOU MISTER MEMBERS
DAY BEGINS AWESOME HALF OF
AMERICA'S POSITION GROUPS HAPPY
TO BE HERE IN SUPPORT OF THE
FRAMER BUT FORD AND LOOK FOR TO
WORK WITH YOU ALL THE DETAILS
IN MAKING THIS OFFICE
SUCCESSFUL. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SIR. GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MY NAME IS
ELENA CENTURY- WITH NEXT IN
CALIFORNIA- WE HEAR A LOT FROM
THE YOUTH ABOUT NOT BEING ABLE
TO ACCESS HEALTH CARE COVERAGE
ESPECIALLY WHEN THE AGE OUT OF.
WHATEVER HEALTH INSURANCE THEY
ARE SO WE ECHO THE COMMENTS OF
THE SUPPORTERS AND LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING. WITH YOU ON THIS
OFFICE. THANK YOU. HAVE YOU
EVER MERECE WHAT THE LET THE NO
COLLISION FOR HEALTHY
CALIFORNIA- AND THE HIGH. COST
OF HEALTH CARE OFTEN FORCES
FAMILIES TO CHOOSE BETWEEN FOOD
OUR HEALTH CARE. AND THIS OFTEN
RESULTS IN PEOPLE NOT RECEIVING
THE MEDICAL CARE THEY NEED AND
AS SUCH WE- SUPPORT-
ELIMINATING THOSE BARRIERS TO
CARE. AND THAT'S WHY WE SUPPORT
THE OFFICE OF HEALTH CARE
AFFORDABILITY THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MA'AM. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN BURRS MEGAN SUPER
SOMEHOW FOR THE CALIFORNIA
PROFESSIONAL FIREFIGHTERS AND
WITH ECHO THE SENTIMENTS THAT
YOU'VE HEARD HERE THIS
AFTERNOON WE THINK. WE ARE
ENCOURAGED BY THIS PROPOSAL TO
SEE IT IN THE BUDGET AND LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE-
LEGISLATURE AND THE
ADMINISTRATION TO ENSURE
TRANSPARENCY BECAUSE WE FEEL
LIKE THAT IS A VERY KEY
COMPONENT OF THIS PROPOSAL.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MA'AM.
GOOD AFTERNOON JESSICA RAN OF
THE CHILDREN'S PARTNERSHIP WE
SUPPORT THE OFFICE IN CONCEPT
AND BELIEVE THAT CHILDREN TO
HAVE ACCESS TO CARE WITHOUT
PUTTING THEIR FAMILY WITH
EXCESSIVE COPAYS- COPAYMENTS
AND DEDUCTIBLES- SO LOOK FOR.
TRUCK NOT THE LEGISLATURE IN
THIS ISSUE THANK YOU THANK YOU
MA'AM. MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
APPLAUD THE GOVERNOR'S EFFORTS
SUPPORTING CONCEPT. THANK YOU
ON BEHALF OF AMERICA'S AGENDA.
SEEING NO FURTHER PUBLIC
COMMENT ON ISSUE FIVE I WILL
NOW ASK THE PANEL FOR ISSUE
FIVE TO COME FORWARD. AND IF WE
CAN START WITH ALICE CHAN
PLEASE. IT'S A SIGN GREAT. MY
NAME IS DR ALICE CHEN AND THE
DEPUTY. DIRECTORPOLICY IN
PLANNING AND DIRECTOR OF
CLINICAL AFFAIRS FOR THE HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES AGENCY AND
THANK YOU FOR GIVING US THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT ON THE
OFFICE OF HEALTH CARE FOR
ABILITY I WILL SAY- IT IS
HEARTENING THAT THERE ARE SO
MANY PEOPLE WHO ARE IN SUPPORT
OF. OF THE CONCEPT OF THIS
OFFICE IT IS ALSO SOBERING TO
SEE THE DIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIANS IN TERMS OF AGE
GENDER GEOGRAPHY. RACE
ETHNICITY ANY WHO ARE BEING
AFFECTED BY THIS- SO START BY
SAYING- OBVIOUSLY.
AFFORDABILITY AND HEALTH CARE
IS A CRITICAL ISSUE FOR
CALIFORNIANS IT IS- ONE OF THE
GOVERNOR'S TOP PRIORITIES TO
ADDRESS. AND AS SUCH- THIS
OFFICE IS ONE OF THE MINISTRY.
IN MINISTRATIONS SIGNATURE
PROPOSALS- IT IS REALLY.
PROMISED ON FOR GUIDING
PRINCIPLE SO FIRST- WE NEED A
CLEAR GOAL IF WE DON'T KNOW
WHERE WE'RE TRYING TO GET WE
WON'T BE ABLE TO GET THERE SO
SETTING A STATEWIDE PER CAPITA
COST TARGET. FOR A YEAR OVER
YEAR CHANGE IN COST. SECOND ALL
IN EVERY SECTOR OF THE
HEALTHCARE INDUSTRY HAS A ROLE
AND RESPONSIBILITY TO PLAY IN
GETTING US TO THAT TARGET.
THIRD ACCOUNTABILITY. WE
ANTICIPATE AND HOPE THAT BY
SETTING A CLEAR GOAL- CHANGE
WILL HAPPEN AND THE SYSTEM ALL
LINE BUT IN CASE THAT DOESN'T
HAPPEN WE HAVE- MECHANISM FOR
PER PROGRESSIVE ENFORCEMENT AND
LASTLY THAT- WE NSURE THAT
SAVINGS A CREW BACK TO
CONSUMERS SO THOSE ARE THE FOUR
GUIDING PRINCIPLES- I'LL WALK
YOU THROUGH THE KEY COMPONENTS
SO IN TERMS OF THE ORGANIZATION
AND PLACEMENT- BECAUSE THIS IS
A HIGH PRIORITY FOR THE
GOVERNOR- THIS WILL BE AN
OFFICE WITHIN THE AGENCY WITH
THE DIRECTOR APPOINTED BY THE
GOVERNOR. THERE WILL BE ELEVEN
MEMBER ADVISORY BOARD WITH
BROAD EXPERTISE REPRESENTING
THE DIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA AND
THE BOARD ADVISES THE DIRECTOR
AND ALL KEY ASPECTS OF THE
OFFICES WORK. IN TERMS OF THE
HEALTH CARE COST TARGET- THE
OFFICE HAS- THE MANDATE TO SET
A STATEWIDE TARGET AN AUTHORITY
TO SET SECTOR SPECIFIC AND
GEOGRAPHIC TARGETS. THE PROCESS
IS THAT'LL BE BASED ON
ESTABLISHED ECONOMIC INDICATORS
AND THERE IS A ROBUST PUBLIC
PROCESS WHERE THE ADVISORY
BOARD MAKES A RECOMMENDATION.
THE DIRECTOR HOLD A PUBLIC
MEETING FOR PUBLIC COMMENT AND
DISCUSSION AND THEN IT GETS
ADOPTED AT A SUBSEQUENT PUBLIC
MEETINGS OF THREE VENUES FOR
DISCUSSION. IN TERMS OF DATA
COLLECTION- WE'RE GONNA START
WITH DATA SUBMISSION FROM
PAYERS INCLUDING SELF INSURED
PLANS- ON THE OFFICE WILL HAVE
THE AUTHORITY TO COLLECT DATA
FROM PROVIDERS IS NEEDED AND
JUST AS A NOTE WE- DID NOT WANT
TO START OUT WITH COLLECTING
DATA. FROM PROVIDERS BEFORE
UNDERSTANDING FOR THE GAPS WERE
IN THE DATA FROM PAYERS BECAUSE
THE DATA SPECIFICATIONS WILL
LIKELY CHANGE YEAR TO YEAR AS
WE LEARN ABOUT THESE GAPS. THEY
WILL BE ADOPTED BY EMERGENCY
REGULATIONS HOWEVER THERE WILL
BE STAKEHOLDER ENGAGEMENT AND
PUBLIC MEETING PRIOR. TO
ACCEPTANCE OF- OUR ADOPTION OF
THOSE REGULATIONS EACH YEAR
THERE WILL BE AN ANNUAL REPORT
ASSOCIATED WITH THE PUBLIC
MEETING THE OFFICE IS CHARGED
WITH ANALYZING REPORTING ON THE
DATA IT COLLECTS. PUBLISHING AN
ANNUAL REPORT AND HOLDING AND
PUBLIC MEETING. ON THE CONTENT
INCLUDES COST TRENDS DRIVERS-
LOOKING AT KIND OF BALANCED
SCORECARD MEASURES TO MAKE SURE
THAT THERE ISN'T UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES IN TERMS OF ACCESS
QUALITY EQUITY. HIGHLIGHTING
BEST PRACTICES ANY IMPACT ON
WORK FORCE AS WELL AS ANY
CORRECTIVE ACTION PLANS AGAIN
THIS PROCESS IS DELIBERATELY-
OPEN TO THE PUBLIC- WITH AMPLE
OPPORTUNITY FOR PUBLIC IMPORT
INPUT. WITH THE ANNUAL REPORT
FINALIZED AT A SUBSEQUENT
MEETING. IN TERMS OF
ENFORCEMENT THE OVERRIDING
PHILOSOPHY IS ONE OF
PROGRESSIVE ENFORCEMENT SO THE
OFFICE STARTS WITH TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE- MOVES ON THE PUBLIC
HEARINGS AND THEN- MAY REQUIRE
A CORRECTIVE ACTION PLAN AND IF
THOSE FAILED THEN THERE ARE
PROVISIONS FOR CIVIL PENALTIES
AND ESCALATING PENALTIES
COMMENSURATE WITH THE- BUT HOW
MUCH THE COST TARGET IS MISSED-
IN THIS CASE THERE IS A FULL
REGULATORY PROCESS TO DEVELOP
THAN FOR SPENT PROVISIONS WAS
STAKEHOLDER INPUT. INCLUDING A
METHODOLOGY TIMELINE
IDENTIFICATION OF WARRANTED AN
UNWARRANTED FACTORS TO PROCESS
THE PEELS I JUST WANT TO FINISH
BY HIGHLIGHTING FOR ADDITIONAL
COMPONENTS OF THE OFFICE- AGAIN
I MENTION THAT WE DON'T WANT TO
HAVE UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES
THERE'S A PROVISION TO LOOK AT
QUALITY PERFORMANCE- AVOIDING-
AS YOU'RE FOCUSING ON COST
NEGLECTING COST. QUALITY EQUITY
ON THE GOAL HERE IS ONE OF
ADMINISTRATIVE SIMPLIFICATION
NOT ADDING NEW REQUIREMENTS ARE
MANDATES BUT REALLY LOOKING TO
SEE- WHAT IS A PARTY SET
STANDARD MEASURES THAT CAN BE
USED. THERE'S ALSO GOAL TO
PROMOTE ALTERNATIVE PAYMENT
MODELS OF SHIFTING THE SYSTEM
FROM A FEE FOR SERVICE- FOCUS
ON UTILIZATION PAYMENT SYSTEM
TO ONE THAT REWARDS HIGH
QUALITY AND COST EFFICIENT
CARE-THIS WILL INVOLVE
DEVELOPING STANDARDS AND
CRITERIA FOR A PM CONTRACTING
THAT CAN BE ADOPTED. BY PAYERS
AND PROVIDERS AND I THINK SOME
OF THE SPEAKERS MENTION THEM
PORTENTS OF PRIMARY CARE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH INVESTMENTS-
THOSE WOULD BE KEY AS WELL AS-
MODELS OF SHARED SAVINGS OUR
POPULATION BASED PAYMENTS.
THERE'S ALSO AN IMPORTANT
FACTOR TO CONSIDER IN TERMS OF
IMPACT AS WE CHANGE THE
HEALTHCARE SYSTEM AND MAKE IT
MORE EFFICIENT ON JOBS IN THE
WORK FORCE. SO IMPORTANCE OF
AVOIDING UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES IN TERMS OF
LOWERING STANDARDS ENCOURAGING
LAYOFFS- AND SO THE OFFICE WILL
HAVE A GOAL OF ENCOURAGING HIGH
QUALITY JOBS. AND IMPORTANTLY
SUPPORTING TRAINING AND
RETRAINING NEEDS BECAUSE WE
KNOW AS WE FOCUS ON MAKING THE
HEALTH CARE MORE EFFICIENT AND
MORE RESPONSIVE ON THERE WILL
BE CHANGES AND HOW IT'S
DELIVERED AND WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THE WORK FORCES TAKING
CARE OF AND THAT PROCESS. AND
THEN LASTLY THERE IS A- FOCUS
ON COST AND MARKET IMPACT
REVIEWS- THE INTENT HERE IS TO
HAVE A MORE PROACTIVE VIEW INTO
THE LANDSCAPE OF HEALTH CARE
CONSOLIDATION THERE IS A BROAD
SCOPE YOU'LL SEE HORIZONTAL.
VERTICAL CROSS INDUSTRY-
INCLUSIVE OF ALL SECTORS THERE
IS A NOTE OF HEALTH PLANS AND
INSURERS BEING CALLED THAT
BECAUSE THEY ARE READY ARE
COVERED BY EXISTING REGULATORY-
AGENCIES AND WE DIDN'T WANT TO.
DUPLICATE THAT WORK- IN ANY OF
FINANCIAL BUT THEN BE REFERRED
TO THE ATTORNEY GENERAL- AND
THEN LASTLY IN TERMS OF FINDING
A THERE'S A B. C. P. COMING
YOUR WAY IN. THANK YOU DOCTOR-
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE LA YOU.
WE ARE ALMOST A PART OF FINANCE
I WOULD JUST NOTE THAT THERE
WILL BE A RESOURCE REQUEST
ALONG WITH THIS BUT IT MIGHT
NOT BE IN THE APRIL TIMELINE
BUT WE DO LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU ON- ANY
CHANGES TO THE PROPOSED TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE OR- AS WELL WITH.
US WITH OTHER STAKEHOLDERS.
THANK YOU MA'AM. BENJOHNSON
WITH THE LA- GIVEN THE TIMING
OF THE RELEASE OF THE TRAILER
BILL WE DON'T HAVE AN ANALYSIS
AT THIS TIME BUT WE WILL BE
LOOKING AT THIS LANGUAGE OVER
THE COMING WEEKS AND WE'LL
SHARE WITH THE LEGISLATURE- AND
THE ANALYSIS THAT WE HAVE ON
THE TRAILER BILL. THANK THANK
YOU SIR I'M SURPRISED THE LA-
COULDN'T GET ON IT TODAY I
STRUGGLED AS WELL TO GET
THROUGH. THE TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE. IF I CAN I'LL START
WITH COMMENTS AND THEN LOOK TO
THE SUBCOMMITTEE- YOU KNOW I.
TOO AM REALLY HAPPY THAT THE
GOVERNOR IS WORKING ON THIS
INCREDIBLY DIFFICULT AND
COMPLEX ISSUE- IT'S IMPERATIVE
FOR US IS THIS AS A STATE TO
BEND THE COST CURVE. IN FOR US
TO. START AFFECTING
AFFORDABILITY WILL ULTIMATELY
ALLOW US TO INCREASE ACCESS AND
pUNIVERSAL COVERAGE AND SO LOOK
FORWARD TO THIS DEPARTMENTS
ABILITY TO HELP US TO SET
TARGETS AS WELL- REALLY DID
WANT TO TALK A LITTLE MORE-
ABOUT THE ADVISORY BOARD OF
COULD. IT SEEMS AS IF THIS IS
YOUR MAIN MECHANISM- IS THE
CREATION THIS ADVISORY BOARD.
TO ESSENTIALLY BE A COST
CONTAINMENT COMMISSION THAT
WILL HELP TO COME UP WITH
PROPOSALS TARGETS FOR CPAS SIX
THURS OR REGIONS AND HOPING YOU
COULD TALK A LITTLE BIT MORE
ABOUT THE COMMISSION SINCE. I
DIDN'T GET THROUGH THE TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE. YOU'RE NOT A
SPEED READER I AM. SO THE WAY
IT'S CONSTRUCTED ELEVEN SEVEN
APPOINTED BY THE GOVERNOR TO
APPOINTED BY THE CENTRAL CAN
ROLES AND TO BY THE SPEAKER OF
THE ASSEMBLY- AND IMPORTANTLY.
AND WE'VE AND DELINEATED A
NUMBER OF CONTENT AREAS WERE-
THE GOAL OF THE VISOR BORDERS
TO HAVE CONTENT EXPERTS SO-
HEALTH CARE ECONOMICS HEALTH
CARE DELIVERY HEALTH CARE
MANAGEMENT FINANCE
ADMINISTRATION AND PAYMENT
METHODOLOGIES HEALTH PLAN WE
WANT PEOPLE WHO ACTUALLY- BOTH
HAVE. DEEP CONTENT KNOWLEDGE
AND IDEALLY KNOW WHAT'S GOING
ON ON THE GROUND WHO CAN
ACTUALLY HELP THE SHAPE. ON
THIS THE OTHER PORTION OF HIS
PROPOSAL SEEMS TO BE REGARDING
ADMINISTRATIVE SIMPLIFICATION
AND YOU'VE IDENTIFIED FOR
SPECIFIC WAYS AT THE END OF THE
AGENDA AND I'M WONDERING IF
PART OF THIS ADMINISTRATIVE
SIMPLIFICATION IS- GOING TO BE
BORNE OUT THROUGH THE TELLING
PROPOSAL OR IF THE OFFICE OF
HEALTH CARE AFFORDABILITY WILL
SPECIFICALLY BE WORKING ON
THINGS SUCH AS ADMINISTRATIVE
COMPLEXITY AND FAILURE OF CARE
COORDINATION. YEAH I THINK
ADMINISTRATIVE SIMPLIFICATION-
IS REQUIRED THROUGHOUT EVERY
SINGLE PART OF OUR HEALTHCARE
SYSTEM- INCLUDING IN KILLING
CERTAINLY THAT IS DISTINCT FROM
THIS PROPOSAL- WE REALLY
ATTENDED TO IT COMES OF EVERY
COMPONENT PIECE OF IT WHETHER
IT'S DATA COLLECTION- QUALITY
MEASURES- OUR WORK FORCE
MEASURES A PM'S WE ACTUALLY
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE DON'T
CREATE ADDITIONAL REGULAR.
DISTRO BURDENS AND PROVIDERS
AND SYSTEMS AND SO THAT'S
REALLY- THREADED THROUGHOUT.
I'M IN THE ONLY OTHER ASPECT OF
THAT  WOULD ADD IS THAT.
EARLIER WE HEARD THAT HEALTH
CARE IS QUESTION WORKERS AS
WELL AND HOW WE MAKE SURE THAT
CONSUMERS ARE NOT UNFAIRLY
BEARING THE BRUNT OF HEALTH
CARE COSTS IS INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT. AS WE SEE A LARGER
SHARE OF THEIR COMPENSATION
GOING TOWARDS HEALTHCARE COSTS
RATHER THAN TAKE HOME PAY AND
THINK IT'S QUITE IMPORTANT TO
RECOGNIZE THE LARGE SHOWING WE
HAD HERE TODAY WHO. ARE DOING
MANY OF THOSE COMMENTS WITH
THAT I WILL LOOK TO THE SUB
COMMITTEE TO SEE IF THEY HAVE
ANY OTHER COMMENTS. DR WHAT.
YES SIR THANK YOU THANK YOU
DOCTOR CHAN FOR THIS-
PRESENTATION AND THANK YOU TO
THE FOLKS WHO- WERE HERE
TESTIFYING EARLIER IN SUPPORT-
IN PARTICULAR WOMAN AT THAT
CAUGHT MY ATTENTION- FROM A SE
YOU TALKED ABOUT TRANSPARENCY.
AND DATA- AND THOSE ARE TWO
THINGS THAT ARE REALLY ON THE
TOP OF MY LIST PERSONALLY.
REFER THE TERM ALL IN HERE- A
LOT. AND I THINK THAT'S
CRITICAL I MEAN ALL SECTORS OF
THE HEALTH CARE- SHOULD BE
LOOKED AT IN MY OPINION BEEN
LOOKING AT AFFORDABILITY FOR
AWHILE NOW AND ACTUALLY HAVE A
BILL ON THIS ISSUE- THAT WILL
BE WORKING CONCURRENT. WITH
OFFICE ON- I NOTED THAT- DAY
ONE COMMENT YOU MADE WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT AS WE TALK ABOUT
HIGH QUALITY CARE. BUT YOU'VE-
AND THAT YOU'RE NOT GOING TO A
NEW. COLLECTIVE PROVIDE DATA
AND I THINK THAT- WHEN WE'RE
LOOKING AT OUTCOMES AND THE
QUALIFY QUALITY CARE. THAT
PROVIDER DATA BECOMES A-
CRITICAL COMPONENT HERE USE
ALSO SAD I DON'T WHEN I WAS
THE ADDITIONAL BURDENS ON
PROVIDERS. WHICH I APPRECIATE
AS HAVING BEEN A PROVIDER FOR
MANY MANY YEARS. SO YOU SAID
INITIALLY PROVIDER DAY WON'T.
IS NOT. GOING TO BE A PART OF
THIS WINDY YOU AT WHAT POINT DO
YOU EXPECT OF RECKLESS AND
BECAUSE I THINK. AS WE START
ANOTHER COMPONENT OF THIS WHICH
IS THE- I BELIEVE IS A CRITICAL
COMPONENT. TO THIS IN A LOT OF
THINGS THAT ARE GOING TO ARRIVE
OUR ABILITY TO RELIEVE. AT
HEALTH CARE AND THE- HEALTH
CARE. IN OUR GOAL GET EVERYONE
COVERED IN THAT THE ALL PAYER
CLAIMS DATABASE AND THAT'S
GONNA BE CRITICAL WE- NEED TO
DATA. FROM ALSO IN THERE AS
WELL SO. JUST LIKE. YOUR
THOUGHTS ON THAT. ABSOLUTELY
THANK YOU- TWO THOUGHTS ONE IS-
THANK YOU FOR LEADERSHIP OF THE
HPV BECAUSE ACTUALLY THAT WILL
BE CRITICAL FOR THE ALL PAYER
CLAIMS DATABASE OR- HEALTH CARE
PAYMENTS. DATABASE SYSTEM I'M
SORRY PROGRAM. IS A IS ACTUALLY
CRITICAL OF THE WORK OF THIS-
OFFICE I THINK FOR THE PURPOSE
OF THE COST TARGETS- THEPAIR
LEVEL DATA FROM OUR
UNDERSTANDING AGAIN LOOKING AT
MODELS FROM SOME OF THE EXPERTS
THAT YOU BROUGHT IN EARLIER- IS
THE NATIONAL CUT TO LOOK AT-
EXPENDITURES PER CAPITA WE
ABSOLUTELY AGREE THAT THE
OFFICE SHOULD HAVE THE
AUTHORITY TO. COLLECT PROVIDER
DATA AS NEEDED ONCE WE DEVELOP-
AN UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT THE
LANDSCAPE IS ACROSS THE STATE
WHAT AREAS WE MAY NEED
ADDITIONAL- GRANULARITY OTHER
PEOPLE ARE REALLY- COGNIZANT OF
IS THE NEED TO STAND THIS UP
QUICKLY AND THE LOGISTICAL AND
NOT A LOGICAL CHALLENGES OF
BRINGING IN FIGHTER DATA WHAT
MUCH MORE VARIABLE FORMAT THAN
PAYER DATA ENTRY RECORD PILOT
ON THE BACK NOT TO SAY THAT
WORK. IN IN THAT WE'RE JUST
BEING REALISTIC TERMS WE'RE
GONNA BE STEP THEN WANTING TO
EARN FROM WHERE ARE SEE WHAT
HE'D IT MEANT AND FIGURE OUT
WHERE WE- FOR. WHITER PARTY. I
WOULD JUST A PERSONAL PLUG IS
LOOK AT I THINK CARE OUTCOMES
CRITIC COME HERE IN IN IN THE
SYSTEM AND SO IT'S A BECOMES
IMPERATIVE THAT WE UNDERSTAND
THAT IF WE'RE DOING TREATMENT A
CERTAIN WAY AND GETTING AND
WHAT ARE THE OUTCOMES WERE
GETTING AND ARE THOSE ARE THOSE
THE BEST BANG FOR THE BUCK. I
THINK THE OTHER THING THAT I
HEARD FROM PEOPLE WHICH IS OUT
ALSO OF CONCERN IS THAT THAT
SAVINGS ULTIMATELY- BE REALIZED
BY CONSUMERS AND- AND SO HOW DO
YOU HOW DO YOU ENVISION THAT DO
YOU HAVE HAS THE ADMINISTRATION
ENVISIONED GOING FORWARD. OF I
WILL SAY THIS IS SOMETHING WE
TALKED ABOUT FROM THE VERY
BEGINNING- AND THIS IS WHERE
WE'RE GOING TO BE ON THE
CUTTING EDGE BECAUSE I THINK
THERE ARE SOME OTHER STATES
HAVE- LOOKED AT COST TARGETS
BUT DIDN'T HAVE AFFORDABILITY-
IN. IN RIGHT IN THE BULL'S EYE
AND THEN KIND OF MISS THE MARK
THERE- SOME OF THE THOUGHTS WE
HAVE ARE. A CREATING A MEASURE
OF AFFORDABILITY SO MEASURING-COMPLETELY OUT OF POCKET COSTS
IN TERMS OF- OBVIOUSLY DOESN'T
GET THE UNINSURED BUT FOR
ANYONE WHO. IS INSURED-
CONSUMER AM COPAYS COINSURANCE
DEDUCTIBLES AND TRACKING THAT
IS A MEASURE AS WELL AS GROWTH
IN PREMIUMS. AND ACTUALLY
TRYING TO. THAT ALSO MEET SOME
KIND OF TARGET WOULD BE A WAY
TO MAKE SURE THAT THE FORD
ABILITY COMPONENT IS SQUARELY
CENTERED ON CONSUMERS WE'VE
ALSO TALKED ABOUT OTHER
MECHANISMS OF MECHANISMS LIKE
THE AND ALL OUR REBATE. BUT
AGAIN WE'RE REALLY LEERY OF
GIVING EVERYBODY A TO OUR CHECK
WHEN REALLY WHAT WE NEED TO DO.
A MAKE SURE PREMIUM- OVERALL
COST OF CARE MORE AFFORDABLE.
I'D I'D FOR SMALL AND I'M I'M
I'M SUPPORTIVE OBVIOUSLY- AND
YEAH I THINK WHEN YOU CONSIDER-
AND I DON'T HAVE THE EXACT
NUMBERS BUT IT HAS HAS BEEN
HOVERING AROUND TWICE THE RATE
OF INFLATION AND THE COST OF.
HEALTHCARE SPENDING. OF THE
IMPACT ON ON EVERY DAY WORKERS
AND THEIR ABILITY TO TAKE HOME
A PAYCHECK WHEN ALL THOSE
INCOME ALL THOSE RACES SEEM TO
BE GOING TO PAY FOR THEIR
HEALTHCARE- IT'S COMPLETELY
UNSUSTAINABLE AND SO THIS IS-
THIS IS AN EFFORT THAT IS-
WELL- IF THE TIME IS RIGHT-
IT'S BEEN RIGHT FOR AWHILE BUT
I'M I'M HAPPY TO SEE THAT WE
CAN MOVE FORWARD ON THIS BUT-
WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH. THE FUTURE THANK YOU
QUEST. THANK YOU TO WHAT SIGNAL
FOR THERE'S PUBLIC OUR SIDE
COMMENTS FROM THE SUBCOMMITTEE
YOU KNOW I WILL I WILL SAY THAT
THE LANGUAGE WAS RELEASED
EARLIER TODAY AND SO THERE
STILL ARE A FEW FINAL CONFLICTS
BETWEEN LABOR LABOR AND
PROVIDERS THAT STILL NEED TO BE
WORKED THROUGH. BUT WE ARE
HAVING THIS HEARING TODAY AT
THE REQUEST OF LABOR WHO ASKED
US TO HAVE TO HEARINGS BECAUSE
THIS ISSUE WERE PROPOSAL IS SO
IMPORTANT TO THEM AS WELL AS TO
THE STATE OUR SECOND HEARING ON
THIS ISSUE AND THIS PROPOSAL
WILL BE ON MAY FOURTH AND LOOK
FORWARD TO INTO DETAILS.
REGARDING THE TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE ON THAT DATE WITH THAT
WE WILL HOLD ISSUE FIVE OPEN.
AND BECAUSE ASSEMBLYMEMBER
REVERSES HERE WILL MOVE TO
ISSUE SIXTEEN. YEAH. SB. GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
REFER. SO REALLY THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE AND I'M
I'M UP PLEASED TO BE HERE TO
REQUEST SEVEN POINT FIVE
MILLION IN ONE TIME FUNDING
IT'S FUNDING FOR YOU CONSULT
SERVICES AND- I TELL HEALTH
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM AS PROPOSED
BY OUR ASSEMBLY BILL TWO ONE
SIX FOUR AND SO FOR FAR TOO
LONG RULE CALIFORNIANS HAVE
LACKED EQUITABLE ACCESS. TO
QUALITY HEALTHCARE AND IN ROLE
IN IN IN IN THE RURAL PARTS OF
THIS STATE ARE- RULE AND-A
COMMITTEE HEALTH CENTERS SERVE
THE MOST MEDICALLY VULNERABLE
PEOPLE INCLUDING THOSE
EXPERIENCING ON IT DID THE
DIAGNOSED SEVERE MENTAL HEALTH
AND THESE HEALTH ISSUES HEALTH
CENTER HAVE CLEARLY FALLEN FAR
BEHIND IN THE TIMES AND IT'S
ONLY GETTING WORSE. AND SO A
LOT OF THESE HEALTH CENTER
NEEDED DROP UP BATES AND ONLY
BE NEED TO BE WITH NEW
TECHNOLOGY- THE TECHNOLOGY THAT
WILL TELL THEM TO SAME STANDARD.
PRESIDENT ENJOY IN THIS NOW
THIS LEGISLATION APRIL AGREED
UPON PROGRAM TO ENSURE THAT
RURAL AND- OUR COMMUNITY HEALTH
CENTERS I HAVE THE TOOLS
NECESSARY TO IMPLEMENT THE- IN
THE CONSULT PROGRAM IN AS A
RESEARCH AND THE DATA SUGGESTS
SUCH SERVICES CAN DRAMATICALLY
IMPACT THE QUALITY AND URGENCY
OF CARE THAT OUR PATIENTS
RECEIVED IN AND SO STILL OFTEN
WHEN ON THESE PATIENTS IN RURAL
OR UNDERSERVED AREAS ARE
REFERRED TO MEDICAL SPECIAL-
THEY PLEASE FOR MOUNTABLE
POPSICLES AND BARRIERS- WHEN
ATTEMPTING TO ACCESS TO THE
CARE THAT THEY NEED ME HE'S
PAID STATE TAKE THE OFF. THEY
CAN'T FIND OF CARE AND RELIABLE
TRANSPORTATION IS A SIGNIFICANT
PROBLEM I AS MANY PATIENTS
AREN'T ABLE TO DRIVE THE
DISTANCE IS NECESSARY TO ATTEND
APPOINTMENTS AND TO SEE A LIST
AND SO OUR GOVERNOR HAS
PROPOSED A VERY THE CHEN AGENDA
BASED ON ADVANCING THE TWISTS
OF ALL CALIFORNIANS AND IF WE
ARE GOING TO ADVANCE THE
INTERESTS OF. ALL PEOPLE IN OUR
STATE- THEN WE MUST FIND A WAY
TO BRIDGE THIS GAP IN HEALTH
CARE I IN A PROVIDING CARE TO
ALL PEOPLE THE DE THE- HE
CONSULTS A PROVEN WAY TO DO
THAT IT'S AN EASY WAY IT'S AN
EFFICIENTWAY TO GET IT DONE-
IN IN THIS BILL ASSEMBLY BILL
TWO ONE SIX FOUR. THE SEVEN
POINT FIVE MILLION THAT IS THE
REQUESTED. WILL NUMBER FIVE
YEARS AND ASK. IT WOULD IT
WOULD BE ONE POINT FIVE MILLION
PER YEAR TO CREATE A GRANT
PROGRAM AND PROVIDE ELIGIBLE
HEALTH CENTER CONTROL NETWORKS-
AND RURAL HEALTH CLINICS WITH
FUNDING TO IMPLEMENT IN HE
CONSULT PROGRAM AND I-
CERTAINLY RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT ON THE BUDGET
REQUEST AND WOULD LIKE TO
INTRODUCE CHEN STOLE. FOR A C.
H. IT IS TO THE ORGAN THE
COMMUNITY HEALTH INFORMATION
NETWORK IT'S A HEALTH ANY
APPOINTMENTS GOVERNOR HAS
PROPOSED SIDE. I WATCH THE TALK
ABOUT THE TECHNOLOGY NEEDED IN
OUR HEALTH CENTERS I HAVE IT ON
MY WRISTS HERE- BUT- CERTAINLY
AND SO SHE A COME TO IT IS THE
AN OR IT'S A OUR HEALTH- TECH
ORGANIZATION- AND SHE WILL
ELABORATE FURTHER ON THIS
FUNDING NEED AND REQUEST THANK
YOU SEARCH. THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER I THINK THEY'RE MUTE
THEM. YEAH YEAH. GOOD AFTERNOON
THANK YOU AS CHAIR ARAMBULA
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE AFTER
THE RECORD I'M MY NAME IS
JENNIFER STOLEN THE EXECUTIVE
VICE PRESIDENT GOVERNMENT
RELATIONS FOR OCEAN OCEANS A
NATIONAL NONPROFIT HEALTH
TECHNOLOGY AND RESEARCH
ORGANIZATION THAT SUPPORTS
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES
THROUGHOUT THE U. S. IN
CALIFORNIA AND WE PROVIDE
SERVICES SUCH AS AFFORDABLE
BROADBAND BEST IN CLASS
TECHNOLOGY DATA ANALYTICS TO
HELP TRANSFORM HEALTH CENTERS
AND IN TWENTY NINETEEN OCEAN
TECHNOLOGIES AND EXPERTISE
ACTUALLY SUPPORTED OVER SEVENTY
HEALTH CENTERS APPROXIMATELY
MILLION CALIFORNIANS INTO POINT
FOR IT HE WILL VISITS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. EXAMPLE DAY OF-
CHIP PLATFORMS TOOLS BEING USED
BY MEMBERS INCLUDE DID YOU
SCREEN IN MANAGEMENT FOR THE
COVERT NINETEEN OUTBREAK- HELP
RECORD. IN BETWEEN IS A CO
MENTAL FOR. AND BRINGING A MEDI
TO IT'S HOMELESSNESS ARE LIVING
ON THE STREETS WITH MOBILE
PLATFORMS- AND ALSO WHILE VERGE
EXPANDING VIRTUAL CARE OPTIONS
FOR PATIENTS LIVING WITH
DISEASE FOR VIRTUAL KAREN
TELEHEALTH. I'M YOU MIGHT ALSO
NOTICES THE CALIFORNIA
TELEHEALTH NETWORK WHICH BRINGS
US SUBSIDIZE BROADBAND SERVICES
TO RURAL PARTS OF THE STATE IN
ALSO WE OPERATE- A FEDERALLY
FUNDED- TELEHEALTH RESOURCE
CENTER FOR CALIFORNIA BASED
HERE IN SACRAMENTO. IS THROUGH
THIS LENS THAT WE ARE THRILLED
TO SUPPORT AB TWENTY ONE FORTY
SIX AUTHORED BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ROBERT RIVAS- AND- THE
COMPANION MEASURE TO THIS
BUDGET REQUEST WOULD SUPPORT-
HOW CENTERS TO IMPLEMENT NEEDLE
ECON SALTS ANOTHER TELEHEALTH
PLATFORMS. IT'S NOT ONLY URGENT
TODAY DRESSING THE KOBE
NINETEEN CRISIS BUT IT'S REALLY
CRITICAL AS WE'RE TRYING TO
BUILD PASSED THE IN THE SYSTEM
AROUND GET ACCESS TO SPECIAL.
RESPONDING TO RE FROM POINT
FIVE IN A FIVE YEAR SUPPLIES
FUNDING TO HEALTH CENTERS AND-
FOR THE ADOPTION AND USE CITY
COUNCIL SERVICES FOR
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES TO HELP
THEM- ACCESS VIRTUAL KAREN
TELEHEALTH IN INCORPORATE INTO
THEIR DAILY PRACTICES. AND
TRAIN THEIR STAFF ON HOW TO USE
THEM AT THE RIGHT TIME TO REACH
PATIENTS OCEAN IS SEEN AGAIN
AND AGAIN EACH CONSOLES AND
VIRTUAL CRE ARE NOT ONLY. ARE
CRITICAL IN ADDRESSING
SKYROCKETING HEALTHCARE COSTS
WHICH IS IMPORTANT- FROM THE
LAST BILL WE JUST HEARD. BUT
ALSO HELPS PATIENTS AVOID
UNNECESSARY EMERGENCY ROOM
VISITS- UNNECESSARY REFERRALS
OFTEN RESULTING IN EXTENSIVE
TRAVEL LOST WORK AND COSTLY
CHILD CARE USED TO BE CONSOLES
CAN IMPROVE COMMUNICATION AND
COLLABORATION BETWEEN SPECIALTY
CARE PROVIDERS AND PRIMARY CARE
PROVIDERS. AND HAS PROVEN THE
QUALITY OF MEDICAL CARE
DELIVERED- IN ACCESS TO OUR-
COMMUNITIES AND WITH THIS OCEAN
STRONGLY SUPPORTS URGE YOUR
SUPPORT OF THIS **** REQUEST.
I'D BE HAPPY TO ANY QUESTION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MA'AM WE
DON'T TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT ISSUE.
SIXTEEN I GUESS I'M THE ONLY
ONE RIGHT NOW BUT I AM KELLY BE
MOTHER HAVE FOR THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION- WE ARE
FINALIZING POSITIONS ON ALL OF
THE BILLS THAT HAVE BEEN
PRESENTED TO US AT OUR COUNCIL
LEGISLATION AT THE END OF THIS
WEEK. SO MAKE SURE TO BACK TO
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE BUT WE'RE
GENERALLY SUPPORTIVE OF EACH
CONSOLE AND TELL IT TELL HEALTH
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MA'AM.
SEEING NO FURTHER. PUBLIC
COMMENT WILL BRING IT BACK TO
THE SUBCOMMITTEE DOCTOR WITH.
WHAT THANK YOU MUCH MISTER
MISTER RIVAS FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD THIS IS SOMETHING THAT-
I'M I'M VERY SUPPORTIVE OF WE
BOTH REPRESENT LARGELY RURAL
DISTRICTS AND OTHER CHALLENGES
FOR PEOPLE JUST. GETTING TO
DOCTORS- AT EVEN GETTING TO THE
PRIMARY CARE IS CAN BE A
CHALLENGE SO YOU ADD TO THAT
SOMETIMES THE COMPLICATIONS OF-
WHETHER- EVERY YEAR I HAVE OF
ROAD CLOSURES THAT PREVENT IN
THIS CASE RIGHT NOW EAST WEST-
BETWEEN- PART OF MY JUST DIDN'T
AND- AND THE ADJOINING JUST.
MAKING IT CHALLENGING FOR
PEOPLE TO GET TO SPECIALTY-
SPECIALTY CARE SO- IT I THINK
THE CHALLENGE FOR SOME OF US
ALSO- YOU KNOW AS AS WE LOOK-
TO- INFRASTRUCTURE. IT THE
CHALLENGES RELATED TO BROAD
WHICH WHICH IS A CONTINUING
CHALLENGE WHICH I KNOW IS ALSO
SOMETHING THE GOVERNOR'S VERY
INTERESTED IN IN IN IN
CHANGING- AND CREATING A MORE
EQUITABLE. ACCESS BEEN FOR
EVERYONE CAN. YOU AMBER SUPPORT
WHAT YOU'RE DOING. THANK YOU
DOCTOR WOULD. SO I CAN I
THOUGHT THE TIED TO THE ISSUE
BEFORE THIS WAS APPROPRIATE AS
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT
AFFORDABILITY THIS SEEMS TO
PROVIDE SOME ADMINISTRATIVE
SIMPLIFICATION I THINK YOUR
WORD WAS EFFICIENCY I THINK HE
HE CONSULTAR TRONIC BUT MAYBE A
FISSION C. WORKS HERE AS WELL.
I THINK MY QUESTION FOR YOU IF
I MAY IS AGAIN HOW THIS TIES
INTO EITHER ALLEN OR THE OFFICE
OF HEALTH CARE FOR THE BILL IS
THERE AN ANKLE HERE TO TOWARD
TO MATCH ABOUT DECREASING
POLICY WITH THIS PROPOSAL AND
ANY WORK YOU COULD DO WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE TO HELP
US TO. MAKE THAT A STRENGTH IN
THE POSITION OF THIS PROPOSAL
ON FOR THIS ONE BUT WITH THAT
WE WILL HOLD ISSUE SIXTEEN OPEN
AND MOVE ON TO ITS TENTH.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER TO. BY SOME.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
COLLEAGUES FOR ALLOWING ME TO
PRESENT A ONE TIME FIVE MILLION
DOLLAR ASKED TO ENSURE THAT
MEDICAL RESIDENTS IN CALIFORNIA
HAVE ACCESS TO COMPREHENSIVE
REPRODUCTIVE AND TRANSGENDER
HEALTH CARE TRAINING OUR STATE
IS HOME TO OVER FOUR HUNDRED
RESIDENCY PROGRAMS YET MEDICAL
RESIDENTS ACROSS CALIFORNIA
REPORTED THAT ABORTION CARE
TRAINING AND TRAINING TO
PROVIDE JENNER HEALTH CARE
SERVICES IS NOT WIDELY
AVAILABLE FOR EXAMPLE CERTAIN
PROGRAMS OPT OUT DUE TO
RELIGIOUS OR MORE PROJECTIONS
OR OTHER RESTRICTIONS RELATED.
FUND THIS LACK OF TRAIN IS NOT
CONSISTENT WITH OUR USES A
STATE WE'RE COMMITTED TO ALWAYS
PROVIDING PATIENTS WITH THE
RIGHT TO CHOOSE WHATEVER
REPRODUCTIVE OPTIONS THEY WISH
AND WE'RE COMMITTED TO
PROTECTING AND SUPPORTING OUR
TRANSGENDER COMMUNITY.
COMMUNITY GROUPS ACROSS THE
STATE PUTTING PLANNED
PARENTHOOD HAVE BEEN STEPPING
IN WHERE THEY CAN'T TO FILL IN
GAPS IN TRAINING BUT THAT'S
SIMPLY NOT ENOUGH. THIS MODEST
FUNNY SO WOULD FOR THE FIELD IS
TRAINING GAP BY PROVIDING
PROGRAMS THE ABILITY TO ACQUIRE
AND EXPLAIN. N. STREET GENDER
TRAINING OPTIONS THROUGH
ACADEMIC CENTERS AND COMMUNITY
PARTNERS. AND WITH THAT I'D
LIKE TO HIDE BUT UP A WITNESS.
A GOOD AFTERNOON THANK YOU TO
THE CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS LISA
MATSUBARA ON BEHALF OF PLANNED
PARENTHOOD AFFILIATES OF
CALIFORNIA REPRESENTING ALL
SEVEN AFFILIATES IN CALIFORNIA
OPERATING OVER A HUNDRED HEALTH
CENTERS IN THE STATE- AS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TO MENTION THIS
IS A LITTLE FOR A ONE TIME
ALLOCATION OF FIVE MILLION. TO
SUPPORT PHYSICIAN NANCY
TRAINING TO PROVIDE FUNDING YOU
OFFER TRAINING RELATED TO
ABORTION CAME IN CARE THE CIVIC
TRANSGENDER PATIENTS. FIRST WE-
IN BARRIERS TO EDUCATION AND
TRAINING IN ABORTION CARE- THAT
EXIST. PUBLIC FUNDING AND OTHER
RESTRICTIONS ON TEACHING
HOSPITALS LIMIT ABORTION
TRAINING FOR RESIDENTS.
TRAINING MAY BE RESTRICTED TO
OBGYN RESIDENTS BEING
PHYSICIANS AND OTHER
SPECIALTIES SUCH AS FAMILY
MEDICINE WITHOUT ACCESS
TRAINING. AND OFTEN ABORTION
TRAINING PROGRAMS CREATE
BURDENS ON THE TRAIN NEED TO
DEVELOP A CLINICAL EXPERIENCE.
GIVEN THAT ABORTION IS NOT ONLY
SAFE BUT COMMON IS TIME FOR A
STATE TO LEAD ONCE MORE BY
INVESTING IN INCREASING THE
AVAILABILITY OF TRAINING AND
RESIDENCIA GRAMS TO AND ACCESS
AND ABILITY AVAILABILITY TO
RUSSIAN CARE. THIS PART OF THE
PROPOSAL'S BEST TO CALIFORNIA'S
WERE TO SUPPORT HEALTH CARE FOR
TRANSGENDER PATIENTS. TO CONVEY
THE LACK OF TRAINING
OPPORTUNITIES I WOULD LIKE TO
TAKE THE OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE
THE EXPERIENCE OF PARENTHOOD
MARMONT TAY'S GENDER FOR ME
CARE PROGRAM DIRECTOR DR
CASSIDY FREDERIC. WHEN SHE
CHOSE A RESIDENCY IN BOTH ONLY
MEDICINE PSYCHIATRY DR
FREDERICK WANTED TO OBTAIN A
SKILL SET THAT WOULD PREPARE
HER TO SERVE FREQUENTLY
MARGINALIZED POPULATIONS.
UNFORTUNATELY SHE FOUND THAT
THE HEALTH SERVICES FOR
TRANSGENDER PATIENTS WERE NOT
INTEGRATED INTO MEDICAL SCHOOL
OR RESIDENCY EXPERIENCES.
DOCTOR FREDERICK HAD TO SEEK
OUT ADDITIONAL TRAINING
OPPORTUNITIES THROUGH VOLUNTEER
WORK TO GAIN EXPERIENCE IN
ORDER TO PROVIDE SERVICES TO
TRANSGENDER PATIENTS INCLUDING
GENDER AFFIRMING SERVICES LIKE
HORMONE REPLACEMENT THERAPY. I
AM HER AND HAD MORE MONTY IS
WORKING TO MAKE TRANSGENDER
INCLUSIVE CARE CORE SERVICE SO
THAT EVERY SERVICES AFFIRMING
FOR ALL PATIENTS. IN ADDITION
PLANNED PARENTHOOD LOCATIONS
ARE BEGINNING TO INTEGRATE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH CARE ACCESS
FOR TRANSGENDER PATIENTS AND
MAKE GENDER FROM HARM THERAPY
MORE WIDELY AVAILABLE. THESE
SERVICES ARE RECOGNIZE AS BEING
MEDICALLY NECESSARY AND ARE
HEALTH SENATOR MEETING THE
INCREASING NEED FOR THESE
SERVICES HOWEVER THERE ARE
STILL RELATIVELY FEW PROVIDERS
WHO RECEIVE TRAINING IN THIS
AREA AS PART OF THEIR MEDICAL
EDUCATION. IT IS CRUCIAL TO
SUPPORT MATTER SINCE GONE
ACCESS THIS TRAINING.
CALIFORNIA NEEDS TO CONTINUE TO
PUSH FORWARD WHEN IT COMES TO
THE BILL ABILITY OF QUALITY.
CARE FOR ALL PATIENTS THIS
MEANS MAKING THE SMITH THE
SUPPORT PRESIDENCY PROGRAMS IN
PROVIDERS WHO WANT TO BE PART
OF ELIMINATING BARRIERS TO BORE
KAREN FOR TRANSGENDER PATIENTS.
THANK YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY
PROVIDE THIS INTRODUCTORY
INFORMATION FOR THE COMMITTEE
AND LOOK FORWARD TO
COLLABORATING WITH YOUR OFFICE.
THEY'RE STILL. MOVING FORWARD.
YOU MAY AND WITH. PUBLIC SHE
TEN. A FEDERAL TRAINED ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA AND I
THINK HEALTH NETWORK IN SUPPORT
OF THIS PROPOSAL. THANK YOU SIR.
RENTS SPENCER WITH AMERICAN
COLLEGE OBGYN STITCHES NINE IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. MEGAN
SERVERS ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
HEALTH PLUS ADVOCATES IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU MA'AM. SEEING
NO FURTHER PUBLIC COMMENT OR
BRING IT TO THE SUB COMMITTEE
TO SEE IF THERE'S ANY COMMENTS-
I WILL THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER TOO FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD AS I'VE MENTIONED IN
THE PAST- CLICK A DOCTOR WHO I
WORKED WITH DOCTOR BARNETT. WAS
TRANS GENDER HERSELF AND- ENDED
UP LEAVING FRESNO AND LEFT A
HUGE VOID FOR OUR COMMUNITY I
UNDERSTAND THE IMPORTANCE OF.
MAKING SURE THAT TRAINING IS
APPROPRIATE FOR OUR RESIDENTS
AND MEDICAL STYLES TO ENSURE WE
CAN TAKE CARE OF OUR MOST ONE
FULL POPULAR. AS WELL WELL THAT
WE PULLED ISSUE TAP IN AM BONTA.
TWELVE RESEARCH.
THERE. A GOOD
ADVENTURE MEMBERS IS MY
PLEASURE TO BE HERE TO PRESENT
A LOW ABOUT WITH ASIA WITH THE
CALIFORNIA HOSPICE ASSOCIATION
OR REQUESTED TO ASK FOR TWENTY
TWO POINT TWO MILLION ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND FOR THE OFFICE OF
STATE WILL HEALTH PLANNING AND
DEVELOPMENTS SEC THREE
RESIDENTS GRANT PROGRAM TO
SUPPORT ADDITIONAL AN EXISTING
RESIDENCY SLOTS THIS IS A NEW
JOB GRANT THIS IS A NEW GRANT
PROGRAM THAT WAS A STEP THIS
YEAR'S BUDGET THE NINETEENTH.
IT INCLUDES THE PORT FOR MANY
THE TWENTY. TO TWENTY TWENTY.
MHM WORKFORCE EDUCATION AND
TRAINING PROGRAM FIVE YEAR PLAN
WHICH INCLUDES A KAIJU
RESIDENCY. CALIFORNIA FACES A
SEVERE AND GROWING SHORTAGE OF
PSYCHIATRISTS WHICH WILL HAVE A
SIGNIFICANT. NEGATIVE IMPACT ON
ACCESS TO MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES. OVER THE NEXT DECADE
IT IS PROJECTED THAT CALIFORNIA
WILL HAVE A FORTY ONE PERCENT.
FEWER PSYCHIATRIST THEN IT WILL
NEED DUE TO AN AGING WORKFORCE.
THE MAIN REASON THAT PSYCHIATRY
RESIDENCY PROGRAMS IN
CALIFORNIA ARE NOT GROWING.
DEMAND IS LIKE A FIVE. TO WITH
THEM AFFECTED STRATEGIES
INCREASING PSYCHIATRIST IN
CALIFORNIA WE'RE EXPANDING THE
SIZE OF EXISTING PSYCHIATRY
RESIDENCY PROGRAMS AND
ESTABLISHING NEW PSYCHIATRY
RESIDENCYPROGRAMS AS WELL. THE
TWO STRONGEST PREDICTORS WHERE
PHYSICIANS WILL PRACTICE AWAY
FINISH RESIDENCY TRAINING AND
WHERE THE ARRAY. HE GOT. 70% OF
ITS POSITION WHO. CALIFORNIA
REMAIN IN OUR STATE TO
PRACTICE. ACCORDING TO THE
CALIFORNIA FUTURE HEALTH
WORKFORCE COMMISSION REPORT THE
NUMBER OF FIRST YEAR RESIDENTS
IN PSYCHIATRY RESIDENCY
PROGRAMS WOULD INCREASE BY
APPROXIMATELY ONE HUNDRED FIFTY
TWO. WHICH WOULD IELD A TWO
HUNDRED AND 47% PERCENT
INCREASE IN GRADUATE EVER SEKAI
RESIDENCY PROGRAMS BETWEEN NOW
AND TWENTY TWENTY SIX. WE LIKE
TO ACROSS ABOUT THE SIX SEVEN
INDIVIDUAL WENT THROUGH THIS.
WHICH HIGHLIGHTS THE IMPORTANCE
OF GOING OUR OWN PHYSICIANS. I
TALKED ABOUT A JEEP INDEED
MOVED TO BIGGER STILL WITH HR
NAY AND ATTENDED HIGH SCHOOL
AND BAKERSFIELD. SHE RECEIVED
HER B. S. FROM UC IRVINE AN MS
DEGREE ANGLE PSYCHOLOGY FROM
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
BAKERSFIELD. SHE THEN RECEIVE
HER DO FROM LAKE ERIE COLLEGE
OSTEOPATHIC MEDICINE. SHE
JOINED THE PSYCHIATRY TRAINING
PROGRAM SEE LIKE KERN MEDICAL
RESIDENCY AT HOSPITAL IN
TWENTY. AFTER GRADUATION SHE
SERVED AT THE BASE OF VA AS A
PSYCHIATRIST SHE A GROWING
DESIRE TO TEACH AGAIN. BACK TO
SERVE AS FACULTY AKRON MEDICAL
IN THE DEPARTMENT OF PSYCHIATRY
STARTING JULY THE TWENTY TWENTY
SHE'LL BE ASSUMING THE ROLE OF
PROGRAM DIRECTOR FOR PSYCHIATRY
TRAINING OCCURRED MEDICAL. JUST
ONE EXAMPLE OF HOW IMPORTANT IS
TO GROW AND DEVELOP MEDICAL
PROFESSIONALS IN OUR STATE. SO
WE CAN ADDRESS OUR STATE MENTAL
HEALTH TREATMENT NEEDS. THAT
TIME WE LOOK FOR SOLUTIONS. TO
SERVICES IS A CRITICAL PART OF
THE SOLUTION. FOR THESE REASONS
YOU REQUEST IS FUNDING TO
INCREASE OUR CAPACITY FOR
PSYCHOTIC PSYCHIATRIC RESIDENCY
PROGRAMS CALIFORNIA HE VERY
MUCH CHAIR AND MEMBERS. AND BOB
WHICH LIKE TO ADD ANYTHING.
CHAPLAINMEMBERS BARBARA GLAZER
WITH THE CALIFORNIAHOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION THE SPOT THIS BUT
REQUIRE. CAL IS BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH CRISIS HAS PUSHED OUR
HEALTHCARE SYSTEM TO THE
BREAKING POINT NESTED AN
ESTIMATED. ONE POINT FIVE.
PEOPLE IN STATE EXPERIENCE A
MENTAL HEALTH DISORDER AND ANY.
YEAH I WON THIRD OF ADULTS
EXPERIENCED ILLNESS ARE GETTING
TREAT. HOSPITALS AND WELL THE
IMP OF EXPANDING ACCESS TO
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH CARE. EVERY
DAY ARE NURSES THERAPISTS
SOCIAL WORKERS AND OTHERS SEE
FIRSTHAND THE CHALLENGES THAT
PEOPLE WITH BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
CONDITIONS FACING GETTING THE
TREATMENT THEY DESERVE. WE
THINK ONE WAY TO DO IT TO HELP
WITH THIS PROBLEM IS INCREASE
THE NUMBER OF PSYCHIATRISTS WE
HAVE IN THIS STATE AND THIS
PROPOSAL WOULD DO JUST THAT
THANK YOU FOR CONSIDERING.
THANK YOU MA'AM. ANY PUBLIC
COMMENT ON ISSUE TWELFTH.
MORTON HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION PLACE TO SUPPORT
THIS REQUEST THANK YOU MA'AM.
RANDALL HAGER REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA PSYCHIATRIC
ASSOCIATION VERY PLEASED TO
SUPPORT THIS REQUEST THANK YOU
SIR. MY NAME IS ROBERT MCCARRON
A PRESIDENT OF THE CALIFORNIA
PSYCHIATRIC ASSOCIATION AND I
VERY MUCH SUPPORT THIS- ALSO IS
A PSYCHIATRY PROGRAM DIRECTOR-
GLAD TO GLAD THAT WE'RE
DISCUSSING THIS AND THAT
CONSIDERING THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SIR SEEING NO FURTHER
PUBLIC COMMENT ON BRING IT UP
TO THE SUB COMMITTEE TO SEE IF
THERE'S ANY COMMENTS. SEEING
NONE- I DO THINK YOUR SPOT ON
AND LOOKING TOWARDS THE PSYCH
RESIDENCY GRANT PROGRAM- I DO
THINK LATER ON YOU'LL HEAR A
PROPOSAL FROM ONE OF OUR
COLLEAGUES HERE ON THE- MEDI.
WHO ALSO SERVED ON THE HEALTH
CARE WORK FORCE TASK FORCES HE
IS THE EXPERT. WELL BUT- YOU
WERE PROPOSALS ARE SIMILARLY
ALIGNED AND- SEEM LIKE THE
RIGHT. NOW AND SO I MAY
ENCOURAGE THE TWO OF YOU TO
COMMUNICATE AND SEE HOW WE
COULD COLLABORATE AND AS AN OR
AN ISSUES. AND WE ARE
SUPPORTIVE OF EACH OTHER'S
REQUEST. GREAT WITH THAT WE
WILL HOLD ISSUE TWELVE OPENED
FOR NOW AND- IF IT PLEASES THE
MEMBERS I'D LIKE TO GO BACK IN-
ISSUE ORDER SO WE WILL NOW MOVE
ON TO ISSUE ELEVEN WITH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER EGGMAN.
FOLLOWED BY ISSUES TEAM
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GALLAGHER AN
ISSUE FOURTEEN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GRAY. WHEN YOU'RE READY SENATOR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- AND WE'RE
ALL TALKING ABOUT MENTAL HEALTH
HERE TODAY AND HOPING IT
IMPROVES FOR ALL OF US- AND AS
WE'RE TRYING TO TEACH TRAIN
MORE PSYCHIATRIST- WE ALSO KNOW
THAT OFTEN PEOPLE SHOW UP FOR-
PSYCHIATRIC ISSUES IN PRIMARY
CARE AND SO THAT'S WHAT THIS
BILL OR THIS BUDGET ASK TEN
POINT FIVE MILLION DOLLAR
BUDGET ASK ASKED THAT WE ALLOW
CONTINUE MISSION OF A
FELLOWSHIP PROGRAMME WHERE
PHYSICIANS- DAYS NURSE
PRACTITIONERS CAN DO A YEAR
LONG FELLOWSHIP. IS THERE UC
DAVIS UC IRVINE THEIR
PSYCHIATRY PROGRAM- FOR THEM TO
BE TRAINED IN HOW TO MORE THAN
AT HOW DO USE EVIDENCE BASED
CRITERIA TO ASSESS PEOPLE WHEN
THEY COME AND WE KNOW A LOT OF
PEOPLE COME IN. THE SAMANTHA
SIZE YOU KNOW THEIR FEELINGS
INTO SYMPTOMS A COMMAND AND
PEOPLE ARE MORE TRAINED THEY'RE
MORE ABLE THAN TO TREAT THEM
PROPERLY THROUGH A MEDICATION
REGIME BECAUSE AS WE KNOW IT'S
VERY HARD TO GET TO SEE A
PSYCHIATRIST. TO OFTENTIMES
PRIMARY CARE PROVIDERS END UP
PROVIDING THAT LEVEL OF CARE
AND WE WANTED TO BE AS
COMFORTABLE AND AS
KNOWLEDGEABLE WITH EVIDENCE
BASE. UP AS WE CANCER WITH ME
HERE TODAY I HAVE RANDALL HAGAR.
AND AS WELL AS DOCTOR. WE CAME
IN WHO YOU'VE HEARD FROM
PREVIOUSLY THANK YOU I DON'T
RECOMMEND. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
SUBCOMMITTEE MEMBERS AND ALSO-
THANKS FOR SUPPORT ASSEMBLY
WOMAN AND A MAN I REALLY
APPRECIATE IT MY NAME IS ROBERT
MCCARRON- I I'M A PRIMARY CARE
DOCTOR. AND I'M ALSO
PSYCHIATRIST AND I KNOW WHAT
IT'S LIKE TO BE SORT OF IN THE
TRENCHES OF VERTICALLY PRIMARY
CARE THE TYPICAL PRIMARY CARE
VISIT IS ANYWHERE FROM TEN TO
FIFTEEN MINUTES FOR A FOLLOW UP
VISIT WHICH IS WAY TOO SHORT IN
MY OPINION. IT'S HARD TO GET
DELIVER CARE DEEPLY ONCE
COMPLICATED CARE INVOLVING
DEPRESSION AND ANXIETY- IT'S
CHALLENGING TO SAY THE LEAST
I'VE HAD THE PRIVILEGE OF
WORKING LARGELY WITH
UNDERSERVED AND VULNERABLE
UNIQUELY VULNERABLE
CALIFORNIANS- FOR MOST OF MY
CAREER BOTH IN SACRAMENTO UC
DAVIS THAT. GREAT CARE AT
UNIVERSITY CALVET PROVIDE
SCHOOL MEDICINE APARTMENTS
OCCASION ALSO THE PRESIDENT THE
CALIFORNIA PSYCHIATRIC
ASSOCIATION. HER CDC
INFORMATION SICIDES HAVE GONE
UP ABOUT 30% FOR THE LAST
DECADE IN ALL AGE GROUPS HUGE
PROBLEM. DEPRESSION NUMBER ONE
CAUSE OF DISABILITY AMONG
ADULTS IN THIS COUNTRY IN THE
STATE. HOMELESS POPULATION
CONTINUES TO RISE IN ALL AREAS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. CHRONIC
PAIN IS CLOSELY CLOSELY TIED
WITH DEPRESSION AND ANXIETY
PARTICULAR AND OPIOIDS
CURRENTLY THE NUMBER ONE CAUSE
OF ACCIDENTAL DEATHS IN THIS
COUNTRY HUGE PROBLEMS. WE DON'T
HAVE ENOUGH PSYCHIATRISTS.
WOULD BE GREAT IF WE HAD MORE
WE NEED A TWENTY YEAR PLAN HAVE
MORE PSYCHIATRIST AND I HOPE WE
GET THERE BUT WE DON'T HAVE WE
DON'T HAVE ENOUGH RGHT NOW
THIS PROJECTED SHORTAGE IS
DEFINITELY- ON THE RISE AND
FORTUNATELY. OVER 65% OF ALL
YOU EVER HEALTH CARE IS NOT
DELIVERED BY PSYCHOLOGISTS NOT
DELIVERED BY SOCIAL WORKERS OR
PSYCHIATRIST DELIVERED BY
PRIMARY CARE PROVIDERS IN A
VERY BUSY BUSY SETTING- NOW.
THE PROBLEM WITH THAT. ISTHAT
PRIMARY CARE PROVIDERS JUST
DIDN'T GET THE TRAINING NOW I'M
IN INTERNET STATE THREE YEARS
OF RESIDENCY TRAINING AFTER
MEDICAL SCHOOL. DURING THOSE
THREE YEARS OF RESIDENCY
TRAINING THE AMERICAN BOARD OF
INTERNAL MEDICINE MANDATES ZERO
MINUTES. ZERO MINUTES. FOR
CLINICAL PSYCHIATRIC TRAINING
NOW. SHOULD YOU GET SOME
LECTURES AND THINGS THAT AFFECT
CERTAINLY PROBABLY FOR LECTURES
A YEAR- WHICH IS WHICH IS TO
WHICH DOESN'T CUT IT AND STATE
CALIFORNIA PHYSICIAN
ASSISTANTS. HAVE REQUIREMENT OF
TWO WEEKS OF TRAINING. TWO
WEEKS OF TRAINING MENTAL HEALTH
YEAH THESE ARE FOLKS ON THE
FRONT LINE THERE ON THE
FRONTLINE. THERE ARE THE
FRONTLINE BUT THEY DON'T HAVE
THE TRAINING OR THE EXPERIENCE
SO WHAT'S THE SOLUTION OF THIS
I'VE LAID OUT SORT OF A BRIEF
SYNOPSIS OF THE PROBLEM WHAT'S
THE SOLUTION I THINK. ONE PART
OF THE SOLUTION IS TO
CALIFORNIA IS TO FIND A WAY TO
MEANINGFULLY. IT'S A STANDARD
REALLY EXPAND AND OPTIMIZE.
MENTAL HEALTH CARE PSYCHIATRIC
CARE DELIVERY- SO WE CAN DO
THAT WE'VE BEEN DOING THAT FOR
THE LAST COUPLE YEARS WITH THE
HELP OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. ALL OF YOU- BY WAY
OF THE TRAIN NEW TRAINERS
PRIMARY CARE PSYCHIATRY
FELLOWSHIP PROGRAM AGAIN THE
IDEA IS TO EXPAND AND OPTIMIZE.
THE WORK FORCE THE PSYCHIATRIC
WORKFORCE. WE'VE BEEN ABLE.
OVER THE LAST FEW YEARS. TO
INCREASE PRIMARY CARE
PSYCHIATRIC KNOWLEDGE RIGHT
QUANTIFIABLE INCREASE- THE
KNOWLEDGE BASE OF PRIMARY CARE
PROVIDERS IN THE STATE. WE'VE
ALSO INCREASE THE COMFORT AND
SKILL SET LEVEL- FOR PRIMARY
CARE PROVIDERS IN WHEN IT COMES
TO PREVENTION. TREATMENT AND
DIAGNOSIS OF COMMON PSYCHIATRIC
DISORDERS WE DECREASE STIGMA
AMONG OUR GRADUATES AND I THINK
MOST IMPORTANTLY WE'VE BEEN IN
A SITUATION WE'VE BEEN TO WE'VE
BEEN ABLE TO- REALLY.
DRAMATICALLY EXPONENTIALLY
INCREASED THE WORK FORCE BY
TRAINING THESE TRAINERS HOW TO
TRAIN OTHER PEOPLE IN THE
REGION SO IT'S BEEN A GREAT
OPPORTUNITY AND LOOKING FORWARD
TO CONTINUE AND I WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION.
WITH A GOAL IN MIND OF FURTHER
EXPANSION EVIDENCE BASED
EXPANSION IN OPPOSITION OF
PSYCHIATRIC CARE CALIFORNIA
THANK YOU. THINK IT'LL TURN
RANDALL HAGER FOR THE
PSYCHIATRIC ASSOCIATION HERE TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THANK YOU
SIR WE WILL NOW TAKE PUBLIC
COMMENT ON ISSUE ELEVEN. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN WHERE'S MY
CONSUMERS ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA HEALTH PLUS
ADVOCATES WE'VE HAD A NUMBER OF
HEALTH CENTERS HAPPY FORTUNATE
ENOUGH TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
THIS PROGRAM WITH A REALLY
GREAT PROGRAM IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU MA'AM SEEING NO FURTHER
PUBLIC COMMENT ON BRING IT UP
TO THE SUBCOMMITTEE TO SEE IF
THERE'S ANY COMMENTS. DR WHAT.
I THINK I WOULD THINK YOU-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER EGGMAN ON YOU.
IN A FUTURE TITLE LATER BUT-
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD
ACTUALLY I'M JUST A COMMENT
JUST IN GENERAL WHAT EVERYBODY
WHO. WAS GOING TO BRING IN
SOMETHING FOR RELATED TO MENTAL
HEALTH HERE TODAY. AND I THINK
THE LATEST IS TO SICK I HEARD
HEARD WAS IT 26% OF OUR
PATIENTS AND ARE FEDERALLY
QUALIFIED HEALTH CENTERS. HAVE
SOME SORT OF BEHAVIORAL HEALTH.
AND I KNOW THAT IN MY OWN
DISTRICT. THE DISTRICT- PRIMARY
CARE IS A IS A BIG CHALLENGE-
PER WITH PROVIDERS AND THAT
MEANS YOU KNOW THAT MEANS THAT
PEOPLE ARE NOT GETTING THE CARE
THAT THEY THEY NEED ESPECIALLY
IF A LARGE PORTION WHAT WAS A
PORTION DOCTOR MCCARRON YOU
SAID HOW MANY PEOPLE. HOW MUCH
CARE IS DELIVERED BY PRIMARY
CARE OF ABOUT 65% ABOUT SIX OF
ALL BE ABLE HEALTHCARE SLIVER
BY PRIMARY CARE PROVIDERS YEAH
OKAY SO- THAT'S A AND I CAN SEE
THAT WOULD BE A CHALLENGE WHEN
WE'RE ALSO LACKING. PRIMARY
CARE PROVIDER MANY IN MANY
AREAS SO- I'VE WON SUPPORT
PROGRAM IT'S I THINK IT'S GREAT
A GREAT PROGRAM AND WILL
CONTINUE ALONG WITH OTHER
PROPOSALS AS WELL. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WOULD YOU KNOW I WILL
JUST TO BE TRANSPARENT WE
FUNDED THIS PROGRAM THE LAST
TWO YEARS AND- ARE A BIG
BELIEVER IN- TRYING TO MAKE
SURE WORK STANDING TO PRIMARY
CARE. AND SO- AGAIN WOULD JUST
ASK THAT WE TRIED TO
COLLABORATEAS MUCH AS WE CAN
WITH DOCTOR WOULD. REGARDING
HIS PROPOSAL AS THIS COMMITTEE
WILL ATTEMPT TO. BRAID ALL OF
THE PROPOSALS INTO ONE UNIFORM
PROPOSAL AND WOULD LIKE TO.
HAVE YOU BY RATE AS MUCH AS WE
CAN TO MAKE SURE THIS GETS
INCLUDED SWABS. WITHOUT WILL
HOLD ISSUE ELEVEN OPEN AND MOVE
ON TO IT TO THIRTY. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
AM PLEASED TO PRESENT TO YOU A
PROPOSAL THIS MORNING- FOR A
ONE TIME GENERAL FUND
ALLOCATION OF TWENTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS TO THE OFFICE
OF STATEWIDE HEALTH PLANNING
AND DEVELOPMENT FOR THE PURPOSE
OF FUNDING THE CREATION OF A
NEW MEDICAL RESIDENCY PROGRAM
AND RURAL NORTHERN CAP. FORMULA
THE A TOPIC OF DISCUSSION FOR
TODAY IS THIS THE LACK OF-
PRIMARY CARE PROVIDERS- AND I
KNOW THAT THAT'S AN ISSUE IN
MANY PARTS OF CALIFORNIA BUT
IT'S CERTAINLY- PRETTY ACUTE IN
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA RIGHT NOW.
THE PROPOSAL WOULD ALLOCATE
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR
OVER THE PERIOD OF FIVE FISCAL
YEARS AND HAS THE POTENTIAL TO
BRING THIRTY TO FIFTY MEDICAL
RESIDENTS TO UNDERSERVED AREAS
IN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA. WHERE
PHYSICAL MENTAL HEALTH HAVE
SOME OF THE LOWEST OUT COMES IN
THE STATE. THE NEED IS
ESPECIALLY CRITICAL IN THE
AFTERMATH OF THE DEVASTATING
CAMPFIRE. DIRECTION OF HEALTH
CARE INFRASTRUCTURE. WAS NOT
LIMITED TO PHYSICAL STRUCTURES-
IS ALSO DEPLETED THE HEALTH
CARE WORK FORCE IS ESTIMATED
THAT 10215% OF PHYSICIANS LEFT
THE AREA AFTER THE FIRE.
ADDITIONALLY MANY CURRENTLY
PRACTICING PHYSICIANS ARE
EXPECTED TO RETIRE IN THE NEXT
FIVE YEARS. I'VE BEEN WORKING
CLOSELY WITH THE BUTTE GLENN
MEDICAL SOCIETY ON THIS ISSUE
THEY'VE ACTUALLY FORMED A
RESIDENCY TASK FORCE. AND I'VE
ALREADY BROUGHT TOGETHER MANY
DIFFERENT PARTNERS TO WORK ON
THIS INCLUDING UC DAVIS CSU
CHICO AND LOW MEDICAL CENTER
BUTTE COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH.
ANTHEM BLUE CROSS AND
PHYSICIANS FOR A HEALTHY
CALIFORNIA THE TASK FORCE'S
FORMING THE NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL EDUCATION PROGRAM TO
SUPPORT THESE PROPOSED MEDICAL
RESIDENCY PROGRAMS AND HELP
RECRUIT RESIDENTS- WHEN THE
PROGRAMS OF LUNCHEON WITH ME
TODAY ACTUALLY HAVE DOCTOR
DAVID ALONSO. FROM THE MEDICAL
SOCIETY TO HIMSELF I LIKE TO
POINT OUT AS WE'VE TALKED ABOUT
THIS ISSUE IS FROM NEW
HAMPSHIRE- BUT HAPPEN TO DO HIS
CLINICAL WORK IN CHICO- FELL IN
LOVE WITH THE AREA WILL BE ABLE
TO KEEP HIM HERE AND- WE ARE
CERTAINLY PLEASED THAT WE HAVE
HIM- BUT WE WANT TO. WANT TO
GET MORE OF DR DAVID ALONSO'S-
SO WITH THAT I'LL TURN IT OVER
TO HIM TO PRESENT A LITTLE BIT
MORE ON THIS ITEM THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS AND SOME A
GALLAGHER FOR THAT MESSAGE. DR
DAVID ALONSO. SERVING A COUPLE
ROLLS PRESIDENT BE GLENN
MEDICAL SOCIETY COMPONENT OF
THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION. BUT ALSO AS A MORE
IMPORTANTLY A PRIVATE PRACTICE
INTERNAL MEDICINE FUNCTION
PRIMARY CARE. ALMOST TEN YEARS
NOW IN BUTTE COUNTY IN CHICO.
IN A GREAT PLACE. AND ON THE
FRONT LINES OF SEEING THE
STRUGGLE THAT WE HAVE OF NOT
HAVING ENOUGH PROVIDERS IN OUR
AREA. WHEN I CAME TO THE AREA.
I WAS TOLD THERE WAS NEED OF
ABOUT TWENTY OR MORE PRIMARY
CARE PHYSICIAN JUSTIN ARE THE
MEDIA REGION- HERE WE ARE TEN
YEARS LATER I BELIEVE OUR NET
NUMBERS ABOUT FIVE LESS THAN
WHAT WE HAD WHEN I FIRST CAME.
TO THE AREA. AND OUT. FIND OUT
THE CAMPFIRE AS ASSEMBLYMAN
MENTIONED ONE ABOUT FORTY
PHYSICIANS A THIRTY TO FORTY
PHYSICIANS THAT LEFT THE AREAS
WAS. IN A PURPOSES OF THEIR
HOME. AND JUST. OF THE SHIFTING
THE NEEDS. FOR WORKING LOWER
WITH PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICER AND
ALSO REINFORCING THAT THEY SEE
THAT THERE'S A- NEED IF WE LOOK
AT. CAN YOU. STRICTLY SPEAKING
WITHIN OUR ONE NOT OF NORTHERN
IT'S ESTIMATED THERE'S PROBABLY
NEED FOR A HUNDRED HUNDRED AND
FORTY- PRIMARY CARE PHYSICIANS
CURRENTLY THE NUMBER STAND
SOMEWHERE BETWEEN FORTY TO
FIFTY- EVIDENCING A HUGE LACK
OF THEIR AND THAT'S JUST
PRIMARY CARE NOT TO MENTION
PSYCHIATRY IS ALSO HAS BEEN
MENTIONED BY THE PREVIOUS
SPEAKERS IS IN DESPERATE NEED
SO WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH HER
ASSEMBLY MAY GALLAGHER AND HIS
OFFICE TO. LOOK FOR SOLUTIONS
FIND TANGIBLE SOLUTIONS AND
PART OF THAT IS LOOKING FOR
THIS FUNDING REQUEST AND THAT
IS TO SUPPORT NEW RESIDENCY
PROGRAMS THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF
FUNDING THAT'S BEEN- BROUGHT
FORWARD IT'S BEEN WONDERFUL TO
HELP EXISTING PROGRAMS EXPAND
BUT A CHALLENGE WE HAVE IN
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA IS THAT
BEING A WORLD SO COMMUNITY
BEING THAT THERE'S LESS IN THE
WAY OF LARGE HEALTH SYSTEMS OR
UNIVERSITIES WE DON'T HAVE
EXISTING PROGRAMS. THAT ARE
THAT ARE VERY LIMITED UP IN AND
THE THING AREA BUT THE WHOLE
REGION REALLY NEEDS A MUCH MORE
ROBUST- EDUCATIONAL ENVIRONMENT
AS A PREVIOUS SPEAKER MAY THAT
WHEN THE PREDICTOR OF
PHYSICIANS PRACTICING AN AREA
IS DOING SOME OF THEIR TRAINING
IN AN AREA I WOULD NUMBER OF
PEOPLE COME TO BE VERY FOR MOST
A IN THAT IT YES CAN THIS ONE
UP THE STAFF IS NEW PROGRAM
EVAN OF. YLIDES HAVE TOGETHER
AS PART OF A TASK FORCE THAT BE
WORKING ACTIVE IN COLLABORATIVE
WE WITH THE IN. WITH THE HAAS
IS TO. WITH YOU CAN A BEHAVIOR
HEALTH WITH NORTHERN VALLEY
INDIAN HEALTH- EVEN BRINGING IN
DISCUSSIONS OF CALIFORNIA
HEALTH AND WELLNESS ANTHEM BLUE
CROSS THEY'VE BEEN ON BOARD
WITH US. FOR DAMAGING THESE
PROGRAMS BUT THE SMALL
COMMUNITY. FACILITIES AND
HOSPITALS UNFORTUNATELY THE
FUNDING IN THE RESOURCES TO BE
ABLE TO GET THESE OFF THE
GROUND SO WE'RE LOOKING FOR
THIS. I REQUEST OVER THE NEXT
FIVE YEARS TO BRING SOME
TANGIBLE RESULTS- TO OUR
COMMUNITY BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT.
WE CAN MAKE A DIFFERENCE WE CAN
MAKE A DIFFERENCE IN THESE. THE
LACK OF CARE IN OUR COMMUNITIES
AND ALL OF A NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA. SO THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME THANK YOU FOR YOUR-
LISTENING AND WE REALLY HOPE WE
CAN THIS- REQUEST. THANK YOU
SIR- WE WILL NOW TAKE PUBLIC
COMMENT ON ISSUES THIRTEEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON. QUINN GREGORY-
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF CLASS IN
ABOUT A YUBA SUTTER AND COLUSA
COUNTY MEDICAL SOCIETY. IN
SUPPORT OF THIS REQUEST THANK
YOU SIR. MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
AND DR JAMES FLOOD- PRIOR
PRESIDENT OF THE BE GLENN
COUNTY MEDICAL SOCIETY. DOUBLE
BOARDED- CURRENTLY IN
CONFERENCE OF BREAST CARE AND
FOR THIS ASK- THIS PROVIDES A
SUSTAINABLE PATH OF GROWTH SO
THAT WE CAN ACTUALLY GROW
RESIDENTS ORGANICALLY IN A
PRIMARY CARE DESERT IN MENTAL
HEALTH CARE DESERT AND WE THANK
YOU FOR THAT. THANK YOU SIR. HI
I'M DOCTOR DANIEL HER WEDDING
AND I'M ALSO COMING IN TODAY
FROM BUTTE COUNTY I'M A
PRACTICING FAMILY MEDICINE
PHYSICIAN I JUST WANT TO
EMPHASIZE THAT WE REALLY HAVE A
LOT IN NEED- AND GROWING OUR
OWN. YOU KNOW GROW GROW OUR OWN
DOCTORS WE DON'T HAVE TO GET IN
SOMEWHERE ELSE- BUT WE DO NEED
ASSISTANCE AND IN DOING THAT
THANK YOU THANK YOU DOCTOR.
KELLY BE MY BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT OF THIS PROPOSAL I
WE APPRECIATE THE WORK OF THE
TASK FORCE AND ALSO RECOGNIZE
THE NEED FOR DO YOU MEAN NAIVE
PROGRAMS MEANING. A PROGRAM
DOESN'T EVEN EXIST YET- SO WE
KNOW THAT THAT IS A DEFINITE
NEED IN THE STATE CALIFORNIA'S
AN EXPORTER OF MEDICAL STUDENTS
SO THIS IS A STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION IN A SPECIFIC
COMMUNITY THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MATT SEE NO FURTHER PUBLIC
COMMENT TO BRING IT UP TO THE
SUBCOMMITTEE. DOCTOR WOULD. THE
QUESTION- TO BOTH OF YOU
ACTUALLY SO. YOU ENVISION THE
THIS IS FIVE MILLION ANNUALLY
FOR FIVE YEARS ENVISIONED THAT
BEING FOCUSED IN BI<c.cyan> COUNTY.</c>
OR AS I SEE OF OTHER SUPPORTERS
HERE SO. CAN YOU EXPLAIN HOW
WHAT WHAT YOUR WHAT YOUR GOAL
IS THERE. THE GOALS MORE BROAD
A WORLD IN VIEW COUNTY WE'VE
BEEN AT THE END OF THE NIGHT AS
THE LIGHTNING ROD TO TRY TO
BRING THIS- TO ATTENTION. BUT
WE'VE ALSO BROUGHT IN THE LOTS
SURROUNDING MEDICAL COMMUNITIES
THINKING RED BLUFF READING DOWN
TO YOU BE CITY IN THAT AREA
REALLY WHO ARE VISION THIS AS
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA. THAT'S WHY
WERE ADDRESSING A SUCH KIND OF
THAT POPULATION IF YOU WILL
THAT'S NORTH OF SACRAMENTO. SO
I KNOW. THAT YOU HAVE HUMBLE
DON'T NORDMANN SEEN A LAKE-
THEY THEY IRONICALLY HAVE NEW
RESIDENCY PROGRAM- THAT WERE
ESTABLISHED IN THE LAST COUPLE
OF YEARS SO- SO I AND THE
REASON. THEIR RESIDENCY
PROGRAMS AND LOOK I'M GONNA SAM
I AM. OF MORE RESIDENCY
PROGRAMS PERIOD- I SEE THE NEED
IN MY OWN COMMUNITIES AND YOU
YOURSELF ILLUSTRATED THERE. NOW
THE NEW. IS TO A PRIME CARE. IS
DECLINE. AS WE HAVE SEEN- AND
AGING AND THROUGHOUT THROUGHOUT
THE STATE- I KNOW THAT THE
COSTS FOR THESE PROGRAMS LIKE-
IT IN YOU CHI- IN AND ALSO IN
EUREKA- ARE ARE VERY VERY
EXPENSIVE. AND IF I'M- IF I
REMEMBER CORRECTLY IN HUMBLE
COUNTY IT'S A COUPLE MILLION
DOLLARS A YEAR TO KEEP THE
PROGRAM GOING. SO I'M LOOKING
AT THE NUMBERS AND I'M
WONDERING. HOW DO YOU MAKE THIS
WORK BECAUSE THIS CAMP THIS
CAN'T BE THE WHOLE THIS CAN'T
BE THE WHOLE NOT CRIED QUITE
FRANKLY. THE IS TO HELP WITH
THE STARTING A PROGRAMS AS THE
TERM THAT WAS USED GMC NAIVE
AREAS. A SOME OF THE EXISTING
FUNDING RESOURCES ARE OUT THERE
FROM THE TOBACCO TAX INITIATIVE
ANOTHER FINDINGS ARE FOR
EXISTING PROGRAMS. SO OUR
EMPHASIS IS IN. WHAT CAN BE
DONE TO HELP GET THESE PROGRAM
STARTED IN BROAD TO MORE OF THE
REGION RATHER THAN JUST THE
HUMBOLDT IN THE OTHER AREAS
THAT HAVE AN A RATING HAS A
SMALL PROGRAM THAT'S- BEEN
GOING. WE'RE LOOKING TO EXPAND
THAT ACROSS THE REGION. WITH
HOPES THAT ONCE PROGRAMS ARE UP
AND RUNNING. THEN THEY CAN BE
ABLE TO ALSO TAP INTO THE
EXISTING FUNDING STRUCTURES
THAT HAVE BEEN PUT IN. THIS FOR
CONTINUED SUSTAINABLE
FUNCTIONING. IN THE NAMES OF
THE DIFFERENT PRESIDENCIES OF
LOOKING AT. TYPES AND TALKING
ABOUT THIS IS OUR INTENT IS THE
NEED IS BROAD. PRIMARY CARE IS
THERE PSYCHIATRY IS THERE. BUT
THERE'S ALSO A NEED FOR THE
SPECIALIST ESPECIALLY IN UP IN
OUR RURAL AREA I MEAN I CAN
SPEAK TO JUST ON FRIDAY I HAD A
PATIENT WHO WAS. FRUSTRATED
WITH HOW HE'S HAVING TO TRAVEL
FROM SHE GO DOWN TOWARD.
SACRAMENTO AREA TO GET HIS
SPECIALTY CURES FOR UROLOGIST
HE COULDN'T. GET INTO SOMEONE
LOCALLY SHORE OF ABOUT THREE
MONTHS. AND THESE ARE VERY REAL
ISSUE SO WE HAVE PRIMARY CARE
PSYCHIATRY BUT WE'RE ALSO. NOT
LIMITING IT TO THAT WE KNOW WE
NEED TO SURGERY OBGYN AT SOME
ESPECIALLY CARE WE HAVE SOME OF
THE HOSPITAL'S. PARTY SHOW
COMMITTEE TO SEE THAT THEY'RE
READY AND THEY WANT TO. START
MOVING IN THAT DIRECT. THANK
YOU. THANK UP SOME ALMOST THANK
YOU MISTER JUST SOME OF THE ON
YOU MENTION TRIBAL AND INDIAN
HOW IN YOUR PRESENT. SO HOW
MUCH THE TWENTY MILLION THE
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT OVER HE
FIVE YEARS WOULD BE ALLOCATED
TOWARDS THAT AND WHAT DO YOU
ENVISION- WITH THE RESOURCES
THAT WOULD GO ON TO HELP THOSE
TRIBAL COMMUNITIES. THERE BEEN
PART OF THE COALITION PART OF
THE TASK FORCE IN TERMS OF
LOOKING FOR RESIDENCY SITES.
IT'S STILL A LITTLE BIT UP IN
THE YEARS TO. WOULD BE HOSTED
BYONE OF THE LOCAL HOSPITALS
ANY CHEESE AREAS WITH ROTATIONS
WITHIN EACH OF THESE FACILITIES
THOSE ARE DISCUSSIONS THAT ARE
STILL ON GOING TO THE EXACT
PROPORTION HOW MUCH WOULD BE A
TRIBAL HEALTH HOW MUCH WOULD BE
AT THE EXISTING HOSPITAL
FACILITIES- BUT THEY'VE BEEN
PART OF THIS TASK FORCE SUPPORT
DISCUSSION CAN THEY'VE TOLD US.
EXPRESS INTEREST THEY'RE READY
TO. BE PART OF THIS INTO HOST
AND DO SOME OF THE TRAINING AND
TEACHING BECAUSE ARE LOOKING
FOR IS ADDITIONAL SUPPORT IS.
SO I'M GLAD ON GOING DIE. IS TO.
SO GET MORE CLARITY AS THE
PROPOSAL MOVES FOR. YEAH AND
THEY AND SO THEY ARE PART OF
THE COALITION IS COME TOGETHER-
AND CERTAINLY- SO FOR INSTANCE
NORTH VALLEY INDIAN HEALTH AND
FOR THE RIVER TRAVEL HEALTH OF
BEEN CRITICAL PARTNERS IN
PROVIDING RURAL HEALTH CARE IN
THESE AREAS- HE BUT I THINK
BOTH OF THEM OFF UPGRADE FQHCS.
CURRENTLY AND SO. IT THEY ARE
PART OF THIS. BROADER COALITION
AND I WOULD SAY A VERY KEY PART
OF THAT COALITION TO HELP
ESTABLISH THESE RESIDENCY
PROGRAMS AND AGAIN THIS WOULD.
THIS WOULD HELP JUMP START THEM
BUT WE'RE STILL WE ARE BRINGING
IN PRIVATE WE'RE BRINGING IN
ALL THE DIFFERENT PARTNERS TO
TRY AND HELP MAKE THIS HAPPEN
AND MAKE IT SUSTAINABLE LONG
TERM. I MAY HAVE A FEW
SUGGESTIONS IF I CAN I HEARD
SOME- COMMENTS REGARDING HOW WE
COULD INCENTIVIZE AND SO I
JUST. WOULD BE REMISS IF I
DIDN'T MENTION THE LOAN
REPAYMENT PROGRAM THAT WAS
PRESENT WITHIN PROP FIFTY SIX.
THAT HELPS COMMUNITIES MUCH
LIKE YOURS AND MINE TO BE ABLE
TO HELP TO RECRUIT. RESIDENTS
TO AREAS- IN PREVIOUS YEARS
WE'VE ALSO PASSED IN OUR
NATIONAL MAP MEDICAL GRADUATES.
A PROGRAM OUT OF UCLA THAT WAS
A PILOT THAT WAS CODIFIED THAT
IS SOMETHING THAT CAN BE
EXPANDED TO OTHER UC'S. AND
MAYBE SOMETHING THAT YOU
CONSIDER LOOKING AT A UC DAVIS
TO SEE IF WE CAN HELP TO PLACE
DOCTORS AN AREA. AND FIND A I
WOULD RECOMMEND THE DIRECTION
THAT AGAIN DOCTOR WHAT IT'S
GOING AND WHICH IS. HEALTH
RESOURCES AND SERVICES
ADMINISTRATION THERE'S A
TEACHING HEALTH CENTER GM ME A
MODEL SIMILAR TO THE FQHCS YOU
MENTIONED. WHICH ARE FOR NEW
SIGHTS NEW AREAS WE CAN HELP TO
PLACE REPRESENTS. BUT WANT YOU
TO TRY TO COLLABORATE THAT AREA
BECAUSE I. THAT'S A GOOD MODEL
FOR A LOOK AT. FOR HOW WE TRAIN
THE- PEOPLE WHO. WORK IN UNDER
SERVED. THAT WE WILL HOLD ISSUE
THIRTY OPEN AND THANK YOU FOR
PRESENTATION. FROM NOT MISS NEW
HAMPSHIRE'S MOTTO IS LIVE FREE
OR DIE. IT SURE IS. WITH THAT
WE WILL HOLD ISSUE THIRTEEN
OPEN AND MOVE ON TO ISSUE FORTY.
THE GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS. I'M A FOR YOU TODAY ON
ISSUE NOT UNFAMILIAR TO- DOCTOR
REGULAR DOCTOR WOULD HAVE BEEN
BEFORE- SEVERAL POLICY
COMMITTEES I'VE BEEN BEFORE
THIS COMMITTEE. DRILLING DOWN
OR WHATEVER A LOT OF- IN THESE
PRESENTATIONS THAT PRECEDED
THIS PRESENTATION ON ACCESS TO
CARE AND REALLY THE FAILED-
EFFORT OF. THE STATE. AND THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO DELIVER
ON THE PROMISE. OF AVAILABLE
AFFORDABLE CARE TO EVERYONE
WE'VE DONE A GREAT JOB OF
EXPANDING COVERAGE. THROUGHOUT
THIS COUNTRY THROUGHOUT THE
STATE WE'VE SPENT BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS IN THE TIME WE'VE ALL
SERVED HERE TOGETHER OVER THE
COURSE LAST. FIVE SEVEN YEARS.
BUT THE REALITY IS REALLY GOING
TO COMMUNITIES LIKE MINE LIKE
DOCTOR RANDALL'S LIKE DOCTOR
WOODS AND OTHERS. THERE IS A
LACK OF SUPPLY OF HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS. AND WHILE YOU
MAY BE ABLE TO GO TO AN
EMERGENCY ROOM YOU CAN DO THAT
WITHOUT INSURANCE COVERAGE WE
ALL KNOW THAT AND SO I'M BEFORE
YOU TODAY WITH- SEVERAL
REQUESTS YOU KNOW- YOUR ADDRESS
THIS SUPPLY PHYSICIANS NURSE
PRACTITIONERS MENTAL HEALTH
SPECIALIST NURSES- MY
CONSTITUENTS ARE STILL FORCED
TO. TAKE THAT EMERGENCY ROOM
CARE- THE SAME PLACE THEY WERE
BEFORE THE COMMITTEE AS WELL AS
CHAIR WHICH PAUL SECURITY HAVE
PURSUED SEVERAL SHORT SHORT AND
LONG TERM SOLUTION TO THIS
PROBLEM BUT THIS IS A DIFFICULT
SYSTEM PROBLEM. SO MORE MUST BE.
TODAY I ASKED WE DOUBLE DOWN
THOSE EFFORTS AND PUT OUR MONEY
WHERE OUR MOUTH IS AS THE
CALIFORNIA FUTURE HEALTH
WORKFORCE COMMISSION'S FINAL
REPORT CLEARLY OUTLINES WE NEED
A COMPLEMENT OF INVESTMENTS
THAT WILL SUPPORT THOSE WORKING
IN HEALTHCARE TODAY AS WELL AS
SUPPORTING THOSE AND
ENCOURAGING THE NEXT
GENERATION. MY REQUESTED THEIR
CONSISTENT WITH THE
RECOMMENDATIONS. TOGETHER WITH
THE CALIFORNIA PRIMARY CARE
ASSOCIATION WE'RE REQUESTING A
NEW ONE TIME GENERAL FUND
INVESTMENT TOTALING FORTY NINE
POINT SEVEN MILLION TO SUPPORT
THE TRAINING. AND PRACTICE OF
THE DANCE PRACTICE CONDITIONS
AND UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES.
THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY AS ONE
OF JUST THREE REGIONS WITH LESS
THAN FIFTY PRIMARY CARE
PHYSICIAN FOR ONE THOUSAND.
PEOPLE ADVANCED PRACTICE CAN
CONDITIONS ARE PART OF THE
SHORT SOLUTION N. P. ISN'T P.
A.'S ARE MORE LIKELY TO WORK IN
RURAL COMMUNITIES REFLECT THE
DIVERSITY OF MY COMMUNITY. FOR
THIS REASON WE'RE ASKING FOR
NEW INVESTMENTS TO SUPPORT THE
EXPANSION OF N. P. TRAINING AND
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES AT UC
AND CSU CAMPUSES. ADDITIONALLY
I'M CALLING ON THE STATE TO
MAKE FIRST TIMEINVESTMENT IN
POST GRADUATE FELLOWSHIP
PROGRAMS FOR NURSE
PRACTITIONERS PHYSICIAN'S
ASSISTANTS LIKE THOSE THAT
EXIST TODAY COMMUNITY HEALTH
CENTERS ACROSS CALIFORNIA. A
GOLDEN VALLEY HEALTH CENTER
NURSE PRACTITIONERS ARE ON
BOARD INTO A COHORT MODEL THE
GUARANTEES THEY MAXIMIZE OUR
SKILLS. IN CARING FOR
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES AND
PATIENTS WITH COMPLEX CARE
NEEDS. IN ADDITION I AM
PARTNERED WITH C. P. C. A. AND
PLANNED PARENTHOOD AFFILIATES
OF CALIFORNIA REQUESTING NEW
ONE TIME GENERAL FUND
INVESTMENTS TOTALING SEVENTY
SEVEN MILLION. TO REDUCE THE
DEBT BURDEN OR ELIMINATE THE
LEVEL THE CRUDE EDUCATIONAL
DEBT FOR UNDER REPRESENT
PHYSICIANS BEHAVIORS AND OTHER
CARE TEAM MEMBERS. THE COST OF
EDUCATION HAS BECOME A MAJOR
DETERMINING FACTOR THAT
PREVENTS MANY LOW INCOME AND
UNDER REPRESENTS STUDENTS FROM
ENTERING THE HEALTHCARE FIELD.
EVEN FOR THOSE THAT TAKE ON THE
COST SCHOOL THAT INFLUENCES
WHICH HEALTH PROFESSION
SUBSPECIALTY AREA TO PURSUE.
AND WHERE TO PRACTICE AFTER
GRADUATING. WE CANNOT ALLOW
RISING COST TO CREATE BARRIERS
FOR PURSUING HEALTH CAREERS AND
PROFESSIONS IN REGIONS OF
GREATEST NEED SUCH AS THE
CENTRAL VALLEY. RESEARCH SHOWS
THE PRIMARY CARE PROFESSIONALS
WITH LOWER LEVELS OF DEBT ARE
MORE LIKELY TO PRACTICE IN
UNDERSERVED AREAS. FOR THESE
REASONS IT IS CRITICAL THAT WE
ADDRESS THE EDUCATIONAL DATA
PRIMARY CARE PROVIDERS BY
PROVIDING FINANCIAL SUPPORT IN
THE FORM OF SCHOLARSHIPS AND
LOAN REPAYMENT PROGRAMS. THESE
ITEMS WILL GET MUCH NEEDED
TRAINING AND SERVICES TO
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES LIKE
MINE I LOOK FORWARD TO WORK
WITH MY COLLEAGUES AND MY CO
SPONSORS WERE HERE TO PROVIDE
MORE DETAIL. AND ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THE COMMITTEE MIGHT
HAVE. THANK YOU SIR. HI THANK
YOU SO A MEMBER GRAY. MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS I THINK YOU THE
OPTION TO SHARE THIS PROPOSAL
MY NAME IS BETH NON ASKING AND
I'M THE DIRECTOR OF GOVERNMENT
AFFAIRS AT THE CALIFORNIA
PRIMARY CARE ASSOCIATION. TODAY
ON BEHALF OF THE THIRTEEN
HUNDRED MANY HEALTH CENTERS
PROVIDE COMPREHENSIVE HIGH
QUALITY CARE SEVEN POINT TWO
MILLION CALIFORNIANS ONE IN SIX
CALIFORNIANS IN FACT. AS MISTER.
OUTLINES WELL THERE IS AN
URGENT NEED TO EXPAND
INVESTMENT CALIFORNIA'S HEALTH
WORKFORCE. WITH A PARTICULAR
FOCUS ON SUPPORTING THAT PERSON.
pWHO PROMOTE COULD LEAD TO SERVE
IN THE VALLEY AND ALL MEDIC.
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES ACROSS
CALIFORNIA. NEW FIVE THANK YOU
FOR ADVANCE TOWARDS CLINICIAN
EDUCATION ENTRY AS WELL NEW DAY
FOR DEBT LEAVE FOR
PROFESSIONALS ARE. THE FIVE
OPPONENTS TO MAKE CONTENT TO
PLAY. OUR IS LOOKING TO ADVANCE
THIS YEAR. TIME I'LL TAKE A FEW
MINUTES TO GO ON DEPTH AROUND
THE- MEN'S HERE TODAY. THE
NATION'S AND IT'S- FUNDING.
CALIFORNIA HOLES. ARE COULD. TO
YOU A CARE TEAM A PER. TO
GUARANTEE TO. ACCESS TO CARE.
WHOLE SENT HAVE SEEN FIRST HAND
THE VALUE OF VANS COULD. IN
PARTICULAR NURSE PRACTITIONERS
AND PHYSICIAN ASSISTANTS. AS
PART OF THESE TEAMS. THE
COMMISSION RECOMMENDS
INCREASING THE NUMBER OF
PERSONS TRAINING TO BECOME
NURSE PRACTITIONERS THROUGH
FINANCIAL SUPPORT. TO UC AND
CSU CAMPUS TO EXPAND AND
ESTABLISH NURSE PRACTITIONER
EDUCATION PROGRAMS COMMITTED TO
PRIMARY CARE AND UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITY. WE REQUEST THIRTY
SEVEN POINT EIGHT MILLION.
TWENTY ONE MILLION FOR
EXPANSION AND SIXTEEN POINT
EIGHT MILLION FIRST TABLETS MET
BE COMMITTED TO THE SONG BROWN
HEALTH CARE WORKFORCE TRAINING
PROGRAM FOR THEM TO USE THEIR
EXISTING INFRASTRUCTURE AND
FUNDING PROCESS EES DISPERSE
TO ELIGIBLE UC AND CSU
CAMPUSES. THIS PROPOSAL IN FACT
GOES ONE STEP FURTHER THAN THE
COMMISSION SUGGESTING THAT POST
GRADUATE FELLOWSHIP OPPORTUNITY
IS FOR BOTH NURSE PRACTITIONERS
AND PHYSICIAN ASSISTANTS ALSO
BE FUNDED BY THE STATE TO
SUPPORT THE SUSTAINABILITY AND
GROWTH OF THESE PROGRAMS. POST
GRADUATE FELLOWSHIPS ARE
OPTIONAL RESIDENCY LIKE
PROGRAMS THAT HAVE GROWN IN
POPULARITY ACROSS THE STATE AND
ACROSS THE COUNTRY TODAY THERE
ARE OVER TWENTY HEALTH CENTERS
PROVIDING POST GRADUATE
TRAINING. WILL SOME PROGRAMS
LAUNCHED WITH FEDERAL HER SO
FUNDS THERE IS NO I'M GOING
FUNDING FROM THE FEDERAL LEVEL
OR THE STATE OR FOR THAT MATTER
TO ESTABLISH OR EXPAND THESE
PROGRAMS. FOR THIS REASON WE
ARE REQUESTING ELEVEN POINT
NINE MILLION BE IT DEDICATED TO
EXPAND NURSE PRACTITIONER AND
PHYSICIAN ASSISTANT FELLOWSHIP
WE ALSO BELIEVE THESE FUNDS TO
BE COMMITTED TO THE SONG BROWN
HEALTH WORKER TRAINING PROGRAMS
FOR AGAIN. THERE ARE THEM TO
UTILIZE THEIR EXISTING
STRUCTURES TO MOVE FORWARD WITH
IMPLEMENTATION AND DISPERSION
OF FUNDS. AS ALWAYS TO DEBT
REDUCTION I WANT TO GO YOU
MOMENTOUS TO WALK THROUGH THE
ELEMENT TO THAT PROPOSAL. WITH
REGARD TO QUESTION WE'RE ASKING
YOU BOLD PLAN THAT AND A BIT ON%
THE CURRENT INFRASTRUCTURE THAT
OUR STATE HAS REPLACED AB LIST
FOR. FORGIVENESS I BELIEVE WE
SEE THE LAW. AND FUN OF INITIAL
CALL. OF THE COMMISSION. A
MERGING CALIFORNIA'S HEALTH
LEADERS SCHOLARSHIP PROGRAM WE
REQUEST FORTY POINT SIX MILLION
TO COVER THE INITIAL COHORT THE
TUITION 410% OF ALL STUDENTS
ENROLLED IN ELIGIBLE CALIFORNIA
HEALTH PROFESSIONS. TO ENABLE
MORE CALIFORNIANS TO PURSUE
DEGREES AND HEALTH PROFESSIONS
AND PRACTICE IN UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES WE PROPOSE THESE
FUNDS BE MINISTERED TO AJ BUT
HOUSED HEALTH PROFESSIONS
EDUCATION FUNDER AGE PATH.
ADDITIONALLY AFTER CLOSE REVIEW
OF CURRENT ASPEN H. BUT THE
MINISTERED FUNDS WE BELIEVE
IMMEDIATE ADDITIONAL
INVESTMENTS ARE NEEDED TO
GUARANTEE THAT A FAR HIGHER
PERCENT. OF ELIGIBLE APPLICANTS
TO THESE PROGRAMS ARE RECEIVING
FUNDS. COLLECTIVELY THESE
PROGRAMS HAS THE POTENTIAL TO
INVEST IN POSITIONS ADVANCE
PURCHASE CLINICIANS BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH AND PRIMARY CARE WORK
FORCE. REQUESTING TWENTY SEVEN
POINT FOUR MILLION BE
DISTRIBUTED TO AGE PATH FOR-
ALLOWING HIGHER PERCENT OF
ELIGIBLE APPLICANTS TO BE
RECEIVING FUNDS. THESE WOULD BE
FOR APPLICANTS TO THE STEVE
THOMPSON POSITION CORPS LOAN
REPAYMENT PROGRAM THE LICENSE
OCCASIONAL NURSE LOAN REPAYMENT
PROGRAM. THE ADVANCED PRACTICE
HEALTH CAROLINE REPAIR PROGRAM
AND LASTLY THE LICENSED MENTAL
SERVICE PROVIDER EDUCATION LOAN
PAYMENT PROGRAM. LASTLY ON THAT
FOR ALSO INCREASE THE NUMBER OF.
HELLO APPLICANTS RECEIVE. OF
FUNDING FOR THE STATE WILL
REPAIR PROGRAMMER SEEKING FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS TO BE DISPERSED
THERE- THE STATE WILL REPAIR
PROGRAM HAS THE POTENTIAL TO
EXPAND THE NUMBER OF PRIMARY
CARE PHYSICIANS DENTISTS DENTAL
HIGH JENIS POSITION ASSISTANCE.
NURSE PRACTITIONERS CERTIFIED
NURSE MIDWIVES PHARMACISTS AND
MENTAL BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
PROVIDERS THEY CAN ALSO RECEIVE
FUNDING. ALL PAUSE THERE- I
KNOW I JUST SHARED A LOT- IN
TERMS OF THESE EXTENSIVE NATURE
OF THESE PROPOSALS HERE UP FOR
THESE. REASONS I'M HAPPY TO
TAKE ANY QUESTIONS I WILL
KNOWLEDGE WE EVER COLLEAGUES IN
THE ROOM FROM OUR PLANNED
PARENTHOOD CALIFORNIA AS WELL
IN ADDITIONAL FEEDBACK ON THE
LOWER PAYMENT SPACE- WE THINK
YOU OFFER CONSIDERING THIS
PROPOSAL AND ADVANCING THIS
PROPOSAL AS PART OF THE BUDGET
PROCESS THIS YEAR. THANK YOU
MA'AM. WE WILL NOW TAKE PUBLIC
COMMENT ON ISSUE FORTY. THANK
YOU CHAIRMAN- MY NAME IS LISA
MUCH OF OUR ON BEHALF OF
PLANNED PARENTHOOD AFFILIATES
OF CALIFORNIA. WE ARE HAPPY TO
WORK WITH THE CALIFORNIA
PRIMARY CARE ASSOCIATION AN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAY ON THIS
ITEM. PARTICULARLY AS IT
RELATES TO DEBT RELIEF FOR
ADVANCED PRACTICE CLINICIANS.
OUR AFFILIATES REPORT
CHALLENGES RECRUITING AND
RETAINING ADVANCED PRACTICE
CONDITIONS IN RURAL SUBURBAN
AND URBAN AREAS A LIKE. DUE TO
BUDGET CONSTRAINTS SECURITY
CONCERNS UNIQUE TO PROVIDING
SEXUAL REPRODUCTIVE CARE. AND
AN EXTREMELY COMPETITIVE JOB
MARKET. IN ORDER TO CONTINUE
PROVIDING PATIENT CENTERED HIGH
QUALITY INTERESTED CARE WE
URGE. THE LEGISLATURE TO
SUPPORT PROCREATING A ONE TIME
FUNDING FOR A PC LOAN REPAYMENT
SPECIFIC TO REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH
CARE. IN ADDITION TO THE
EXISTING. PROGRAM THANK YOU
THANK YOU MA'AM. HELLO MY NAME
IS ARIANNA MARLYS I AM WITH THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICINE COALITION
IN SUPPORT OF THIS PROPOSAL OUR
COALITION IS ALSO SEEKING
SOLUTIONS TO REDUCE HEALTH
DISPARITIES FOR COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR. TO THE EXPANSION AND
INCREASE DIVERSITY OF PRIMARY
CARE PHYSICIANS TRAINING AND
PRACTICING IN OUR STATE WELL
OUR WORK FOCUSES ON IMPROVING
SYSTEMS THAT INTERFACE WITH THE
PIPELINE ANY EFFORT TO INCREASE
THE DIVERSITY OF OUR DOCTORS
CANNOT HAPPEN WITHOUT
ADDRESSING THE COST OF
TRAINING. THAT CREATES THE
NUMBER ONE BARRIER TO PURSUING
PROFESSIONAL TRAINING AND
HEALTH FOR STUDENTS OF COLOR.
WE NEED FOLKS TRAINING TO BE IN
PRIMARY CARE TEAMS WHO WANT TO
GIVE BACK WERE PART OF THE
COMMUNITIES THEY SERVE AND WHO
CAN AFFORD TO SERVE THEIR
FAMILIES AND FRIENDS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MA'AM. BENJAMIN TRAIN
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA PAN
ETHNIC HEALTH NETWORK IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU SIR. KELLY
BEAM ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
WANT TO ECHO THE COMMENTS OF
THOSE THAT CAME BEFORE ME IN
ADDITION TO THE TESTIMONY HERE
I WOULD JUST CAUTION- THAT IF
WE TO GET THE MOST BANG FOR THE
STATE'S DOLLAR THAT THERE BE A
COMMITMENT TO SERVE ANY IT FOR
ANY THESE LOAN REPAYMENT
PROGRAMS THAT THEY SERVE A
CERTAIN THRESHOLD OF MEDI CAL
PATIENTS- AND- OR- BE QUICK
ADMINISTRATION OF THE FUNDS
BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT. IT'S VERY
VERY VERY NECESSARY- IN A LOT
OF DIFFERENT COMMUNITIES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MA'AM SEEING NO
FURTHER PUBLIC COMMENT I'LL
BRING IT UP TO THE SUB
COMMITTEE TO SEE IF. THERE'S
ANY COMMENTS DR WHAT.
COMMENTING ALL DAY HERE BUT- I
JUST WANT TO I WANT TO THANK
YOU MISTER GRAY FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD- WE SHARE A COMMON
GOAL OBVIOUSLY AND I'VE AS-
PREVIOUS SPEAKERS AS WELL.
THERE IS A COMMON TO COM LINK
THERE WERE A LOT OF US ARE FROM
RURAL AREA OR JUST IN GENERAL
UNDERSERVED AREAS AND SO. ON
THE SENATE MISTER ON THE WAY
FORCE CAN. THE NUMBER THAT
STICKS IN MY MIND WAS IN ORDER
FOR US TO GET TO WHERE WE NEED
TO BE IN TEN YEARS WE NEED
SPEND ABOUT THREE BILLION
DOLLARS. FOR THREE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR OVER TEN
YEARS AND WE'VE ALREADY LAST
YEAR THAT SO WE GOTTA GET
RATCHETED UP AT SOME POINT. BUT
I THINK I THINK YOU I THE
CHURCH AT RISK PRACTITIONER
THIS IS ASSISTANTS AS WELL
BECAUSE- SECRET I HAVE I
BELIEVE THAT IF WE IF WE- ARE
OF THE ROAD ALL OF OUR EXISTING
WORKFORCE HELP WITH OUR PRIMARY
CARE. AS WELL AND I ALSO
RECOGNIZE THE ELEGY OF EARLIER
IN AND ALSO. OTHER SERVE AREAS
AND ATTRACT PEOPLE KEEPING THEM
THERE SO I WOULD I WOULD BE
THAT WE CAN MAKE IT IN TO HELP
KEEP KEEP FOR A LITTLE LONGER.
BUT OBVIOUSLY FINE AND AN
EDUCATIONAL DATA ARE CRITICAL
TO. PEOPLE'S DECISIONS. ON WHAT
A PRACTICE. IN ME THAT MADE IT
MORE DECISION THIRTY PLUS AGO I
THE- CHAIN BUT THE SET BUT BUT
THE SEARCH. GENERALLY OVER TIME
SO THE NEED IS GREAT ACTUALLY-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. RAMOS HERE HE
HE IS ALSO IN A IN A CRITICALLY
UNDERSERVED AREA IN THE IN
INLAND EMPIRE AS- AS IS THE
CENTRAL COAST AS WELL SO- I
THINK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD AND LOOK FORWARD TO.
HEARING MORE. WORKING WITH YOU.
THANK YOU TO WOOD ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RUBIO. YOU JUST WANTED
TO MENTION- IN TERMS OF. TRYING
TO STAY IN THE COMMUNITY- WHEN
I AS A TEACHER- THE- STATE
OFFERED WHAT THEY CALLED AN
HOUR APOLLON. AND SO WE WOULD
GET A DISCOUNT OR I DON'T KNOW
WHAT THEY CALLED IT BUT- FORGET
LOAN FORGIVENESS FOR EVERY YEAR
THAT WE TAUGHT IN AND
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES FOR UP
TO FIVE YEARS. SO THEN THE
REQUIREMENT WAS THAT YOU STAYED
FOR FIVE YEARS AND THEN THE-
THE AMOUNT WAS GIVING COULD
COMPLETELY BUT IT WAS THE
INCREMENTAL BASED ON THE YEARS
THAT YOU WERE SERVING IN THAT
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITY AND KNOW.
YOU'VE THOUGHT OF ANY OF THAT I
JUST FIGURED I'D- PUT IN MY TWO
CENTS IN BECAUSE I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT IF WE'RE GOING TO.
TRY AND KEEP THESE FOLKS- AND
WITHIN THOSE COMMUNITIES THAT'S
A REALLY GOOD WAY OF MAKING
SURE THAT- THE INVESTMENT THAT
WE MAKE IN THEM IS BEING PUT
BACK INTO THE COMMUNITIES THE
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES AT
YOUR- ADVOCATING FOR. THANK
THANK YOU. MEMBER AND IF I MAY
AT- I DIDN'T HEAR DOCTOR WOULD
SAY CENTRAL VALLEY AND-
SHORTAGE AREAS AND I THINK IT
WOULD. BE REMISS FOR MYSELFAND
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAY KNOCKED
TO. REPRESENT THOSE AREAS- I
DID WANT TO ECHO THE COMMENTS
OF THE PREVIOUS LOAN REPAYMENT
PROGRAMS THAT HAD REQUIREMENTS
FOR SEEING 30% MEDI CAL
PATIENTS. THAT MAY BE SOMETHING
YOU WANT TO INCLUDE WITHIN YOUR
PROPOSALS SO THAT WE CAN HAVE
SOME- STANDARDIZATION AMONGST
THOSE PROGRAMS- I WILL SAY THE
ONE THAT STUCK OUT. TO ME THE
MOST WAS P. A.'S AND NURSE
PRACTITIONERS WHO PROVIDE.
COMPREHENSIVE REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH IT'S INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT THAT. OUR FAQ EACH.
IN URBAN AND RURAL AND SUBURBAN
PARKS ARE ABLE TO. BE ABLE TO
ACCESS CARE- WITH THAT YOU HAVE
LEFT US WITH SOME WORK TO DO
AND- WOULD ASK IF YOU HAVE ANY
WORDS TO CLOSE. DOG THAT IF
THEY COMMITTEE FOR YOUR
COMMENTS- AND THE SUPPORT OF
THE- PAST SEVEN YEARS- THOSE
WAS A CENTRAL VALLEY INCLUDING-
THE CHAIRMAN HERE HAVE WORKED.
TOWARDS GETTING A MEDICAL
SCHOOL PUT INTO- UCSF AND UC
MERCED IN A PARTNERSHIP A
JOINT- MD PROGRAM BUT MOREOVER
BEYOND THAT WE'RE REALLY TRYING
TO TAKE. KIDS FROM AN
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITY HAVE
MENTORSHIP PROGRAMS IN JUNIOR
HIGH SCHOOL HIGH SCHOOL GET
THEM INTO A LOCAL UNIVERSITY A
LOCAL MED SCHOOL A LOCAL
RESIDENCY PROGRAM AND A LOCAL
LAW REPAIR PROGRAM. AND IF WE
CAN REPEAT- THAT EFFORT OVER
AND OVER AGAIN TO GO TO MAKE IT
A HUGE IMPACT BUT- I THINK ALL
OF THESE. PROGRAMS WE'VE
HIGHLIGHTED HERE TODAY FOR
INCLUSION IN THIS YEAR'S BUDGET
ARE PART OF THAT- HOLISTIC
APPROACH. TO IMPROVE ACCESS WE
DON'T HAVE ACCESS WERE JUST
REALLY LEAVING A TREMENDOUS
SWATH OF CALIFORNIA BEHIND-
INCLUDING MANY THE DISTRICTS
THE FOLKS- SITTING IN FRONT OF
ME SO THANK YOU FOR
CONSIDERATION I HOPE WE CAN
MOVE FORWARD. IS ITEMS HERE
THANK YOU SIR WE HAVE THAT WE
WILL HOLD ISSUES. OPEN. I'M A
POLICE FOR. OUT OF ORDER BUT
NOW WE WILL BACK. IN TO ISSUE
SICK. EMS AUTHORITY DEPARTMENT
AND BUDGET OVER. GAP BAND SIX
FORWARD PLEASE.
DOCTOR ARAMBULA
AND- COMMITTEE MEMBERS THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY I AM
JENNIFER LAMB ACTING CHIEF
DEPUTY DIRECTOR AND DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF LEGISLATIVE
REGULATORY AN EXTERNAL AFFAIRS
FOR THE AMERICAN- EMERGENCY
MEDICAL SERVICES AT THE ALREADY
I AM PRESENTING ON BEHALF OF
DOCTOR DAVID DUNCAN AN
EMERGENCY PHYSICIAN AND
DIRECTOR OF THE- EMERGENCY
MEDICAL SERVICES AT THE
ALREADY. WHO IS ELSEWHERE
ENGAGED WITH CORONAVIRUS
NINETEEN RESPONSE ACTIVITIES.
AND THIS IS RICK TRUSSELL OUR
CHIEF OF FISCAL ADMINISTRATION
AND AS REQUESTED WE WILL
PROVIDE A BRIEF OVERVIEW OF THE
DEPARTMENT IN OUR BUDGET. OUR
EMERGENCY MEDICAL SYSTEM IN
CALIFORNIA WAS CREATED IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY ONE BY HEALTH
AND SAFETY CODE DIVISION TWO
POINT FIVE WITH THE INTENT OF
CREATING A STATEWIDE SYSTEM
WITH THEM SO RESPONSIBLE FOR
THE COORDINATION AND
INTEGRATION OF ALL STATE
ACTIVITIES CONCERNING EMERGENCY
MEDICAL SERVICES. TO ENSURE THE
PROVISION OF EFFECTIVE AND
EFFICIENT EMERGENCY MEDICAL
CARE. I AM SET IS A SMALL
DEPARTMENT BUT WITH SIGNIFICANT
RESPONSIBILITIES THAT FALL INTO
THREE MAJOR CATEGORIES. FIRST
PRE HOSPITAL EMERGENCY SERVICES
WHICH IS ONE PIECE OF AN
EMERGENCY CARE NETWORK THAT IS
INTEGRATED WITH WORST HOSPITAL
EMERGENCY DEPARTMENTS AND OTHER
SERVICES. IN CALIFORNIA THERE
ARE OVER SIXTY FOUR THOUSAND
CERTIFIED EMTS AND NEARLY
TWENTY FOUR THOUSAND LICENSE
PARAMEDICS THAT RESPOND TO
ABOUT FIVE POINT FOUR MILLION
NINE ONE ONE CALLS FOR
EMERGENCY SERVICE ANNUALLY.
WITH FOUR THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED
AND TEN GROUND AMBULANCES AND A
HUNDRED AND THIRTY SEVEN AIR
AMBULANCES THEY TAKE IN THE ILL
OR INJURED TO ONE OF THREE
HUNDRED AND FORTY NINE ACUTE
CARE HOSPITAL EMERGENCY
DEPARTMENTS THAT ALSO MAY BE
DESIGNATED SPECIALTY CARE
CENTERS LIKE A TRAUMA CENTER.
SPECIFICALLY ANSWER IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE LICENSING
OF PARAMEDICS IN DISCIPLINING
THOSE LICENSES WHEN NECESSARY
AND MAINTAINING THE SCOPE OF
PRACTICE. STE TRAINING
STANDARDS AND REGULATIONS FOR
ALL EMS LEVELS INCLUDING PUBLIC
SAFETY FIRST STATE. SECOND ONLY
WITH MANY OTHER STATE PROGRAMS
THE EMS SYSTEM IS A TWO TIER
RESPONSIBILITY BETWEEN THE
STATE AND LOCAL AGENCIES I AM
SAID DEVELOPS GUIDELINES AND
IMPROVES PLANS FOR EMERGENCY
MEDICAL SYSTEMS THAT ARE
IMPLEMENTED AND OPERATED BY
THIRTY THREE LOCAL EMS AGENCIES
ACROSS THE STATE. I AM SO ALSO
DEVELOPS REGULATIONS FOR DESIGN
AND QUALITY OF SPECIALTY CARE
SYSTEMS INCLUDING THE TRAUMA
SYSTEM WITH SEVENTY NINE
DESIGNATED CENTERS. THE AFRICAN
REGENCY CARE CENTERS THERE ARE
THIRTY THREE PEDIATRIC CRITICAL
CARE CENTERS AND TWENTY FIVE
EMERGENCY DEPARTMENTS APPROVED
FOR PEDIATRICS. A STROKE SYSTEM
WITH A HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
DESIGNATED CENTERS AND A
CARDIAC SYSTEM WITH A HUNDRED
AND FORTY SEVEN CENTERS. IN
ADDITION TO A STATEWIDE POISON
CONTROL SYSTEM. THE THIRD MAJOR
AREA OF RESPONSIBILITY IS THE
MEDICAL RESPONSE TO DISASTER. I
AM SO PARTNERS WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH TO
BUILD A PUBLIC HEALTH AND
MEDICAL RESPONSE EMERGENCY
FUNCTION WITH FEDERAL STATE AND
LOCAL STAKEHOLDERS AND PLAN FOR
THE MEDICAL IMPACT OF ANY TYPE
OF DISASTER OR HEALTH
EMERGENCY. AS PART OF OUR
PLANNING EFFORTS ANSWER
DEVELOPS AND MAINTAINS THE
HOSPITAL INCIDENT COMMAND
SYSTEM WHICH HAS BECOME A
NATIONAL STANDARD IN
INTERNATIONAL MODEL. OUR
PROPOSED BUDGET FOR THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED BUDGET FOR
TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY ONE
RELEASED IN JANUARY OF THIS
YEAR INCLUDES EXPENDITURE
AUTHORITY IN THE AMOUNT OF
THIRTY FIVE POINT NINE MILLION.
AND SEVENTY POINT EIGHT
PERMANENT POSITIONS. OF THIS
AMOUNT SIXTEEN POINT SIX
MILLION IS DELEGATED FOR STATE
OPERATIONS AND NINETEEN POINT
THREE MILLION IS DESIGNATED FOR
LOCAL ASSISTANCE. THE
DEPARTMENT HAS TO BUDGET
PROPOSALS CURRENTLY UNDER
CONSIDERATION BY THE
LEGISLATURE. WE WERE ASKED
ASSEMBLY QUESTIONS- INSTEAD OF
TALKING ABOUT OUR BUDGET CHANGE
PROPOSALS MAY I ENDEAVOR TO
ANSWER THOSE FOR YOU YES PLEASE
THANK YOU. WE ARE ASKED TO
PLEASE DESCRIBE HIM SAYS ROLES
AND RESPONSIBILITIES WITH
REGARD TO RESPONDING TO AN
INFECTIOUS DISEASE PANDEMIC. I
AM SO IS TASKED WITH THE
COORDINATION OF MEDICAL
DISASTER MEDICAL CARE AND
MEDICAL RESOURCE COORDINATION
FOR THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
UNDER THE EMERGENCY SUPPORT
FUNCTION EIGHT HEALTH AND
MEDICAL AND UNDER THE STATE
EMERGENCY PLAN I. AM SO WORKS
WITH LOCAL AND REGIONAL STATE
FEDERAL PARTNERS DURING HIGHLY
INFECTIOUS DISEASE PANDEMICS TO
PLAN MITIGATE RESPOND AND
RECOVER. ANSYS DISASTER MEDICAL
RESPONSE ACTIVITIES ARE FOCUSED
IN THE FOLLOWING AREAS.
PREPAREDNESS IN COMMUNICATION I
AM SO WORKS WITH LOCAL REGIONAL
STATE AND FEDERAL PARTNERS TO
PRE PLANNED IN THE EARLY PHASES
OF AN H. ID OUTBREAK TO
ESTABLISH COMMUNICATION OF
ROLES AND RESPONSIBILITIES WITH
ALL PARTNERS AND TO ESTABLISH A
CONSISTENT REPORTING STRUCTURE.
AND SO ALSO PRODUCES IN
DISSEMINATES PRE HOSPITAL
MEDICAL GUIDANCE AS NEEDED
THROUGHOUT AN H. ID PANDEMIC
RESPONSE. WE ALSO ARE- LOOKING
AT SURVEILLANCE AND DETECTION.
I'M SO WORKS CLOSELY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS
IN REGIONAL DISASTER MEDICAL
HEALTH SPECIALISTS AND LOCAL
EMERGENCY MEDICAL SERVICES
AGENCIES TO PUT IN PLACE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA SURVEILLANCE AND
DETECTION PROTOCOLS DURING AN
H. ID PANDEMIC. THIS INCLUDES
CLOSELY MONITORING GLOBAL RISK
AND ADJUSTING STATE PROTOCOLS
BASED ON THE WORLD HEALTH
ORGANIZATION'S CENTERS FOR
DISEASE CONTROL AND CITY P. H.
INFORMATION RECOMMENDATIONS. I
AM SO ALSO WORKS WITH ALL
RELEVANT PARTNERS TO TAKE
ACTIONS AS NECESSARY TO LIMIT
THE SPREAD OF AN H. ID PANDEMIC
AND TO RESPOND TO THE MEDICAL
NEEDS OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA I. AM SO WILL
COORDINATE APPROPRIATE MEDICAL
RESPONSE WHEN WE CRESTED AND
NEEDED USING THE STANDARDIZED
EMERGENCY MEDICAL SYSTEM.
MANAGEMENT SYSTEM. THE SECOND
QUESTION OUR WHAT ACTIVITIES
HAS M. SAID ENGAGED IN RELATED
TO COVERT NINETEEN. CURRENT
COVERT NINETEEN ACTIVITIES
INCLUDE ASSIGNING STAFF TO ALL
STATE OPERATION CENTERS THIS IS
THE STATE OPERATIONS CENTER AND
THE MEDICAL AND HEALTH
COORDINATION CENTER.
COORDINATING AND DEVELOPING
DEPLOYING AMBULANCE STRIKE
TEAMS ROSTERS AND COORDINATE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSISTANT
TEAMS. FOR POSSIBLE DEPLOYMENT
ENSURING MEDICAL SHELTERS ARE
PREPPED TO BE DEPLOYED
COORDINATING PATIENT TRANSFERS
TO QUARANTINE CENTERS ARE
HOSPITALS AND WORKING WITH OUR
LOCAL REGIONAL STATE AND
FEDERAL PARTNERS TO UPDATE. AND
DISSEMINATE THE POLICIES
NECESSARY TO OPERATIONALIZE THE
GOVERNOR'S RECENT EMERGENCY
PROCLAMATION. I AM SO HAS ALSO
DEPLOYED STAFF AND
COMMUNICATION EQUIPMENT TO
OAKLAND TO SUPPORT THE GRAND
PRINCESS CRUISE SHIPS MISSION.
THAT'S WHERE DR DUNCAN IS NOW.
CURRENTLY ANSWER IS INTEGRATED
WITH THE HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES INCIDENT MANAGEMENT
TEAM OVERSEEING THE MISSION
ADDITIONALLY EMSA HAS
ESTABLISHED ONSITE EMS COMMAND
AT THE OAKLAND PORT TO
COORDINATE THE MOVEMENT OF
PERSONS DISEMBARKING FROM THE
CRUISE SHIP REQUIRING MEDICAL
CARE TO HOSPITALS AND IS
ENTERED INTO A CONTRACT WITH
AMERICAN. MEDICAL RESPONSE TO
EXECUTE THE TRANSPORTS USING
MULTIPLE AMBULANCE STRIKE TEAMS
AN AMBULANCE STRIKE TEAM IS A
GROUP OF FIVE AMBULANCES OF THE
SAME TYPE. EITHER ADVANCED LIFE
SUPPORT OR BASIC LIFE SUPPORT
WITH A COMMON COMMUNICATIONS
AND THE LEADER IN A SEPARATE
COMMAND VEHICLE. ALL ALSO MS IT
IS IMPLEMENTING POLICIES AND
PROCEDURES ALLOWING LOCAL EMS
AGENCIES TO UTILIZE PARAMEDICS
TO TRANSPORT PATIENTS TO A
MEDICAL FACILITY OTHER THAN A
CUTE GENERAL ACUTE CARE
HOSPITAL AND ALLOWING FOR THE
USE OF OUT OF STATE MEDICAL
PERSONNEL. AS OUTLINED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S EMERGENCY
PROCLAMATION FOR COVERT
NINETEEN. THANK YOU DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE ALEJO. PUBLIC
COMMENT ON ISSUE SIX. SEEING
NONE I WILL BRING IT UP TO THE
SUBCOMMITTEE TO SEE IF THERE'S
ANY QUESTIONS AND I MAY JUST
ASK A RHETORICAL ONE JUST TO
GET IT OFF MY CHEST BUT IS THE
STATE REALLY PREPARED FOR A
PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY. AT
THIS TIME I DON'T THINK I CAN
ALONE ANSWER THAT QUESTION FROM
EMPHASIS PERSPECTIVE WE ARE
LEANING FORWARD IN DEALING ALL
THAT WE CAN DO. TO INFORM OUR
EMS PERSONNEL OF HOW TO WORK
WITH THE HIGHLY FRACTIOUS
DISEASE AND DISSEMINATE
INFORMATION THAT WE'RE GETTING
FROM OUR PARTNERS. LIKE THE
PUBLIC HEALTH DEPARTMENT IN
GETTING THAT INFORMATION OUT
THERE IN A TIMELY MATTER AND
DISSEMINATED WIDELY WIDELY. I
AM REMINDED AND FEEL LIKE A
MUST EDITORIALIZE JUST A LITTLE
BIT THAT OUR GOAL SHOULD BE TO
TAKE CARE OF AMERICANS AND
THERE ARE A LOT OF AMERICANS
WHO CURRENTLY ON THAT CRUISE
SHIP AND WE HAVE A
RESPONSIBILITY AS A STATE TO
TRY TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO
CONTAIN AND TREAT AS MANY AS WE
CAN SO- I ADMIRE THAT'S DR
DUNCAN IS OUTRIGHT NOW WITH THE
CRUISE SHIP IN JUST APPRECIATE
THAT HE'S THERE RIGHT NOW. I'M
I DO HAVE A QUESTION IF WE CAN-
YOU HAD MENTIONED AMBULANCE
STRIKE TEAMS BUT I UNDERSTAND
THAT I'M SO ALSO HAS HAD IN THE
PAST- MOBILE FIELD HOSPITALS
AND I'M WONDERING IF. THESE
COULD BE ESSENTIAL FOR
INFECTIOUS DISEASE OUTBREAKS
FIRES OR OTHER TYPES OF
EMERGENCIES ARE THOSE MOBILE
FIELD HOSPITAL SOMETHING THAT.
AM SO USES REGULARLY OR COULD
BE USED IN THESE SCENARIOS. SO
THE MOBILE FIELD HOSPITAL
PROGRAM HAS TRANSFERRED INTO
THE MOBILE MEDICAL SHELTER
PROGRAM AND WE HAVE STATION TO
THESE MOBILE MEDICAL SHELTERS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE- IN
STRATEGIC LOCATIONS TO BE USED-
AS LOOK THE LOCALS DETERMINE
THE NEED- OR WE CAN SAY THAT W
HAVE USED THE SHELTERS. IN THAT
CONFIGURATION TO- HAVE A
RESPONSE LIKE WE DID IN THE
CAMP FIRE IN PARADISE WHERE WE
USE THEM IN ISOLATION TENSE WE
ALSO USE THEM CURRENTLY TO- OUR
ENDEAVORS TO HELP THE- AND THE
HOMELESSNESS. BY HAVING THEM BE
USED AS SUPPORT SERVICES TENSE
SO THE TENT STRUCTURES ARE
VALUABLE TO US AND WE'RE USING
CREATIVE WAYS TO USE THEM AND
DEPLOY THEM AT THE LOCAL SITES
AS NEEDED. CAN YOU TELL ME HOW
MANY OF THESE MOBILE OIL
MEDICAL SHELTERS THE STATE
CURRENTLY HOUSE AND IS
UTILIZING. SO WE STARTED WITH A
THREE MOBILE FIELD HOSPITALS
WERE CONFIGURED AS A TWO
HUNDRED BED LARGE HOSPITALS- WE
HAVE ALSO GIVEN ONE TO THE
CALIFORNIA- MILITARY DEPARTMENT
FOR THEIR USE. AND THEN WE HAVE
MADE SIX- INDEPENDENT MODULES
OF THOSE TWO HUNDRED BEDS IN
SPREAD THOSE OUT THROUGH-
CALIFORNIA. FOR USE AS A LOCAL
ASSET. I'M JUST OUT OF
CURIOSITY IS AN EARTHQUAKE AN
EMERGENCY FOR WHICH THESE
SHELTERS CAN BE USED THEY CAN
BE USED IN THOSE TYPES OF
SITUATIONS- I FINALLY HAS IS M.
SO INVOLVED IN THE ACQUISITION
OF COVE IN NINETEEN TESTS FACE
MASKS OR OTHER MATERIALS OR
EQUIPMENT. AND IF SO CAN YOU
PLEASE DESCRIBE. BELIEVE WE'RE.
I DON'T THINK THAT WORK DIRECT
RECIPIENTS OF BUT WE ARE IN
COORDINATION WITH OUR HEALTH
CARE PARTNERS AS WELL AS WITH
CD PH- WITH THAT AND SEE NO
FURTHER QUESTIONS FROM THE
SUBCOMMITTEE WE WILL HOLD ISSUE
SIX OPEN AND APPRECIATE ALL THE
HARD WORK THAT YOU'RE DOING.
THANK YOU. WITH THAT WE WILL
MOVE FORWARD TO ISSUE FIFTEEN
BECAUSE I SEE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
NAZARIAN IS HERE AND THEN WE
WILL COME BACK TO ISSUE SEVEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON AND THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY. HAPPY TO
JUST DIVE RIGHT IN YES PLEASE
MEMBERS I'M PROUD TO PRESENT A
PROPOSAL TO EXPAND THE
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER
WORKFORCE BY ALLOCATING FOUR
POINT SEVEN BY REQUESTING TO
ALLOCATE FOUR POINT SEVEN
MILLION GENERAL FUND DOLLARS TO
BE ADMINISTERED BY THE OFFICE
OF STATEWIDE HEALTH PLANNING
AND DEVELOPMENT. WE ARE WELL
AWARE OF THE HEALTH CARE
WORKFORCE CRISIS THAT OUR STATE
IS ENCOUNTERING AND THE
SHORTAGE OF BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS STIFLING FOR
EXAMPLE THE 8% OF CALIFORNIANS
MET THE CRITERIA FOR SUBSTANCE
USE DISORDER IN THE PAST YEAR
OF THOSE ONLY ONE IN TEN
RECEIVE TREATMENT. THERE ARE
LESS THAN TWENTY THOUSAND
COLISEUM AND DRUG ABUSE
COUNSELORS CURRENTLY CERTIFIED
IN CALIFORNIA FEWER THAN SEVEN
HUNDRED OF THE NEARLY ONE
HUNDRED AND FORTY THOUSAND
PHYSICIANS. HOLD A CALIFORNIA
LICENSE MAINTAIN AN ADDICTION
SPECIALTY CERTIFICATION. NOW
OUR GOVERNOR HAS TAKEN THAT AS-
DEDICATED AND HAS DEDICATED
FUNDING TO ADDRESS THIS CRISIS
HE HAS INVESTED IN THE OFFICE
OF STATEWIDE HEALTH PLANNING
AND DEVELOPMENT AS PART OF THE
LAST BUDGET CYCLE. HOWEVER THE
FOCUS ON SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER
PROFESSIONALS IS LACKING AND WE
ARE REQUESTING THAT ARE SPREAD
UTILIZE A SEGMENT OF FUNDS
ALREADY ALLOCATED TO ADDRESS
THE WORK FOR SHORTAGE. TO
SUPPORT SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER
FIELD IN THREE AREAS ONE
TUITION ASSISTANCE FOR
VOCATIONAL COMMUNITY COLLEGE
AND UNIVERSITY EDUCATION. TO
IMPROVE THE PIPELINE FOR
POTENTIAL NEW ENTRANCE BY
PROVIDING TRAINING
REIMBURSEMENT FEE WAIVERS
PROTESTS AND CERTIFICATION. AND
THREE DEVELOPMENT OF A STATE
WIDE SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER
WORK FORCE NEEDS ASSESSMENT
REPORT TO EVALUATE THE CURRENT
STATE OF THE SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER WORKS US. DETERMINE
BARRIERS TO ENTRY AND EVALUATE
THE STATE'S SYSTEMS FOR
REGULATING AND SUPPORTING THIS
WORK FORCE. WE HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO GROW OR WERE
FORCED AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
THAT YOU SUPPORT THIS PROPOSAL.
I'M JOINED BY DOCTOR LEANDER
CLARK HARVEY FROM THE LEAD
SPONSORING ORGANIZATION THE
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL OF COMMUNITY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH ORGANIZATIONS
WHO PROVIDE WE'VE COME ON WHEN
HIS PROPOSED AS WELL THANK.
RETENTION USE A MEMBER.
ARAMBULA STEAMED SOMEONE THANK
YOU FOR TAKING IT OUT I THINK
WE'RE ON LAST EXTRA FOR THE NOW
OKAY. I'M UNDER QUICKER EVERY
DAY PAUL AND LET OF FOR CD HA
AND WE'RE SPONSORED PROPOSED
AND WE REPRESENT OVER SEVENTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH AGENCIES
ACROSS CALIFORNIA WHICH PROVIDE
MENTAL HEALTH. AND SUBSTANCE
USE DISORDER SERVICES AND MY
COLLEAGUES FROM THE CO
SPONSORING ORGANIZATIONS ARE
HERE AS WELL TO JOIN ME FOR
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE SO WE'VE
SUBMITTED A LETTER TO THE
COMMITTEE- REQUESTING THAT YOU
CONSIDER OUR FUNDING REQUEST.
TO EXPAND THE SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER WORKFORCE IN OVER
TWENTY ORGANIZATIONS HAVE
SIGNED IN SUPPORT JUST OVER THE
WEEKEND SO IT'S GROWING. WE'VE
HEARD MANY STATISTICS TODAY
ABOUT THE DISPARITIES IN
AVAILABILITY. AND POSITION
HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS HOWEVER BY
TWENTY TWENTY EIGHT CALIFORNIA
WILL ALSO HAVE A PAUCITY OF
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH PROVIDERS AND
THE RECENT TWENTY TWENTY
NATIONAL CONTROL DRUG STRATEGY
REPORT INDICATES THAT QUOTE.
BUILDING THE ADDICTION
TREATMENT WORK FORCE IS ONE OF
THE MOST IMPORTANT WAY TO
ADDRESS GAPS AND TREATMENT. AND
SO IS ASSEMBLY MEMBER IN THIS
AREA AND EXPLAIN THE PROPOSAL
SEEKS TO DO THIS IN THREE
DIFFERENT WAYS. I WON'T GO
THAT'S BECAUSE THEY YOU CAN.
LISTEN UP BUT THE THIRD ONE
WOULD HE TALK ABOUT. AND NEEDS
ASSESSMENT IS REALLY IMPORTANT
BECAUSE ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD
TALKED EARLIER ABOUT. BEING A
PART OF THE FUTURE HEALTH
WORKFORCE COMMISSION AND WHAT
THEY DID NOT GET TO DO IS TO IT
IN DEPTH EXAMINATION. OF THE
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER WORK
FORCE FOR THIS PROPOSAL WOULD
ALLOW FUNDS FOR THAT. WE
REQUESTED OFSHE BUT BE THE
ADMINISTERING AUTHORITY AND
WE'RE COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH
HOSPITAL IN ANY OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS AT THIS PROPOSAL
MOVE THROUGH THE PROCESS. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. WE WILL NOW
TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT ON ISSUE
FIFTEEN. BENJAMIN TRIED WHAT
THE CALIFORNIA PENNETTA HEALTH
NETWORK IN SUPPORT I SUPPOSE-
WILL CREATE WORK FORCE THAT IS
REFLECTIVE OF THE COMMUNITIES
THEY SERVE. THANK YOU SIR. P.
NELSON WITH THE- CALIFORNIA
ADDICTION COMMUNITY THAT
RECOVERY OF CALIFORNIA AND
WE'RE IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU SIR
SEEING NO FURTHER PUBLIC
COMMENT ON BRING IT UP TO THE
SUB COMMITTEE- YOU KNOW I DO
RECOGNIZE THAT WE HAD A ONE
TIME FIFTY MILLION DOLLAR.
INVESTMENT LAST YEAR OR FOR ALL
SPREAD WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
FOR MENTAL HEALTH WITH NO
SPECIFIC SET ASIDE FOR
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER WORK
FORCE. I'D I DO HAVE A QUESTION
IF I MAY AND I'M TRYING TO FEEL
OUT ON THE STATE FOR A NUMBER
OF YEARS HAS TRIED TO GET TO A
STATE PEER SUPPORT
CERTIFICATION. AND I'M TRYING
TO UNDERSTAND WHAT WOULD BE THE
FUNCTIONAL DIFFERENCE BETWEEN.
THE SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER WORK
FORCE AND PEER SUPPORT I'D BE
HAPPY TO ANSWER THAT THANK YOU
SO THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THE
PURE SUPPORT WORK FORCING AND-
CERTIFIED AND REGISTERED
COUNSELORS IS THE COUNSELORS-
DO CLINICAL WORK SO THEY WOULD
BE DOING THE ACTUAL COUNSELING-
CASE MANAGEMENT GROUP
COUNSELING EXCEPT FOR THERE ARE
TWELVE DOMAINS TWELVE CORE%
SERVICES THAT THEY PROVIDE
WHERE IS A PURE WORKER WOULD BE
SOMEBODY MORE LIKE A NAVIGATOR
SOMEBODY WHO WOULD HELP
SOMEBODY MAKE SURE THEY GO TO
MEETINGS. TO GIVE THEM YOUR
SUPPORT THAT TYPE OF THING SO
WE TRY TO REALLY KEEP THOSE TWO
THINGS SEPARATE SO THAT PEOPLE
UNDERSTAND THAT I DON'T HAVE
THE CLINICAL SCRIPTS NECESSARY
TO TREAT THE DISEASE THEY CAN
BE SUPPORTED HELPFUL PEOPLE TO
MAKE SURE WELCOME WITH THEIR
MEDICATED STREET GOOD EATING
SIX AFTER AND THAT IS THERE SO
THEY'RE BOTH VERY IMPORTANT
JUST TWO DIFFERENT BANKS. MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS ONLY MEASURE
WITH THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF ALCOHOL AND DRUG PROGRAM
EXECUTIVES AND- WE- PROVIDE
DOES SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER
TREATMENT SERVICES NUMBER THREE
HUNDRED SITES THROUGHOUT THE
STATE AND PROBABLY THE LARGEST.
EMPLOYER OF SUBSTANCE USE
COUNSELORS IN THE STATE. OF WE
ALSO SEE THAT WE SUPPORT- WE
HAVE SUPPORTED IN THE PAST AND
YOU CONTINUE TO SUPPORT THIS
YEAR. UP YOUR SUPPORT
CERTIFICATION FOR SUBSTANCE USE
COUNSELORS AND WE SEE THAT IS
A- NOT ONLY A CRUCIAL ROLE IN
HELPING PEOPLE. I GET TO WHERE
THEY NEED TO BE AND- IN AND
NAVIGATE THROUGH SOME OF THE
SYSTEMS. BUT IT ALSO IN TERMS
OF CAREER DEVELOPMENT IS ONE OF
THE ENTRY LEVEL PLACES THAT.
OKAY MOVE INTO IN PEOPLE WHO
HAVE LIVED EXPERIENCE- IT IS
THE ENTRY LEVEL FOR THEM TO
MOVE INTO- AND CONTINUE ON INTO
SUBSTANCE USE COUNSELING. THANK
YOU MA'AM I'M- FORGIVE ME I DID
INTEREST MYSELF FLAYED SHERRY
DAILY WITH THE CALIFORNIA
CONSORTIUM PROTECTION PROGRAMS
AND PROFESSIONALS BEG YOUR
PARDON. NO WORRIES- IF I MAY I
MAY ASK- LEON READ A FOLLOW UP
WITH STAFF REGARDING THE NEEDS
ASSESSMENT IF WE COULD GET MORE
SPECIFICS IN A IN A COST FOR
THAT I THINK THAT WOULD BE
IMPORTANT FOR US TO UNDERSTAND
INDIVIDUALLY FROM THE THREE
ISSUES. NO PROBLEM THANK YOU
WITH THAT- ASSEMBLYMEMBER
NECESSARY IN ANY CLOSING WORDS.
HAPPY TO OBLIGE AND CONTINUE
FALL WITH FOLLOW UP THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
THANK YOU AND WITH THAT WE WILL
HOLD ISSUE FIFTEEN OPEN. WE
WILL NOW MOVE ON TO ISSUE SEVEN
DEPARTMENT OF MANAGED
HEALTHCARE. BUDGET OVERVIEW.
HI
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
MY NAME IS MERRY WATANABE I'M
THE ACTING CHIEF DEPUTY DEPUTY
OF THE DEPARTMENT OF MANAGED
HEALTHCARE WITH ME I HAVE GINNI
PHILLIPS OUR DEPUTY DIRECTOR
FOR LEGISLATIVE AFFAIRS I AM
PLEASED TO BE HERE TODAY TO
OFFER A OVERVIEW OF THE
DEPARTMENT OR BUDGET AND TO
ADDRESS ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE ABOUT OUR FOR BUDGET
CHANGE PROPOSALS. THAT WILL
HELP THE DEPARTMENT ACHIEVE ITS
MISSION OF PROTECTING CONSUMERS
HEALTHCARE RIGHTS AND ENSURING
A STABLE HEALTH CARE DELIVERY
SYSTEM. THE DAMAGE THE LICENSE
AND REGULATES APPROXIMATELY A
HUNDRED TWENTY SEVEN HEALTH
PLANS TO PROVIDE HEALTH
COVERAGE TO MORE THAN TWENTY
SIX MILLION CALIFORNIANS WE
REGULATE MORE THAN 96% OF
COMMERCIAL AND GOVERNMENT
HEALTH PLAN ENROLLMENT IN THE
STATE. THE DEAL MADE SEIZE
TOTAL PROPOSED FISCAL YEAR
TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUDGET IS
NINETY THREE POINT SEVEN
MILLION AND APPROXIMATELY FOUR
HUNDRED NINETY AUTHORIZED
POSITIONS THIS INCLUDES FOR
BUDGET CHANGE GRIPS PUZZLES
WHICH ADD THREE POINT SIX
MILLION AND A HALF POSITION.
THE DEPARTMENT ESPECIALLY
FUNDED BY IT WILL SPECIMENS ON
HEALTH PLAN COULD RECEIVE A
GENERAL FUND MONEY. THIS OUR
DEPARTMENT AND BY OVERVIEW I
WOULD BE TO GO INTO MORE TO
TELL OF THE DEPARTMENT OR ABOUT
CANCER IF YOU HAVE ANY THING I
AM I DO BELIEVE IT'S GOOD
EVENING BY NOW BUT IT IS- WITH
THAT FINANCE LEO. AND THEY PUT.
ON IS SEVEN. SEEING NONO BRING
IT UP TO THE SUBCOMMITTEE. YOU
KNOW I DO THINK AT SOME POINT
WE WILL TALK ABOUT ENFORCEMENT
OF THE MENTAL HEALTH PARITY AND
I BELIEVE THAT WILL BE ON A
FOLLOW UP HEARING- ON
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH ON APRIL
THIRTEENTH BUT DID WANT TO TAKE
THIS OPPORTUNITY IF I COULD-
TALK ABOUT HOW WE CAN ENSURE
NETWORK ADEQUACY. HOW CAN YOUR
DEPARTMENT MAKE SURE THAT OUR
NETWORKS ARE ACTUALLY WORKING
AND AVAILABLE FOR THE PLANS
THAT WE HAVE SURE SO MAYBE I'LL
TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT ABOUT
THAT I MEAN THERE'S A
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF WORK THAT
WE DO IN REGARDS TO NETWORK
ADEQUACY IN TIMELY ACCESS AND I
THINK WE PROBABLY TALKED QUITE
A BIT ABOUT THAT WITH YOU- I
THINK WHEN WE COME TO TALK
ABOUT MENTAL HEALTH IN THE WORK
WE'VE DONE ON. THE OF THE THAT
I THINK KEEP TO THE RIGHT AS
WE'VE DONE THIS AMOUNT OF AND
YET WHAT WE CONTINUE TO HEAR IS
THAT THERE'S ACCESS PROBLEMS. I
THINK WE ARE WE DON'T WORK
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION ON HOW WE TACKLE
THAT WERE PARTICIPATING HEALTH
US FOR OUR SWEET A LOT OF TIME
TALK OR STAKEHOLDER BUT I THINK
A NUMBER OF COURSE IS LEFT TO
BE ANSWERED ABOUT WHAT TRUE
BARRIERS ARE FOR CONSUMER WE
HAVE MIGHT. AS THE OF US BUT
LOW. OUT YOU KNOW IDEAS ABOUT
OUR X. BUT WERE REAL LOOKING TO
ARE STAKEHOLDERS IN KIND OF A
STATE WIDE PROCESS TO HELP US
UNDERSTAND WHAT THAT WOULD BE-
AGAIN TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF WORK
THAT WE DO ABOUT YOU KNOW
ACCESS AND NETWORK AVAILABILITY
AND TIMELY ACCESS BUT THERE
STILL SEEMS TO BE AN ISSUE FROM
A CONSUMER PERSPECTIVE. YEAH
AND IF I CAN I DON'T MEAN TO-
JUMP ON YOU BUT I DON'T THINK
ANYONE ELSE IS MAKING COMMENTS
ON IT- YOU KNOW I'D I'D DO SEE
BEING THE KNOX KEEN PLAN THAT
IT'S YOUR DEPARTMENT THAT
ACTUALLY. OVERSEAS IN
AUTHORIZES THE NETWORKS THAT
ARE USED AND SO THERE IS SOME
RESPONSIBILITY THAT I BELIEVE
YOUR DEPARTMENT BEARS IN
ENSURING THAT WE DO HAVE
NETWORK ADEQUACY AND SO WE JUST
ASK THAT YOU CONTINUE TO.
FIGURE OUT BEST PRACTICES IN
WAYS THAT YOU CAN INTERACT AND-
I WOULD SHARE MY CONCERNS THAT
SOMETIME SUB CONTRACTING DOES
PROVIDE US THE TRANSPARENCY
THAT WE NEED. TO MAKE SURE THAT
OUR NETWORKS ARE ACTUALLY
WORKING FOR OUR COMMUNITY SO-
WITH THAT WE WILL HOLD ISSUE
SEVEN OPEN AND MOVE ON TO ISSUE
EIGHT.
GOOD EVENING MEMBERS
DELIGHTED TO BE HERE THANK YOU.
I AM ERICA'S LOOK I AM THE
ACTING CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR
FOR THE OFFICE OF STATEWIDE
HEALTH PLANNING AND DEVELOPMENT
ARE ACTING DIRECTOR MARCO MEECH
IS ALSO RESPONDING TO THE
CORONA VIRUS. SO I WILL SPEAK
TO A REQUESTED OF BUDGET YOUR
TOTAL FUNDS AND POSITIONS AND
THEN PROVIDE A BRIEF OVERVIEW
IF THAT SUITS A CHAIR. AUSTIN
ADVANCES CALIFORNIANS ACCESS TO
SAFE QUALITY HEALTHCARE
ENVIRONMENTS BY FOCUSING ON
THREE PRIMARY AREAS. HEALTHCARE
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT. HEALTH
CARE DATA COLLECTION AND
REPORTING. AND HEALTH CARE
CONSTRUCTION AND FINANCING. I
SPREADS TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY
ONE PROPOSED BUDGET IS ONE
HUNDRED AND SIXTY POINT THREE
MILLION AND FOUR HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY FIVE POSITIONS.
ULTIMATELY 21% OF OUR SPEEDS
BUDGET IS GENERAL FUND THE REST
IS VERY A SPECIAL FUNDS MANY OF
THEM FEES SUPPORTED. WITH A
SMALL AMOUNT OF FEDERAL FUNDING
ABOUT ONE POINT SIX MILLION FOR
OUR WORK FORCE PROGRAMS. WE
HAVE FOUR BCP'S FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION TOTALING THREE
POINT SIX MILLION AND FIVE
POSITIONS. FIRST ITEM IN THE
OVERVIEW HEALTHCARE WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT OUR CURRENT
PROGRAMS INCREASE ACCESS TO
HEALTHCARE FOR UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES AND POPULATIONS BY
INCENTIVIZING A DIVERSE AND
CULTURALLY AND LINGUISTICALLY
COMPETENT HEALTH CARE
WORKFORCE. WE FOCUS ON
RECRUITING AND RETAINING
VARIOUS HEALTH PROFESSIONALS IN
AREAS OF UNMET NEED. INCREASE
THE GEOGRAPHIC DISTRIBUTION OF
CALIFORNIA'S HEALTH CARE
WORKFORCE AND EXPLORE NEW
SERVICE DELIVERY MODELS. I JUST
WANT TO NOTE THAT WE ARE AT ALL
SHOULD TAKING A FRESH LOOK AT
HOW WE STRUCTURE OR WORKFORCE
PROGRAMS AND EVALUATING THEIR
EFFECTIVENESS WE ARE LOOKING
ACROSS THIS DEPARTMENT AND
ACROSS THE AGES C. H. S. H. S.
AGENCY. IN A COMMA BROAD
CONTEXT. ASKING HOW WE CAN
BETTER COORDINATE. AND WE
RECOGNIZE THAT WE NEED BETTER
DATA TO DETERMINE THE ACTUAL
IMPACTOF OUR EXISTING PROGRAMS
AND SPECIFICALLY TO BETTER
UNDERSTAND HOW OUR PROGRAMS
INCENTIVIZE. BEHAVIORS. NEXT
HEALTHCARE DATA COLLECTION AND
REPORTING SO I SPEED COLLECTS
DATA FROM NEARLY SEVEN THOUSAND
HEALTHCARE FACILITIES THAT ARE
LICENSED BY THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH WE
MAKE MUCH OF OUR DATA AVAILABLE
TO THE PUBLIC RESEARCHERS
POLICY MAKERS THE MEDIA AND
MANY MORE. WE ALSO PRODUCE
MEASURES ANALYSES AND REPORTS
ON HEALTH CARE OUTCOMES AND
QUALITY AND OTHER RELATED
HEALTH TOPICS. I SHOULD
CONTINUES TO IMPLEMENT A COST
TRANSPARENCY PRESCRIPTION DRUG
PROGRAM SINCE JANUARY ONE TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
PHARMACEUTICAL COMPANIES HAVE
BEEN PROVIDING SIXTY DAY
NOTIFICATIONS DIRECTLY TO
SPECIFIED REGISTERED
PURCHASERS. WHEN THE COST OF A
DRUG INCREASES ABOVE A CERTAIN
THRESHOLD. IN TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN OSPREY BEGAN PROVIDING
QUARTERLY REPORTS FOR
MANUFACTURERS THAT INCLUDE
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION ABOUT
THE INCREASES TO EXISTING DRUGS
THAT HAVE BEEN SUBJECT TO THE
NOTIFICATION REQUIREMENT TO
PURCHASERS. IN TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN ON US BUT ALSO BEGIN
PROVIDING QUARTERLY REPORTS FOR
MANUFACTURERS IDENTIFYING NEW
DRUGS THAT WERE INTRODUCED A
MARKET ABOVE A CERTAIN COST.
OUR STATE HAS ALSO BEEN
IMPLEMENTING ANOTHER COST
TRANSPARENCY PROGRAM THE HEALTH
CARE PAYMENTS DATA PROGRAM. PER
STATUTE THE DATABASE WILL BE
SUBSTANTIALLY COMPLETE BY JULY
OF TWENTY TWENTY THREE. THE
HEALTH CARE PAYMENTS DATA
SYSTEM WILL SUPPORT
ADMINISTRATIVE INITIATIVES
ARRIVE AIMED AT ADDRESSING
COSTS AND IMPROVING SYSTEM
PERFORMANCE INCLUDING THE
OFFICE OF HEALTH CARE
AFFORDABILITY. THE CENTER FOR
DATA INSIGHTS AND INNOVATION
AND INITIATIVES TO ADDRESS
PHARMACEUTICAL COST. AJ BUT IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR COMMITTING A
REVIEW COMMITTEE TO ADVISE US
WITH ON THE ESTABLISHMENT
IMPLEMENTATION AND ONGOING
ADMINISTRATION OF A STATEWIDE
HEALTH CARE PAYMENTS DATABASE
WHICH SOMETIMES CALLED IN A P.
C. D. THE REVIEW COMMITTEE
FIRST CONVENE IN MARCH TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN AND HAD THEIR
LAST MEETING FEBRUARY TWENTY-
LAST MONTH TWO THOUSAND TWENTY.
AND I AM VERY PLEASED TO REPORT
THAT THE REVIEW COMMITTEE MADE
THIRTY SIX UNANIMOUS
RECOMMENDATION STOSCH BUT- THIS
MORNING OUR SPEED RELEASED A
REPORT TO THE LEGISLATURE THAT
INCLUDES THE REVIEW COMMITTEES
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE DATABASE.
THE REPORT IS DUE ON OR BEFORE
JULY ONE. BUT WE RELEASED IT
TODAY TO PROVIDE INFORMATION
AND CONTACTS FOR OTHER
ADMINISTRATION PROPOSALS IN THE
AREAS OF HEALTH CARE
AFFORDABILITY AND QUALITY.
MOVING ON TO HEALTHCARE
CONSTRUCTION AND FINANCE
AWESOME IT IS THE BILLING
DEPARTMENT FOR CALIFORNIA
HOSPITALS AND SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES. AND HOSPITAL MISTER
THE SEISMIC SAFETY PROGRAM OSP
IT IS COMMITTED TO THE
PRINCIPLE OF ACCESS TO HIGH
QUALITY CARE IN SAFE
ENVIRONMENTS AND WE CONSIDER
THIS OUR DUTY AND OBLIGATION.
WE ARE ALSO COMMITTED TO
WORKING COLLABORATIVELY WITH
HOSPITALS AND LOCALITIES TO
ASSIST WITH LOWERING THE COST
OF COMPLIANCE AND PROVIDING THE
BEST POSSIBLE CUSTOMER SERVICE.
TODAY MORE THAN 95% OF ACUTE
CARE HOSPITAL BUILDINGS OF THE
STATE COMPLY WITH A SEISMIC
SAFETY ACTS TWENTY TWENTY
EARTHQUAKE COLLAPSE STANDARD
MEANING THEY DO NOT POSE A
SIGNIFICANT RISK OF COLLAPSE.
BY TWENTY THIRTY THE STANDARD
IS THAT ALL ACUTE CARE
BUILDINGS MUST BE CAPABLE OF
REMAINING FUNCTIONAL AFTER A
STRONG EARTHQUAKE. TODAY
APPROXIMATELY 74% OF ACUTE CARE
BUILDINGS IN CALIFORNIA MEET
THE TWENTY THIRTY STANDARD. AND
FINALLY THE CAL MORTGAGE
PROGRAM- THE PROGRAM PROVIDES
HEALTH FACILITY CONSTRUCTION
LOAN INSURANCE TO NON PROFIT
AND GOVERNMENT FACILITIES AT NO
COST TO TAXPAYERS. THIS IS
CALIFORNIA'S NONPROFIT AND
PUBLIC HEALTH FACILITIES TO
GAIN ACCESS TO LOW COST
FINANCING FOR THE CAPITAL
CONSTRUCTION DEEDS AS OF
DECEMBER THE PROGRAM'S
INSURANCE PORTFOLIO CONSISTED
OF ONE POINT SEVEN BILLION IN
LOANS FOR SEVENTY SEVEN
FACILITY PROJECTS. THAT
CONCLUDES MY REMARKS WE HAVE
OUR EXPERTS ARE TODAY TO HELP
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE EL AL.
PUBLIC COMMENT ON ISSUE EIGHT.
GOOD EVENING M. JDS HERE ON
BEHALF OF SCA YOU CALIFORNIA WE
HERE IN TO SUPPORT THE
HOPEFULLY THE CREATION OF THE
HEALTH CARE PAYMENTS DATABASE
SCA WITH AN ACTIVE MEMBER ON
THE REVIEW COMMITTEE THAT OFSHE
BUT HAD FACILITATED- IN THE
LAST YEAR AND WE'RE EXCITED
ABOUT THE OPPORTUNITY TO
FINALLY GET A STATE WIDE HEALTH
CARE DATABASE UP AND RUNNING.
ALSO TO LINK THAT WITH THE
OFFICE OF HEALTH CARE
AFFORDABILITY WE LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH THE LEGISLATURE
TO THE BUDGET AND LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS SEES AND ALSO WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION ON THIS PROPOSAL
THANK YOU THANK YOU MA'AM.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEGAN
SUPER SOMEBODY HALF OF
CALIFORNIA HEALTH PLUS
ADVOCATES I WANT TO SUPPORT THE
WORK FORCE ITEMS THAT CONTAINED
IN THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET FOR
UNDER US PAID. PACIFIC LEAVE
THEM THE ON GOING MONEY FOR THE
SONG BROWN PROGRAM AND AS
YOU'VE HEARD ALREADY ONCE TODAY
FROM. AS A MEMBER GRAY AND YOU
WILL BE HEARING FROM DOCTOR
WOULD WE ARE- ADVOCATING FOR
ADDITIONAL DOLLARS FOR THE SONG
BROWN PROGRAM AN ADDITIONAL
WORKFORCE TRAINING PROGRAMS.
AND LONER PAYMENT PROGRAMS THAT
WOULD BE ADMINISTERED BY US BUT
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU ON
THIS. THANK YOU MA'AM. KELLY BE
MEMBER HAVE FOR THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION- WE ARE
ALSO- I WANT TO LINE MY
COMMENTS WITH OUR COLLEAGUES AS
HE ARE YOU AND THAT WE ARE
SUPPORT OF THE HEALTH CARE
PAYMENTS DATABASE AND THOSE
THIRTY SIX RECOMMENDATIONS AND
WE'RE GLAD THE REPORT IS OUT
RELEASE WE CAN GET GOING ON
THAT- AND ALSO I AM EXCITED
THAT OFFICE SEEKING A CLOSER
LOOK AT THE EFFICACY OF THE
FUNDS THAT HAVE ALREADY GONE
OUT. AND MAKING SURE THAT EVERY
DOLLAR WE SPEND HAS THE
APPROPRIATE IMPACT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. LINDA WAY WITH
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY WE TOO ARE IN SUPPORT
OF THE- ALL PAYERS CLEAN THE
DATABASE- AS WELL AS THE- WE
SUPPORTED THE- LEGISLATION AND-
ALSO SUPPORT THE CITY. THANK
YOU MA'AM. IF I MAY UM C. NO
FOR THE PUBLIC COMMENT I'LL
BRING IT TO THE SUBCOMMITTEE
AND IF I MAY I- WAS HOPING YOU
COULD SPEAK TO. THE TWENTY
NINETEEN BUDGET ACT IN WHICH WE
HAD- GIVEN FIFTY MILLION
GENERAL FUND TO SUPPORT MENTAL
HEALTH WORK FORCE PROGRAMS AS
WELL AS THE SIXTY MILLION TOTAL
THAT. THIRTY FIVE FROM GENERAL
FUND TWENTY FIVE. FROM THE
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES FUND FOR
THE WET PLAN IF YOU COULD
DESCRIBE IN MORE DETAIL- AT
FUNDING HAS BEEN IMPLEMENTED.
JUST I'LL TURN IT OVER TO SEE
JAY HOWARD OUR DEPUTY DIRECTOR
IN THAT AREA THANK YOU. I AM
SUBJECT THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF
THE HEALTH CARE WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT DIVISION I'M
ACTUALLY WAS DRAFTING A QUICK
RESPONSE TO ANSWER THAT
QUESTION- SO I'LL START WITH
THE SIXTY MILLION DOLLARS TO
THE PLAN WITH THE SIXTY MILLION
DOLLARS IS- OUR SECTOR THE
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS. I GET MY
FIFTIES AND SIXTIES CONFUSED
AFTER FIVE O'CLOCK YOU SHOULD
TRY IT IN SPANISH AND HAD. SO
THE FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS IN
GENERAL FUND WAS TO SUPPORT
EXISTING MENTAL HEALTH
WORKFORCE PROGRAMS OR PROGRAMS
THAT HAVE A NEXUS WITH MENTAL
HEALTH SO WE KNOW THAT MANY OF
OUR WORK FORCE PROGRAM
SPECIFICALLY LOAN REPAYMENT
SCHOLARSHIP PROGRAMS-
CROSSOVER. WHERE THEY THEY MADE
SUPPORT TRADITIONAL- PRIMARY
CARE SERVICES AND ALSO SUPPORT
PSYCHIATRISTS AND SO WE WERE.
CARVING OUT. PORTIONS OF THAT
GENERAL FUND TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY SUPPORT. MENTAL HEALTH
PRACTITIONERS- THE CURRENT
PLAN- RIGHT NOW SINCE WE'RE
GOING TO LET THE NUMBER OF
APPLICATIONS THAT WE RECEIVE
ALSO DRIVE SOME OF THAT
ALLOCATION BECAUSE- OF THAT THE
NUMBER OF APPLE. ELLIS
L'APPLICATION THAT WE RECEIVE
YEAR OVER YEAR. FLUCTUATES SO
THE PRIMARY PROGRAMS WILL BE
USED SUPPORT CLUED THE STATE
LOAN REPAYMENT PROGRAM SO THIS
YEAR ONLY BEEN ABLE TO AWARD A
HALF A MILLION DOLLARS JUST
OVER HALF A MILLION DOLLARS- TO
ELIGIBLE. OLD MAN.
PRACTITIONERS IN THE STATE ON A
PAYMENT PROGRAM THE STATE ONE
OF HIM PROGRAM ALSO HAS A
MATCHING COMPONENTS SO YOU KIND
OF GET A LITTLE MORE BANG FOR
YOUR BUCK. THERE'S A-
REQUIREMENTS- OUT OF A ONE ONE.
THAT WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO MAKE A
MILLION DOLLARS REALLY IN
LONER. AWARDS TO KNOWLEDGE ALL.
UP MENTAL PRACTITIONERS. STATE
LAW. PROGRAM WHERE PLAY TO
AWARD APPROXIMATE. SIX MILLION
TO REPLACE MENTAL HEALTH
MONNING. FOR EVERY. ACTIVE THAT
SELL FOR. AND HEALTH WITH COULD
BE. WITH DOLLARS IN WE'RE GONNA
SEE A LAW GROW IN THE NUMBER OF
PEOPLE THAT WERE ABLE TO AWARD-
I THINK THAT WITH THOSE FUNDS
WERE GOING TO BE ABLE TO AWARD.
CLOSE TO IF NOT A 100% OF
ELIGIBLE APPLICANTS IN THAT
PROGRAM THIS YEAR- TO THE TUNE
OF ABOUT SIX AND A HALF OR
SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS.
ADDITIONALLY WILL BE ABLE TO
AWARD I'M A PROP UP TO- AND-
AND IT GIVE TAKE TO IT WE
HAVEN'T GOTTEN ALL THE
APPLICATIONS SCORED YET BUT
APPROXIMATELY. UP TO TWENTY
FIVE PSYCHIATRISTS THROUGH THE
STEVEN THOMPSON LOW PAYMENT%
PROGRAM. THAT'S ABOUT TWO AND A
HALF MILLION DOLLARS- AND THEN
AWARD A FEW PROVIDERS THROUGH
OUR ALLIED. HELLO PROFESSIONS
REPAYMENTPROGRAM- THAT'LL BE
ABOUT SO IN TOTAL THERE'S A
ROUGHLY TEN MILLION DOLLARS IT
WILL LIKELY EXPAND THIS YEAR-
IN ALL LIKELIHOOD I WOULD
EXPECT- HYPOTHESIZE THAT WE MAY
SEE A GROWTH IN THE NUMBER OF
APPLICATIONS WORD WILL GET
HELPS THAT HEY WITH THEIR OR
THEIR APPROVING MORE THAN FIVE
OR 10% OF ELIGIBLE APPLICATIONS
AND SO WE MAY SEE A GROWTH AND
THE DEMAND BUT EVEN IF THERE'S
NOT THEN IN THE COURSE OF THE
NEXT FIVE YEARS SENATE THAT WE
SPEND TEN MILLION A YEAR THAT
THAT'S SORT OF THE PLAN BUT IF
YOU CAN A WAR MORE. ELIGIBLE
APPLIQUE NEXT YEAR THAN TEN
MILLION THEN THAT'S WHAT WE'LL
DO IS OF THE PLAN IS TO AWARD
AS MANY ELIGIBLE APPLICANTS AS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE THIS FUNDS-
SO THAT'S THAT THE FIFTY
MILLION GENERAL FUND AND THEN
THE WORK CURRENTLY CSUS
ENGAGING COLDER LANCE. TO COME
HOME TO THE PLAN THERE
SUPPORTING INDIVIDUALS WILL BE
ADMINISTERED THROUGHOUT THE
REGIONAL PARTNERSHIPS IS FIVE
REGIONAL PARTNERSHIPS
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA- COUNTIES
WITH THE X. LA COUNTY THERE OWN
READ PARTNERS AND WILL
ADMINISTER LOW PAYING
SCHOLARSHIP AND PIPELINE AND
STATE AND PROGRAMS TO SUPPORT
THE PUBLIC MENTAL HEALTH SYSTEM
WORKFORCE- WE ANTICIPATE
ALLOCATED ROUGHLY FORTY MILLION
DOLLARS SO 33% MATCH
REQUIREMENTS ON TOP OF THAT-
WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH THE
STAKEHOLDERS RUN THE PROGRAM
WILL BE ADMINISTERED- AND PLAN
ON AND REALLY IN A- GRAHAM
PUZZLE THIS SPRING AND HAVE
GRANT AWARDS MADE. A FIRST PART
OF THE NEXT FISCAL YEAR SO. I
AND THEN THERE'S AND THEY OF
SAID BE OF THE STATE
APPROPRIATIONS SIXTY MILLION
FORTY MIN AGO TO THAT. ANOTHER
TWENTY MILLION- GO TO WHAT WAS
BROUGHT UP EARLIER TODAY WHICH
IS A NEW PROGRAM THAT WE'RE
WORKING ON DEVELOPING WHICH IS
THE PSYCHIATRIC- EDUCATION
CAPACITY EXPANSION PROGRAM
THAT'LL SUPPORT PSYCHIATRIC
EDUCATION- RESIDENCY SLOTS AS
WELL AS PSYCHIATRIC NURSE
PRACTITIONER TRAINING POSITIONS
OR SLOTS- WE'RE ANTICIPATING
TO. AWARD ROUGHLY TWENTY
MILLION DOLLARS FOR THAT
PROGRAM- AND THE WAY THAT WE'RE
STRUCTURING THE AWARDS IS A BIG
COMPONENT OF HOW THOSE PLANS
WILL BE AWARDED TO PROGRAMS IS
ON A- OF COSTUME. BASIS SO
WE'RE GONNA A SCORING CRITERIA
WILL BE HOW MANY SLOTS CAN GROW
ON A PER. CAPITA BASIS SINCE E
DON'T KNOW EXACTLY HOW MANY
POSITIONS WILL BE ABLE TO
CREATE A WILL BE ABLE TO REPORT
BACK ON THAT AND WE THINK IT WE
STRUCTURED THE AND SENTENCED TO
WAY THAT. IT'LL REALLY WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO GET THE WHAT
WE'RE SIGNAL INTO THE PROGRAMS
IS. I AM AT A PROPOSAL IS AT A
AT A LOW PER CAPITA COSTS AND
THAT'LL HELP YOUR SCORE AND
HELP YOUR AWARDS THAT WE CAN
REALLY CREATE AN INCENTIVE FOR
THEM TO- COUPLE TOGETHER OTHER
RESOURCES TO REALLY EXPAND THE
NUMBER OF PSYCHIATRISTS OR
TRAINING. WILL BE EXCITING TO
SEE IT IT'S THE FIRST TIME THAT
WE'VE GOT THIS WAY GENERALLY AT
SOME OF OUR OTHER PROGRAMS
AWARD FUNDS WHERE THE- WHAT WE
MIGHT SAY OH. FOR THREE AND A
THOUSAND HE IF YOU KNOW YOU
MAKE A PROPOSAL TO GROW BY ONE
SLIGHT WILL PAY THREE HUNDRED
THOUSAND. WHAT KIND OF FLIPPING
IT SOMETIMES LIKE A REVERSE
ACTION YOU TELL US HOW MANY
PEOPLE YOU CAN GROW WITH HOW
MUCH MONEY. BUT WE'RE GEARING
THE SCORING HEAVILY TOWARDS-
LAUREN THAT PER CAPITA COST WE
CAN REALLY GROWTHAT NUMBER I
CAN MAKE THE BEST USE. THAT
TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS. I HAVE
A- FOLLOW UP QUESTION IF I CAN
WE'RE GOING TO HEAR A PROPOSAL
LATER REGARDING ANOTHER ONE
TIME FUNDING. AND I'M WONDERING
HOW USEFUL IT IS FOR ONE TIME
FUNDING FOR. GROWTH OF
RESIDENCY SLOTS. IS THERE A
NEED FOR. US TO HAVE CONTINUED
FUNDING IN THIS AREA AND- DO
YOU HAVE AN ESTIMATED IDEA OF
HOW MUCH THAT. FUNDING WOULD
BE- OR SHOULD WE- CONTINUE YEAR
AFTER YEAR COMING BACK FOR
TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS. I THINK
THAT SOME REALLY COMPLICATED
QUESTION ON I THINK OF IT IN
THE SCHEMES OF WE HAVE PRIMARY
CARE RESIDENCY SLOTS AND
PSYCHIATRY RESIDENCY SLOTS AND
SPECIALTY SLOTS AS WERE
MENTIONED EARLIER AND SO IT'S A
IT'S A MORE COMPLICATED
QUESTION- YEAH I THINK THAT
THAT WHAT WE HEARD FROM SOME OF
THE PROGRAMS THROUGH OUR
STAKEHOLDER PROCESS WAS. IT BE
NICE IF WE KNEW THAT THERE WAS
SUSTAINABLE FUNDING TO SUPPORT
THIS ON GOING BUT- THAT THEY'RE
NOT GOING TO TURN DOWN ONE TIME
FUNDS EITHER- AND SO WE'RE
AGAIN TRYING TO STRUCTURE OUR-
AWARDS. AROUND KNOWING THAT
THERE MAY NOT BE ADDITIONAL
FUNDS WERE TRYING TO STRUCTURE
THE AWARDS AND THE INCENTIVES
SO THAT. THEY CAN PUT TOGETHER
A SUSTAINABLE PROPOSAL WITH THE
LIMITED AVAILABLE OF THAT WITH
WITH WITH THE KNOWN AVAILABLE
FUNDS- I WOULD. LIKE TO FOLLOW
UP IN THE NEXT ISSUE REGARDING
HOW WE ENSURE IT'S EIGHT TWO
LOT. AS THEY HAVE SOME.
REGARDING SOME OF THE SONG
BROWN AND- AS AN ISSUE BUT I
DIDN'T. HEAR THAT YOU ALSO DEAL
WITH HEALTHCARE DESTRUCTION AND
FINANCING AND- YOU BROUGHT UP
THE TWENTY TH A- SEISMIC AND-
THAT WE HAVE. AND I THINK MY-
QUESTION JUST FIRST. GENERAL
HOW MUCH OF A NON MANDATE IS
THE- SEISMIC BILL THAT WAS
PASSED RECENTLY REQUIRING
TWENTY THIRTY MANDATE. DO WE
HAVE AN ESTIMATE FOR THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA THAT'S A VERY
INTERESTING QUESTION I WOULD
SAY THE AWESOME IT. DOES NOT
HAVE AN ESTIMATE THERE IS A
STUDY OUT THERE THE RAND STUDY
IN WE ASSISTED WITH THAT STUDY
A WE CAN INDEPENDENTLY VERIFY
THAT ITS CONCLUSIONS OF I SEE
PAUL COLEMAN OR DEBBIE
DIRECTORS COMING UP HERE YOU
MIGHT HAVE MORE TO SAY. GOOD
EVENING ALL COMMON OF THE US W.
DIRECTOR FOR THE FACILITIES
DEVELOPMENT DIVISION OF THE
ARCH BUT OUR OFFICES THEY WORK
OF PANNING DEVELOPMENT- PART
OF THE ISSUE WITH REGARDS TO
COST IS THAT IT IS- CONSTANTLY
MOVING TARGET- HOSPITALS HAVE
FOR EXAMPLE UNDER THE AB TWENTY
ONE NINETY OF PART OF WHAT WAS
DRIVING HOSPITALS TO USE THAT-
PROGRAM OR THAT EXTENSION WAS
BECAUSE THEY WANTED TO CHANGE
THEIR COMPLIANCE. APPROACH
METHOD ALSO SOMETIMES WILL
START ALSO THEY WANT TO PREVENT
THE NOTES CHANGED DECIDE THEY
WANTED TO A NEW BUILDING
INSTEAD. SO WE CAN'T PREDICT
WHAT THE HOSPITAL SIGNED UP TO.
WELL IN THE DOING WE CAN JUST
LOOK AT HISTORICALLY WHAT IT
HAS COST. TO DO EACH OF THE
DIFFERENT KINDS OF COMPLIANCE.
WHICH THAT INFORMATION PROVIDE
IN FURTHER STUDY AND I THINK
THAT'S HOW THEY AREDERIVED THE
NUMBERS THAT THEY CAME UP WITH
ANECDOTAL IF I. MAY I. THINK
IT'S AWFULLY HARD FOR US TO
HAVE THE DISCUSSION REGARDING
AFFORDABILITY AND NOT KNOW.
INHERENTLY THE UNFUNDED MANDATE
THAT COMES WITH THIS SEISMIC
BUILT IN SO I THINK HOSPITALS
ARE HAVING DIFFICULT
CONVERSATIONS NOW STARTING TO
PREPARE FOR TWENTY THIRTY AS
THESE CONSTRUCTION COSTS CANNOT
BE BORE IN A SINGLE YEAR. AND I
HAVE CONCERNS COMING FROM A
PART OF THE STATE THAT'S NOT A
SEISMICALLY. ACTIVE AS THE
COASTAL REGIONS THAT- THE
HOSPITAL WHERE I TRAINED AT A
LEVEL ONE TRAUMA CENTER IS
TELLING ME IT'S TWO BILLION
DOLLARS FOR THEIR HOSPITAL A
LOT. I WOULD LIKE TO ENGAGE THE
DEPARTMENT INTO SOME
CONVERSATIONS. AND UNDERSTAND
THERE MAY BE MORE WORK THAT
NEEDS TO BE DONE IN THIS AREA
BUT- DO FEEL WE HAVE A
RESPONSIBILITY TO. HELP WITH
THIS UNFUNDED MANDATES TO HELP
WITH AFFORDABILITY AS WE'RE
TRYING TO KEEP ALL COSTS WITHIN
THE SYSTEM THAT. ASSEMBLYMEMBER
WOULD. I WOULD JUST- IF MY
MEMORY AND IT MY MEMORIES
BEGINS TO- DIMINISH AS WE REACH
THE SIX O'CLOCK HOUR BUT MY
MEMBER MEMORY WE HAD A HEARING
ABOUT THE SEISMIC OF SEISMIC-
UPGRADE AT. COMPLIANCE ISSUES
AND MY MEMORY OF THAT RAND
STUDY IS THAT THE COST
ESTIMATES WERE OFF WAS A
HUNDRED AND THIRTY FOUR BILLION
DOLLARS. AND I SPECIFICALLY
REMEMBER TALKING ABOUT YOUR
YOUR HOSPITAL WAS LOOKING AT
TWO BILLION DOLLARS FOR NEW
HOSPITAL OR A BILLION DOLLARS
AS I RECALL TO RETROFIT THE
EXISTING HOUSE. AND I BELIEVE
IF A FIVE STILL CORRECT MY
NUMBERS I COULD BE FLAT ON ALL
OF THEM QUITE FRANKLY. BUT THAT
HOSPITAL SERVES ABOUT NINETY
PERCENT. BUT IT'S MEDICARE
MEDICAID- MEDI CAL AND SO HOW
DOES A HOSPITAL LIKE THAT HAVE
THE RESOURCES TO. TO DO THE
EITHER REBUILD OR OR OR-
RETROFIT AND THAT'S AND THAT'S
PART OF THE CHALLENGE WE FACE.
WELL AND- WITH THAT WILL HOLD
ISSUE. EIGHT OPEN AND MOVE ON
TO ISSUE NINE- BUT DO THINK
SOME QUESTIONS REGARDING HEALTH
CARE WORK FORCE. ARE AFFECTED
BY DECISIONS HOSPITALS ARE
MAKING REGARDING THE SEISMIC
CHANGES AS WELL AND SO- JUST.
WANT YOU TO KNOW IT'S A
HOLISTIC DISCUSSION TO FIGURE
OUT HOW WE CAN DEAL WORKFORCE
LAST QUESTION YES SERVICE ON.
JUST ONE JUST A QUESTION I WAS
AS I'M LOOKING HERE YOU HAVE A
YOU HAVE THE HEALTH CARE
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT DIVISION-
AND ENCOURAGING DEMOGRAPHIC
THEN REPRESENTING GROUPS TO
PURSUE HEALTHCARE CAREERS
IDENTIFYING GEOGRAPHIC AREAS OF
UNMET NEED. ENCOURAGING PRIMARY
CARE PHYSICIANS AND NON
PHYSICIAN PRACTITIONERS PROVIDE
HEALTHCARE. IN HEALTH
PROFESSIONAL SHORTAGE AREAS IN
CALIFORNIA. WHERE DOES THAT
WORK ON WONDER THE DO HAVE REAP
ABOUT HOW THAT HOW THIS IS
GOING- IS THAT IS THAT
SOMETHING. ON A SAID I AND I
APOLOGIZE IF I MISS A SOMEWHERE
THERE'S A FIRST I'VE SEEN THIS
SO I'M CURIOUS AS TO HOW THIS
WORKS WHERE THE RESORT WHERE
YOUR RESOURCES ARE COMING FROM
AND WHERE YOUR OUTCOMES. SO THE
RESOURCES ARE LARGELY WHAT
WE'VE DESCRIBED AROUND THE
DIFFERENT LONERGAN PROGRAM SO
IT HAS REACHED OUT OKAY FUNDING
SOURCES AS WELL AS SOME BROWN
AND SO WE HAVE- OUTCOMES
REPORTS FOR. BOTH THE WEB PLAN
AS WELL AS FOR THE SONG BROWN
IS AND WE ALSO PUBLISHED
REPORTS ON- THE DEMOGRAPHIC
WE'VE THAT PROVIDED A WHAT WAS
TO AND WHERE THOSE INDIVIDUALS
ARE PRACTICING SO THAT
ENCOURAGEMENT AS FINANCIAL
SENATE OKAY I THINK. YES IN
THIS IN SOME OF THE ARE FOR
PATIENT HAS NUMBER PROGRAMS ARE
I LICENSE THE GAMES A SEARCH ON
TYPES OF LICENSE. WHAT IS A-
MONEY IN WHAT MORE PEOPLE BY
THE THERE IS FOUGHT. US THOSE
PRO IS DOING ANYA REPORT TO THE
LEGISLATURE WELL. GREAT THANK.
YOU WITH THAT WE WILL ISSUE
EIGHT. MOVE TO ISSUE. AND I
WOULD LIKE TO RECOGNIZE AND
WELCOME. GILBERT IT'S OUR
HEARING AND ABILITY TO SEE YOU.
WE HAVE THE PLEASURE OF HAVING
JAYCEE COOPER AT ONE OF OUR
FIRST HEARINGS. AND APOLOGIZE
FOR THE LATE HOUR AND BRING IN
YOU AND- I WILL SAY YOU
RECEIVED A- AN AWARD FROM A
GROUP THAT I'D LIKE TO INSURE
THE UNINSURED PROJECT AND- JUST
WANT TO RECOGNIZE. YOUR
LIFETIME WORK. AND LOOK FORWARD
TO. HAVING YOU PRESENTS NOW.
THEN THE INTRODUCTION WHICH I
APPRECIATE- AS YOU KNOW ABOUT A
FEW YEARS OF PUBLIC HEALTH AND
MEDICAL MANAGE CARE EXPERIENCE
AND I'VE ALSO BEEN A PHYSICIAN
PRACTICING AND TAKING CARE OF
LOW INCOME AND VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS ON MAKES A VERY
BRIEF COMMENTS AND THEN TURNED
OVER TO JC COOPER. PROP FIFTY
SIX IS PROVIDED REALLY
SIGNIFICANT FUNDING FOR
PHYSICIANS AND DENTISTS AS WELL
AS OTHER PROVIDERS THE LIST IS
AVAILABLE YOU KNOW IN THE
PACKAGE SO YOU CAN SEE WHERE
THE NUMBERS ARE. I FEEL LIKE IT
IS REALLY AUGMENTED
REIMBURSEMENT AND TRULY KIND OF
STABILIZE THE MARKET. SO JC
WILL TALK ABOUT ANSWERING THE
QUESTIONS THAT YOU RAISED
AROUND. YOU KNOW SHOWING PROOF
OF ADDING BUT WHAT I THINK IT'S
REALLY DONE IS REALLY
STABILIZED. AND SO WHEN I THINK
ABOUT IT. THAT YOU KNOW THE
LOAN REPAYMENT PROGRAMS WERE
TALKING ABOUT. SOME HEALTH
PLANS HAVE DONE SOME INNOVATIVE
RECRUITMENT PROCESS SEES TO
BRING NEW PROVIDERS IN. BUT
THEN YOU'VE GOT TO HAVE THE
ABILITY FOR THOSE PROVIDERS TO
CONTINUE TO PROVIDE CARE. AND
THAT REALLY ULTIMATELY COMES
FROM THE REIMBURSEMENT THAT
THEY RECEIVE AN AND PROP FIFTY
SIX IS A- PRETTY SIGNIFICANT TO
HELP TO THAT. YOU KNOW THERE'S
SOME ANECDOTES OF ENCOURAGING
NEW DOCTORS BUT THEY'RE THEY'RE
A LITTLE BIT YOU KNOW A FEW AND
FAR BETWEEN LIKE BRAND NEW TO
COME IN BECAUSE OF THE
ADDITIONAL REIMBURSEMENT. BUT
AS I SAID I REALLY SEE THE KEY
PART OF PROP FIFTY SIX AND
REALLY HAVING BEEN ON THE
GROUND WITH THAT. AS REALLY
JUST. KEEPING THE DOCTORS WE
HAVE- AND NEW DOCTORS THAT ARE
BROUGHT INTO THE LOAN REPAYMENT
OR INNOVATIVE PROGRAMS THAT
SOME PLAN HAVE DONE. KEEPING
THEM GOING AS MEDICAL PROVIDERS
AND TO ME THAT'S KIND OF BEEN
THE REAL. PIECE OF PROP FIFTY
SIX ON THE PHYSICIAN SIDE. AND
JC WILL TALK ABOUT SOME OF THE
OTHER PROVIDER ALL. OVER YOU
SEE. THESE NAMES. UP TO PROVIDE
SO THE- OVERSEE THE PROP FIFTY
SIX- LOW PAYMENT PROGRAM FOR
YOUR DENTIST IN POSITIONS AND
THAT'S WILL FOCUS ON IT GENERAL
OVERVIEW AND- DIG INTO THIS
COMMITTEES QUESTIONS
SPECIFICALLY- SO THE PROGRAM
THAT HELPS DEVELOP INCENTIVE
FOR PROVIDERS TO. PARTICIPATE
IN MEDICARE PROGRAM WE DO SEE.
ON THEIR IT IS. A DIRECT
CORRELATION INCREASING ACCESS
TO MEDICAL SERVICES ANYONE WHO
JONES IN IN THE REPAYMENT. IS
IT SEEMS PROVIDE EITHER A NO
ACCESS TO MEDICARE PROGRAM. UP
A NEW PROVIDER THE MEDIC
PROGRAM. WHICH MUCH WE TARGET
HAS. IN WITHIN THE- BY SECOND.
THE REST SEE YOUR FELLOW. ON
THAT INTENT ON TO IN THE IT
WILL HAVE A JUST FOR TEN OF.
FIVE YEAR SERVICE COMMITMENT
SAME FOR DENNIS IF THEY ARE
DOING- A THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND
FOR EXCHANGE DENNIS ALSO HAVE A
PRACTICE SUPPORT GRANT. OF UP
TO THREE A THREE HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS WHICH GIVES
THEM A TEN YEAR SERVICE
OBLIGATION WITH THAT PARTICULAR
APPROACH- AWARDEES WILL RECEIVE
ONE FIFTH OF THEIR WARD EVERY
YEAR UPON REPORTING TO THE
DEPARTMENT THEY HAVE COMPLETED
THEIR ACTUAL OBLIGATION. SO
WHAT THEY PUT IN THEIR
APPLICATION IS THE TESTING TO-
WHAT THEY WOULD PROVIDE IN
REGARDS TO JUST IN CASE LOW TO
MEDI CAL- OR THEIR COMMITMENT
ONCE THEY REPORT THAT THEY HAVE
MET THAT THEN THEY RECEIVE THE%
PAYMENT. UP TO THE FIVE YEARS
OF THE OBLIGATION. ON THE
DEPARTMENT HAS PARTNERED WITH
PHYSICIANS FOR A HEALTHY
CALIFORNIA- TO ADMINISTER THE
PROGRAM DH CS IN PC HAVE
ESTABLISHED AN ADVISORY
COUNCIL. ON THAT LOOKS AT
ELIGIBILITY CRITERIA ON THAT
LOOKS AT SCORING CRITERIA AND
ULTIMATELY GIVES THE FUNDING
RECOMMENDATIONS ON AN ANNUAL
BASIS. SO THE SUBCOMMITTEE DID
ASK US TO ADDRESS IN REGARDS TO
WHETHER THAT FELT LIKE THE
OPPOSITION AND LOAN REPAYMENT
PROGRAM WAS RESULTING IN
INCREASED PARTICIPATION. IN CO
ONE WHICH THERE ARE CURRENTLY
FIVE COHORTS CURRENTLY PLANNED
FOR THIS PROGRAM DHC HAS
AWARDED TWO HUNDRED AND- SEVEN
POSITIONS AND FORTY DENNIS BUT
A LOT OF REPEAT. PRO ALL IN THE
LONG PAYMENT I'M FOR THE FIRST
COURT WE DIDN'T HAVE ANY
PRACTICE SUPPORT GRANTS GIVEN.
OF IS A SIGNATURE PORTION OF
POSITION ARE COMING IN NEW TO
THE PROGRAM WHICH WE SAW IS
REALLY- AS A GOOD SIGN. THE
OTHER THING THAT I WOULD POINT
OUT IS WE DO HAVE SOME A
SUCCESS STORY FOR EXAMPLE. WE
HAD A CHILD PSYCHIATRIST WHO
APPLIED FOR THE LOAN REPAYMENT
PROGRAM THIS PARTICULAR-
INDIVIDUAL WAS AND DID THEIR
MEDICAL SCHOOL IN CALIFORNIA
BUT THE RESIDENCY WAS OUT OF
STATE. THEY WERE PREVIOUSLY
GOING TO. BE PUTTING THEIR
PRACTICE UP IN THE ATLANTA
AREA. WHEN HEARING ABOUT THE
PROGRAM- THEY DECIDED TO APPLY
IN WHEN UPON GRANTED THEY NOW
ARE PROVIDER IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY- PROVIDING SERVICE 294%
MEDI CAL BENEFICIARIES BY
OPENING THEIR PRACTICE THERE.
SO THERE IS A LOT OF HOPE IN
REGARDS TO THIS PROGRAM.
HOWEVER PSYCHIATRIST YES WE DO
DEFINITELY IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY- HOWEVER THIS IS STILL
AN EARLY PROGRAM IT IS HARD FOR
US TO SIT AND SAY THAT THERE'S
EVIDENCE THAT THIS IS GOING TO
HAVE IMMEDIATE ACCESS. TO
SERVICES- BUT WE DO THINK THAT
IT IS VERY PROMISING PROGRAM-
THE ONLY THE FIRST CORPS HURT
WAS ONLY AWARDED IN JULY OF
TWENTY NINETEEN. AND WE DON'T
HAVE COMPLIANCE REPORTS YET.
THE COMPLIANCE REPORTS FOR THE
FIRST COHORT WILL BE DUE TO THE
DEPARTMENT IN AUGUST OF TWENTY
TWENTY. AND THEN WE'LL BE ABLE
TO SEE UPON WHAT THEY COMMITTED
TO WHETHER THOSE OBLIGATIONS
WERE MET WITH THEM THAT FIRST
COHORT. IN THE BE HAPPY TO
REPORT TO YOU UPON THE
COMPLETION OF COMPLYING WERE. I
FOR THE SECOND I WILL BE READY
AND FORTY WILL IN. IN MAY OF
TWO TWO THE- IS A FOR TO. YOU
INTO US THIS PROGRAM OVER CO OR
IN IN. TWO YEARS SINCE A WHOLE
ALONG TERM CAN. PROVIDE
SERVICES MEDICARE BENEFITS.
ADDITIONALLY THERE WAS
QUESTIONS BY THE SUBCOMMITTEE
IN REGARDS TO. THE PROPOSITION
SUPPLEMENTAL- PAYMENTS IN
REGARDS TO PROP FIFTY SIX. THE
PAYMENTS WERE DESIGNED TO
INCENTIVIZE AYE PROVIDER
PARTICIPATION AND UTILIZATION
IN PARTICULAR SERVICES. AS YOU
HEARD DOCTOR GILBERT MENTION OF
WE DO FEEL LIKE IT HAS
STABILIZED. I THINK ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT WE WANT TO MENTION
THOUGH IS THERE'S BEEN SUCH A
MULTI PRONGED APPROACH IN
REGARDS ACCESS TO MEDICAL
SERVICES FOR BOTH POSITION. AND
DENTAL SERVICES WE DON'T KNOW
IF WE CAN ACTUALLY CORRELATE BE
EXPANSION TO PHYSICIAN SERVICES
DIRECTLY TO ONLY PROP FIFTY
SIX. FOR EXAMPLE THE DEPARTMENT
HAS. SINCE TWO THOUSAND AND
SIXTEEN THROUGH THE MEDICAID
FINAL ROLE IN PUSHING
EXTENSIVELY ON NETWORK
ADEQUACY. REQUIRING OUR MANAGED
CARE PLANS TO CONTRACT WITH
ADDITIONAL PHYSICIANS. I'M TO
PROVIDE SERVICES ACROSS THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA ESPECIALLY
IN AREAS WHERE WE FELT LIKE
THERE WASN'T ADEQUATE ACCESS TO
SERVICES- THAT IS GOING TO
ALSO. IMPACT THE ABILITY OF NEW
PHYSICIANS COMING INTO MEDI CAL
SO WELL IT CAN'T BE A DIRECT
CORRELATION. WE DO THINK THAT
THERE IS IT IS VERY
COMPLIMENTARY AND ARE MULTIPLE
AREAS- PUSHING IN THIS
DIRECTION. SIMILAR ON THE
DENTAL SIDE- FOR THE DENTAL WE
HAVE- DE DENTAL PROP FIFTY SIX-
SUPPLEMENTAL PAYMENTS BUT WE
ALSO HAD THE DENTAL
TRANSFORMATION. AND PUSHING
FORWARD AT THE SAME TIME WHICH
WAS FOCUSING ON EVEN OF SERVER.
AND AS AS THIS. QUE AND- PUT
FOR DE ACCESS TO SERVE. SO
THERE ARE SOME DIFFERENT MORE.
A PRO. THE DEBATE OUR VIEW FOR.
ON SAYS TO MEDICAL. OF SERVICE
DENTAL SERVE. YOU CAN SAY.
ACCESS TO BOTH POSITION AND
DENTAL SERVICES ACROSS MEDI CAL
WE STILL HAVE WORK TO GO BUT WE
DO FEEL LIKE IT IS A STEP IN
THE RIGHT DIRECTION. THE NEXT
WE HAVE CJ HOWARD WITH OCEAN.
THANK YOU. SO FIRST UP FROM
BROUGHT OVERVIEW OF HEALTH WORK
FOR PROGRAM AND HEALTH WERE
FORCED TO OF WHICH TO ACCESS TO
CARE MENTAL K. MENTAL HEALTH
CARE AND HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS
AND UNDERSERVED AREAS
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA. IT
SHOULD BE YOU DD CONDUCTS
HEALTH CARE WORK FORCE RESEARCH
TO IDENTIFY AREAS OF AN UNMET
NEED AND IT SHOULD BE DE DE
GRANT PROGRAMS PROVIDE
FINANCIAL INCENTIVES TO
ENCOURAGE UNDER REPRESENTED
GROUPS TO BE SIR TO PURSUE
HEALTHCARE CAREERS AND FOR
INDIVIDUALS AND ORGANIZATIONS
TO PROVIDE HEALTHCARE SERVICES
IN AREAS OF UNMET NEED. A
PROVIDE A OVERVIEW OF SOME OF
OUR MAIN. RAM THE ONE OF COURSE
BEING THE SON ROUND TRAIN
PROGRAM. SO THE SONG ROWNTREE
PROGRAM PROVIDES INCENTIVE
FUNDING FOR INSTANCE. THAT
EDUCATE AND TRAIN FAMILY
MEDICINE AND PRIMARY CARE
RESIDENTS FAMILY NURSE
PRACTITIONERS PHYSICIAN
ASSISTANTS AND REGISTERED NURSE
STUDENTS TO PRACTICE IN AREAS
OF UNMET NEED THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA. OUR MENTAL HEALTH
WORKFORCE EDUCATION TRAINING
PROGRAM OR WHAT PROGRAM AIMS TO
DIVERSIFY AN INCREASE THE
PUBLIC MENTAL HEALTH SYSTEM
WORK FORCE TO ME CALIFORNIA'S
NEEDS. AS DESCRIBED FOR THAT
TWO PRONGED APPROACH OF
SUPPORTING INDIVIDUALS AS WELL
AS SUPPORTING SYSTEMS- AND THEN
I'M JUST GONNA LUMP TOGETHER
BECAUSE WE HAVE MULTIPLE LOAN
REPAYMENT PROGRAMS THAT ARE ALL
JUST A LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT IN
TERMS OF HOW THEIR STRUCTURE
AUTHORIZED- FUNDED BUT- WE ALSO
HAVE OUR LOAN REPAYMENT
PROGRAMS AND SCHOLARSHIP
PROGRAMS- THAT. AIM TO INCREASE
THE NUMBER OF PROVIDERS AND
DOESN'T NEED A PRIMARY CARE
MENTAL AND DENTAL SHORTAGE
AREAS THROUGHOUT. CALIFORNIA
THROUGH PAYMENT OF QUALIFIED
EDUCATIONAL EXPENSES OR
REPAYMENT OF EDUCATIONAL LOANS
IN EXCHANGE FOR PROVIDING
DIRECT PATIENT CARE AND
DESIGNATED SHORTAGE AREAS- THE
TYPICAL SERVICE RIGHT.
COMMITMENTS RANGE BETWEEN ONE
AND THREE YEARS- I'D SAY MOST
OF THEM ARE TO AND IN MANY
CASES THERE'S AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR ONE YEAR EXTENSIONS AND
SUCH SO WE CAN KIND OF DRAG OUT
THE- OR- ANY ENHANCE THE RICH%
WITHIN THESE PROGRAMS AND
WITHIN EACH REGION SO THE THIS.
CREATED AS QUESTIONS ABOUT WHAT
HAPPENED IS THAT SOME THE
EFFECT OF FORCED AND OFTEN. SO
AS FAR AS I'VE MENTIONED TODAY
OFFICE IS LIKE IT'S MORE OF
THIS ASSN MEASURE THE IMPACT OF
OFFICE FORCE PRO. AND I DON'T
TO PAINT WITH TO BE OF A BRUSH
HERE BUT I SAY SORT OF CAN'T.
THAT IN HIS IS THE STORE WE
HAVE A LOT OF THE DATA OUT
AWARDED WHOLE. THE DEMO. MY
LOCAL I. IN. WE SPENT THE-
NECESSARILY GETTING AWAY THAT
DO WE DO. THE IMPACT HOW DID WE
GET TO IN. ACCESS TO CARE HOW
DID WE CHANGE THE LAND. WITH A
TELL. THEM THAT'S THAT WERE
REALLY TAKE A OF NEW APPROACH
TO LOOKING AT SO. WHAT I THINK
WOULD BE HEALTH THOUGH. TO IS
TO WALK THROUGH A FEW OF A
PROGRAM AND- WHAT WE HAVE
MEASURED PREVIOUSLY BUT WILL
CONTINUE TO MEASURE. COURSE AND
THEN ALSO SORT OF PLANS FOR AND-
WHAT WE MEASURING. AND IS JUST
A QUICK SNAPSHOT OF SOME OF OUR
EFFORTS KNOWING. WE REALLY DO
HAVE A IT A NEW LOOK AT WE'RE
OF THE IMPACTS PROGRAM HAVE AND
STARTING WITH OF COURSE THE-
GOALS THOSE PRO. BECAUSE REALLY
EASY SAY THAT WE HAVE A- SO.
WHY WE JUST GOT RID OF TIPS IS
ALSO. WELL MAYBE THERE'S- THERE
OTHER THAT MY BE. THE FOR EACH
OF THESE FOR. SO WITH THE SONG
FOR BROWN. THE STATUTORY
DEFINED OF. IS TO INCREASE
NUMBER OF AN REPRESENT MINORITY
CARE PART. THE TRAIN OLD. PER
IN AREAS THAT MANY. AND WE DO
THAT. GRANTS TO. TRAINING
PROGRAM. THREE YEARS AGO THE
CALIFORNIA CARE WERE. POLICY
CAN THAT. MAKES RECOMMEND. ON
HOW TO A WAR THESE FUN.
COMPLETELY THEIR SCORE IN
APPROACH THAT WE CAN HOPEFULLY
IN THE COMING. YEARS AND NOW
START TO HAVE A BETTER OUTCOME
DATA AROUND. ARE WE MAKING AN
IMPACT ARE THESE FUNDS AN
INCENTIVE TO PROGRAMS TO.
INCREASE THE NUMBER OF
UNDERREPRESENTED MINORITIES
THAT THEY TRAIN AS WELL AS
TRAINING PLACE AND IN AREAS OF
UNMET NEED- THROUGH A VERY
QUICK SO THEY USED TO BE A
HISTORICALLY QUALITATIVE
APPROACH AND IT'S A VERY
QUANTITATIVE APPROACH WHERE THE
WE LET THE PROGRAM'S DATA SPEAK
FOR THEMSELVES AND THEN THAT'S
THAT DATA THAT DRIVES- OUR
AWARDS- AND SO WHAT WE- HOPE TO
BE ABLE TO DO IS TO. TO
BENCHMARK THAT WE CAN SAY IT.
PREVIOUSLY THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA THE PROGRAMS OR
APPLYING TO US WE SHOULD BE
ABLE TO SEE THAT THE PERCENTAGE
OF UNDER REPRESENTED MINORITIES
INCREASES WE SHOULD BE ABLE TO
SEE THAT TRAINING IN AREAS OF
UNMET NEED INCREASES. AND WILL
BE ABLE TO MEASURE THAT AND
DEMONSTRATE THAT NOISE THAT WE
WEREN'T ABLE TO NECESSARILY
TRACK BEFORE BECAUSE WE JUST
DIDN'T HAVE ACCESS TO THAT
DATA. I'M SO THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT WE'RE PLANNING TO LOOK FOR
TO DEMONSTRATE OUR IMPACT ON
ENSURING THAT WERE CHANGING THE
LANDSCAPE ARE PEOPLE BEING
TRAINED IN AREAS OF UNMET NEED
AND ULTIMATELY. PRACTICING IN
THOSE AREAS- CURRENTLY THE WHAT
DO WE KNOW ABOUT SOME OR SOME
RAM PROGRAMS WE DO KNOW THAT
SOME BROWN PROGRAMS. TEND TO BE
BASED OFF OF HOW WE AWARD OF
THE BILL- APPLICATIONS THAT WE
RECEIVE NOT EVERYBODY RECEIVES
AN AWARD TO RECEIVE MONEY. WE
KNOW THAT THE FUNDS ARE BEING
GEARED TOWARDS A PROGRAMS THAT
SCORE THE BEST AT. THE NUMBER
OF YOUR ENDS THAT THEY TRAIN
AND REPRESENT A MINORITY SORRY
THE FOR THE AFRICAN. AS WELL AS
TRAINING IN THOSE AREAS OF
UNMET NEED SO WE KNOW THAT
WE'RE HAVING AN IMMEDIATE
EFFECTIVE. BUT WOULD ALSO LIKE
TO SAY TO BE ABLE TO EVALUATE
IF THESE ARE AN INCENTIVE THERE
ACTUALLY CHANGING PROGRAM
BEHAVIORS AND THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
HOPING TO. MEASURE AND AS AS
ONE. ASPECT OF WHAT WE HOPE TO
MEASURE IN THE FUTURE- FOR. IT
TO THE WAY THE WORK FOR SAID
YOU. TRAIN FUNDS. THE MAIL
HEALTH SIR. ACT THEIR PRIMARY
AIMS TO INCREASE THE
RECRUITMENT AND RETENTION OF A
CULTURALLY COMPETENT WORKFORCE
IN THE PUBLIC MENTAL HEALTH
SYSTEM- THE- NEW WHAT. PLAN
PROVIDES IS IT'S A BEFORE FOR
SEVERAL PROGRAMS AND- THAT
SUPPORT INDIVIDUALS- AS WELL AS
EXPAND THE NUMBER OF
PSYCHIATRISTS THAT WE TRYING.
SO FOR EACH OF THESE PROGRAMS
IS SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT MEASURES
AND DATA THAT WE HOPE TO
GATHER- TO ALTERNATELY MEASURE
AND ASSESS. OUR OUR IMPACT- FOR
THE SAKE EXPANSION COMPONENT
AND PRETTY CLEARLY ONE OF THE
OUR OUTCOME MEASURES WILL BE
THE NUMBER OF NEW SLOTS THAT
WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO CREATE IN
CALIFORNIA- FOR. THE SUPPORTING
INDIVIDUALS COMPONENT. THE WORD
OR GETTING THROUGHOUT. EFFORT
WITH STAKEHOLDERS WE'RE GOING
TO HAVE ACCESS TO DATA THAT WE
DID NOT HAVE IN THE PAST FOR
WE'RE GONNA BE ABLE TO. IDEALLY
MEASURE. THE ENTIRE- THE SIZE
OF THE PUBLIC MENTAL HEALTH
SYSTEM WORKFORCE AND ARE WE
HAVING AN IMPACT THAT. INCREASE
IN IT. AND ALSO MEASURE
RETENTION RATES WITHIN THE
PUBLIC MENTAL HEALTH SYSTEMS DO
TO OUR- AND IT WAS SORT OF LOOK
GLOBALLY BUT THEN I ALSO TRY TO
MEASURE MORE. SPECIFIC
INFORMATION ABOUT THE
PARTICULAR. IF THAT WOULD. BE
MAKE AWARDS TO. WE DO KNOW THAT
FROM THE PRICE WHAT AND SOME OF
OUR OTHER LONGER PRO THAT WITH
FOR EXAMPLE PARTY THE PRIOR
WHAT WITH SOME HEALTH LOAN
ASSUMPTION WE KNOW THAT THE OLD
EASE DID STAY A WE NEED TO DO
WORK TO DO MORE ALONG THE RURAL
FALL UP THE RIGHT NOW THERE ARE
REALLY POTS WHERE A LARGE
MAJORITY OF THE PEOPLE THAT WE
MADE A WORDS TO ARE STILL
PRACTICING IN THE PUBLIC HEALTH
SYSTEM AFTER THEIR- SERVICE
COMMITMENT. WITH REGARD TO LET
HIM PROGRAM THESE OFF SERVICE
BY A- AND A- TOOL AND THEY HAVE
IT TOO. IN WE KNOW THAT WE HAVE
A VERY HIGH PRO COMPLETION
RIGHT SO WE'D BE A VERY FEW
PEOPLE THAT PREACH THE PEOPLE
WHO MAKE AWARDS TO COMPLETE THE
PROGRAM THEY COMPLETE THEIR
SERVICE COMMITMENTS OF BE AT
ONE TWO OR THREE YEARS- AND WE
ALSO. WE HAVE NATIONAL STUDIES
AS WELL AS AN INTERNAL STUDIES
IT CAN SUGGEST THAT. UPWARDS OF
70% OF PARTICIPANTS IN PROGRAMS
LIKE OUR STATE LOAN REPAYMENT
PROGRAM OR LIKE OUR STEVEN
THOMPSON LOAN REPAYMENT
PROGRAM. REMAIN IN HEALTH
PROFESSIONAL SHORTAGE AREAS FOR
MORE THAN FIVE YEARS AFTER FOR.
AFTER FULFILLING SERVICE. SO WE
DO THERE ARE NATIONAL STUDIES
THAT SHOW THAT PROGRAMS LIKE
OURS WORK. SOMETIMES CAN DE
THESE PER THESE STUDY CAN BE
COST BURDENSOME. BUT ALL THE
DATA THAT WE HAVE SUGGESTED
THAT IMAGE WAS A PARTISAN IN
AN- INFORMATION THAT SOME OF
THEM. COMPLETE THE SERVICE. AND
THEN LEAVE AN AREA ABOUT MEN.
THE MOST OF THE BIGGEST WE'VE
BEEN ABLE TO KIND SO THAT ALL.
FOR OF THEM STATE NOW IT MIGHT
BE A LITTLE BIT BETWEEN EACH
PRO. AND WE TRYING TO MORE WORK
AROUND. AND MORE LONG. STUDIES
OF THE ORDER. THAT WE'VE MADE
AWARDS TO BUT ALL THE DATA THAT
WE'VE HAD IN THAT WE'VE BEEN
ABLE AND ALL THE STUDIES
SUGGEST THAT THESE PROGRAM ARE
EFFECTIVE. BOTH A RETENTION
TOOL ALSO. WE HERE AND- FROM
PROVIDERS THAT PEOPLE WERE
ACCEPTED AT. EMPLOYMENT OFFERS
BETTER AND THAT THEY ARE AT
LEAST AS NO AT THE B. L. FOR
SOME OF THE LONG RIGHT. PRO SO
IT IF I CAN TELL YOU HOW MANY
PEOPLE KNOW. ACCEPTED OFFER
HOPE THAT THEY WERE TO BE EL.
ULTIMATELY RECEIVE A AWARD BUT
WE KNOW THAT IT HAS. A I DON'T
WE KNOW THAT IN AND SOMETHING
LIKE STATE FUNDED BY PRO. WHERE
IT'S- DOLLAR AND I'M NOT LEAVE.
FUNDS THE FEEDBACK THAT WE GET
FROM THE PROVIDER COMMUNITIES
QUITE PA. THAT WE USE THIS IS
SOME. TOOL TO PROVE. TURNS A.
GEN ONE. A IN THE PUBLIC NOW
OUR STAY IN THE PUBLIC SYSTEM
AND STAND THERE IS OF AN UNMET
NEED- SO IN CLOSING- WE ARE
ALWAYS LOOKING AT WAYS TO USE
NEW DATA TO DETERMINE HOW TO
MOST THE- ADMIN. PROGRAMS AND
WE'RE COMMITTED TO USING OUR
RESOURCES IN SUCH A WAY THAT WE
MAXIMIZE THE BENEFIT THAT THEY
HAVE ON EXPAND ACCESS TO CARE
FOR CALIFORNIANS. THANK YOU SIR
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE ALEJO.
GET A ONE MORE QUESTION IF YOU
WANT ME TO ANSWER I MEAN IT'S
GETTING LATE I DON'T KNOW I
DEFINITELY DO ABOUT NUMBER OF
NEWS. THAT'S LONG BROWN SO THE
NUMBER I'VE NEW. SLOTS AND THAT
WE CREATED WITH THE MILLION
THINK THAT IT'S AN TO GIVE A
CONTEXT OF HUNDRED MILLION
FIGURE OF THAT AMOUNT-
APPROXIMATELY SOME PORTION OF
THE HUNDRED MILLION WAS SET
ASIDE FOR PROGRAM
ADMINISTRATION ABOUT SIX
MILLION DOLLARS. SOME PORTIONS
SET ASIDE ACTUALLY TO AUGMENT
THE STATE LOAN REPAYMENT
PROGRAM WHICH WE JUST
DISCUSSED- END OF THAT A
ROUGHLY SEVENTY SEVEN MILLION
DOLLARS WAS DEDICATED OVER THE
COURSE OF THE THREE YEARS TO
SUPPORT EXISTING. RESIDENT
PLOTS SO TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS
AND OVER THE COURSE OF THE LAST
THREE YEARS WAS YOUR MARCH FOR
EXPANDING NEW PROGRAMS THE
CREATION OF NEW PROGRAMS OR
EXPAND EXISTING. GOV IF YOU
THINK ABOUT IT PURCHASED SLOT
IN THE PROGRAM THAT PROVIDE IT
SENT FUND ENTER THE THIS WAS
WHEN IS IT THESE PROGRAMS GROW.
SO WHAT IS THAT CREATED IT
CREATED A HUNDRED AND SIXTY
FIVE F. PRIMARY CARE THAT NINE
PURSES A FIFTY PRIMARY CARE
READ. SLOTS FORTY FIVE THESE.
ARE EX. OF EXISTING READ PO.
AND A HUNDRED AND TWENTY OF
LOTS ARE SO THIS WITH AWARD TO
SEVEN. NEW PER CARE AS A TO PRO.
THANK YOU DEPARTMENT FOR LA
BANJO WITH THE LET'S ANALYST'S
OFFICE ARE A HAS DONE A NUMBER
OF REPORTS ON THESE ISSUES OR
LATER ISSUES THE LAST YEAR'S
REGARD PROPER FIFTY SIX WE HAVE
KERR DH TO PROVIDE. ON THE AND
OF THE PROP TWO SIX THAT LOANER
PROGRAM IS LIKE THAT WOULD BE
PER AS THE REAL THE FUNDING IS
REALLY OFF THE GROUND THIS YEAR
I THE BEGINNING OF NEXT BUT
SUPPLE BUT PAYMENTS BEEN AND
SINCE TWENTY SO EIGHTY. AND WE
WOULD BE INTERESTED IN SEEING
HOW THOSE HAVE AND UTILISE AS
WELL AS POTENTIALLY PROVIDER
ENROLLMENT IN THE PROGRAM AS
WELL- REGARDING- THE ARCH BEDS
VARIOUS PROGRAMS ROOF WE'VE
REALLY STICK OF REPORTS ONE ON
MENTAL HEALTHWORKFORCE ONE ON
AS AND SEE PROGRAMS ONE ONE PUT.
USE OF THE OF JUST TEMPORARY
FUNDING FOR RESIDENCY PROGRAMS
WE DID THINK COULD BE TO HELP
FUND THE CREATIONS OF NEW RED
PROGRAMS- AT IN PLACES WHERE
MEDICARE DOESN'T FUND ANY
RESIDENCY SLOTS AS MEDICARE
COULD- SERVE AS A MORE ONGOING
FUND SOURCE FOR SUCH PROGRAMS
SO WE WOULD BE INTERRED WE
WOULD BE INTERESTED IN LEARNING
MORE ABOUT WHERE THOSE
OPPORTUNITIES ARE. THAT DOES
LIKE A UP TO USE OF IT TEMP FOR
WE DID FOR THAT OVER A THE WORK
FORCE PRO I WE HAVE NOT SEEN
THE GOOD COMPREHENSIVE VALUE.
OF A WHERE THE GREATEST REPORT
CHALLENGES IN THIS ARE AND B.
WHERE HOW STATE'S PROBE ALL PER
IN EFFECTIVELY ADDRESSING THOSE
AND SO WE WOULD OCCUR THE
DEPARTMENT AND OTHERS SORT OF
MAKES OF THAT DATA OUT IS
AVAILABLE TO THE- SO WE CAN BUY
UNDERSTAND THE BILL APPROACH
FOR THE LATER TO. THANK YOU ONE
OUT PUBLIC COMMENT ON THE ISSUE.
WHEN THE WAY WITH WEAPONS THAT
ONLINE POVERTY WE SUPPORT THE
CA OF THE LOAN WITH PROGRAMS
PAYMENTS DOING THE CAL ACCESS
AND THINK IF THERE'S A WAY TO
YOU MORE SO AFFECT. DESTRY THE
LOAN REPAYMENT PRO AT FUNDS I
SUCH AS LOWER THE LOWER AMOUNT
TO A PRO TO AND- THE NUMBER OF
WAR THAT. SHOULD THE WE CAN
ABOUT THE ACCESS TO SPECIAL.
AND IDENTITY HELP OF IN THAT
THERE ARE EIGHT TO COUNTY WITH
NO DATA CAP PROVIDER AND SAID
COUNTIES WITH ONLY DEDICATE
PROVIDER. SO IF THERE A LOT. IS
OPPORTUNITY TO CONSIDER A REACH.
APPROACH ENCOURAGE DEPARTMENT
TO LOOK AT THAT THANK YOU THANK
YOU. KELLY MY BEHALF OF THE-
MEDICAL SO WE HAVE. TEACH SIX
IS OVER SO OF. IF FUNDING
INCLUDING LUBRICANT PROGRAM CMA
OTHER STATE ARE. FOR THE
PROPOSED EXTENSION OF THE
PROPERTIES PM FOR ANOTHER
EIGHTEEN TO JULY FIRST TWENTY
TWO THREE HOWEVER THERE'S PRESS
ON THESE PROGRAM AT THAT WE
WANTED TO KNOW- OR THIS
REVENUE- WITH THE DECLINE IN
PROPERTY SIX TOBACCO TAX
REVENUE I'M NOTED IN THE-
BACKGROUND. OF THIRTY ONE
MILLION A YEAR- DECREASE
COMMITMENT TO THE SUPPLEMENTAL
PAYMENTS AND ALL THE PROVIDERS
FUNDED BY THESE RATE INCREASES.
FOR A LONGER TIME PERIOD AND
THE ADDITION OF THE INCREASED-
ONE HUNDRED MILLION BACK FEEL
TO THE PREVIOUS TWO TAXES- AS
PROPOSED BY CITY FTA WE ARE
CONCERNED ALL OF THESE
INCREASED PRESSURES ON PROP
FIFTY SIX REVENUE UNDERSCORES
THE IMPORTANCE. OF SUPPORTING
THE EXISTING PROGRAMS
LEGISLATURE AND GOVERNOR HAVE
CONFIRMED IN THE LAST FEW
BUDGET YEARS. ONE WAY TO
SUPPORT THESE PROGRAMS IS TO
ALLOCATE THE PROPOSED A
CIGARETTE TAX TO PROGRAM
SUPPORTED BY A PROP FIFTY SIX
AS A VOTERS INTENDED. WHEN THEY
PASSED THE INITIATIVE TO TAX
THE CIGARETTES AT A LEVEL
COMMENSURATE TO TRADITIONAL
COMBUSTIBLE CIGARETTES THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. GOOD EVENING
BRAND OF HEAVEN SPENCER THE
CALIFORNIA US HE- ONE ECHO SOME
COMMENTS HOW MUCH WE APPRECIATE
OVER OVER. OF THE FIFTY SAY
BOTH THE- PAYMENTS AS AS THE
STUDENT REPAYMENT WE'VE BEEN
VERY PLEASED TO WORK WITH THE-
FOR ALL THE- AS PART OF.
ADVISORY GROUP. ON A LOT FOR
THE PER. IT'S BEEN VERY
EXCITING FOR US WE HAVE A LOT
OF HOPE IN THE PRACTICE SUPPORT
GRANT AND HOPING THAT WILL GET
PEOPLE TO NOT JUST TAKE MEDI
CAL BUT ACTUALLY MOVED TO SOME
OF THOSE AREAS. WHERE WE DON'T
HAVE ANY DENNIS OR ANY DENNIS
TAKING MEDI CAL IT'S OBVIOUSLY
DIFFERENT ISSUE IF YOU'VE GOT
SOME PLACE WHERE THERE ARE LOTS
OF DENTIST HOW DO INCENTIVIZE
THEM TO TAKE. MEDI CAL VERSES
HOW DO YOU GET SOMEBODY TO GO
TO A DIFFERENT PLACE- SO WE'VE
BEEN DOING A LOT OF WORK WITH
OUR MEMBERSHIP OUR LOCAL
COMPONENTS AS- WELL AS THE
OFFICE OF ORAL HEALTH IN TRYING.
TO REACH OUT TO THEM SELECT
THAT THIS IS A VERY. ADVERTISE
ABOUT THE WORLD CAN. I AND THAT
THEY COULD GO ON PRACTICE THEIR
HAVE SOME THEIR- SURVEY PLEASE
THAT AS- AS THE- GO WE ARE.
THINK THAT I THE DONALD THERE
IS A LOT OF EVERY THAT KING. WE
HAVE A FOURTEEN HUNDRED
PROVIDER IN ROLE WHICH IS A
COME REVERSAL THE TO. IN
ENROLLMENT WE'VE SEEN. YOU SEEN
AN UPTICK IN UDEL. AND KIDS
PREVENTION OF ABOUT A THINK LOW
OR 7% AND A SMALLER A FOR. BUT
THEY HAVE BEEN OF TO CHANGES
THAT ARE ARE HAPPENING. AND CAL
IN. THE OF ADULT BUT DONALD. SO
IT'S OF HARD TO EXACTLY WHAT'S
MADE CHANGE BUT WE DO THAT THE
RAY. HAVE A SICK. IMPACT WE
JUST A THE- OF CMA. DO YOU
THINK THAT THE FIFTY SIX SHOULD
INCLUDED EAST THAT'S AN- THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL. TO TAX IS
THAT CORRECT SIR OF THE SAME.
COMBUST. SIR. GOOD EVENING
KATIE LEE NOT BE HALF OF THE
CHILDREN SPECIALTY CARE
COALITION REPRESENTING
PEDIATRIC SUBSPECIALTY MEDICAL
GROUPS THROUGHOUT THE STATE-
OUR MEMBERS HAVE BENEFITED
GREATLY FROM THE PROP FIFTY SIX
PROGRAMS PARTICULARLY THE
PHYSICIAN SUPPLEMENTAL PAYMENTS
AS WELL AS THE LOAN REPAYMENT
PROGRAM- PROGRAMS LIKE THESE
HAVE HELPED TO OUR MEMBER
MEDICAL GROUPS RECRUIT AND
RETAIN PEDIATRIC SUB
SPECIALISTS TO CONTINUE TO
PRACTICE HERE IN CALIFORNIA
WHERE WE ALREADY HAVE
DEMONSTRATED SHORTAGES THAT
MANY SUBSPECIALTIES- WERE VERY
PLEASED TO SEE THE EXTENSION OF
THE SUPPLEMENTAL AYMENTS
THROUGH JULY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY THREE AND URGE THE
LEGISLATURE TO APPROVE THIS
EXTENSION- THIS CERTAINTY GIVES
OUR MEMBER MEDICAL GROUPS
GREATER CONFIDENCE TO MAKE
OPERATIONAL DECISIONS BASED ON
THE ADDITIONAL REVENUE- WE TO
SUPPORT. HE PROPOSED USE A
GREAT TAX AND WOULD ALSO-
RECOMMEND THAT THOSE GO TOWARD
SUPPORTING THE PROP FIFTY SIX
PROGRAMS THAT I JUST MENTIONED
THANK YOU. GOOD EVENING MISTER
CHAIRMAN MAY KNOW BEHALF OF THE
PDA DATE. HEALTH COLA. A GROUP
OF PROVIDERS FOR MEDICALLY
FRAGILE. CHILDREN WHICH WERE
BENEFICIARIES OF THE RATE A
SUPPLEMENTAL RATE. INCREASE IT
HAS ALLOWED DODD GREATER ACCESS
TO A PROFESSIONALS- BY THE-
PEDIATRIC DAY HEALTH CENTERS-
THEY HAVE HAD SOME- HICK UP TO
GETTING RETROACTIVE. PAYMENTS
TOTHEM WHICH IS TITLED A
LITTLE BIT OF A SLOWING ON HOW
FAST THEY COULD. EXPAND THEY
SUPPORT THE EXTENSION OF THE
SUPPLEMENTAL PAYMENTS AND- IN A
PERFECT WORLD WOULD LIKE TO SEE
IF MADE PERMANENT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU SIR. I
MISTER CHAIR MEMBER OF THE
COMMITTEE KEVIN REP MAC
HEALTHCARE WE SHOULD THE
GOVERNOR PROPOSAL TO INCREASE
OUR OR EXTEND THE UP PROP FIFTY
SIX- EXTENSION OF FUNDING- WE
ALSO SUPPORT THE CMA'S- CALL
FOR INCLUDING THE E. CIGARETTE
PACKS IN THOSE FUNDS AS WELL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SIR. MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF ASKING ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ACADEMY OF FAMILY PHYSICIANS WE
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THE
ONGOING SUPPORT FOR THE SONG
BROWN PROGRAM WHICH AS YOU
KNOW. IS THE STATE'S ONLY
PROGRAM DEDICATED TO SUPPORTING
FAMILY PHYSICIAN PRIMARY CARE
RESIDENCIES OF WHICH THERE ARE
CURRENTLY A DEARTH IN THE
STATE. ADDITIONAL FUNDING HAS
RESULTED IN A LOT MORE SLOTS
AND HAS BEEN VERY MEANINGFUL TO
PATIENT ACCESS- IN BY OUR
ESTIMATES EVERY FAMILY MEDICINE
RESIDENT FUNDED BY SONG BROWN.
PROVIDES AN AVERAGE OF AT LEAST
SIX HUNDRED ADDITIONAL PATIENT
VISITS JUST DURING THE TRAINING
YEAR SO WE REALLY APPRECIATE
THAT ADDITIONAL SUPPORT LOOK
FOR THE CONVERSATIONS ON PROP
FIFTY SIX AND TREATMENT OF A
TAX AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
ATTENTION. THANK YOU MA'AM.
HELLO MY RIBS AND WITH PLANNED
PARENTHOOD OF CALIFORNIA WE
APPRECIATE THE LEGISLATURE. AND
ADMINISTRATIONS A COMMITMENT TO
EXPANDING ACCESS TO SEXUAL
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH. COMPANY
CULMINATING IN THE ALLOCATION A
HUNDRED. MILLION IN STATE PROP
FIFTY SIX REVENUE WHICH IS
ALLOWED US TO EXPAND HEALTH
CENTER HOURS. OPEN NEW
LOCATIONS AND PARTICIPATE
INNOVATIVE PARTNERSHIPS LIKE
THE WELL BEING CENTERS AND LA
COUNTY THERE FOR. INSURANCE
GOVERNOR BUDGET. PROPOSAL TO.
PROP FIFTY SIX SUPPLEMENTAL.
WHEN IT EIGHT MONTHS UNTIL JULY
TWENTY THREE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MA'AM SEEING NO FURTHER
PUBLIC. I WILL UP THE
SUBCOMMITTEE. SEE IF WE HAVE
ANY COMMENTS SOME. PERSONAL
THANK YOU AGREE. EVERYONE FOR
THE- I PUSH IT I'D- WANTED TO
COMMENT A LITTLE LAW. THE SONG
BROWN AT. COMPOUND I'M I. IN
WHAT CAN TO BE SUPPORTIVE ANY
WE CAN'T HELP FUND ALONG
REPAYMENT PROGRAMS FOR THE- I
WILL SAY FOR THE- AS I'VE SAID
ENOUGH. SETTINGS I AM CA
OVERALL TO LOOK AT THE AND THE
MOST CURRENT. I HAVE AND I WISH
THERE WERE SOMETHING MORE
CURRENT BUT- COULD. EIGHT
THOUSAND FIFTEEN WE SAW 10%
DROP IN THE NUMBER PRIMARY CARE
PHYSICIANS. STATEWIDE A TIME
WHEN THE POPULAR GREW BY TWO
POINT FOUR MILLION. AND THAT
COMES FROM SEE THAT YOU SEE SO
STUDY THAT DONE IN TWO THOUSAND
SO I'M I'M WHO. THEY'LL BE
FRESHMAN IS POINT. BY WHAT CAN.
ME IS THAT WHILE ARE DOING THIS
AND WE ARE DOING EVERYTHING WE
CAN TO ENCOURAGE. I FEEL LIKE
WE ARE IN IT IN SOME WAYS IT
FEELS LIKE A FINGER IN THE DIKE
BECAUSE WE'RE STILL HAVING
PHYSICIANS H. OUT. WE HAVE- WE
HAVE AREAS WHERE THEREARE
THERE AREN'T PRIMARY CARE
PHYSICIANS AND WE CONTINUE TO
HAVE OTHER CHALLENGES AND SO.
SO JUST TO COMMENT FOR THE
RECORD THAT THAT- IF OUR GOAL
IS TO PROVIDE HEALTHCARE FOR
EVERYONE IN CALIFORNIA- WE NEED
TO BE WE NEED TO BE FIGURED OUT
A WAY TO GET MORE PRIMARY
KERRY. CARE PROVIDERS OUT IN
THE FIELD. AND THIS IS A PIECE
OF THE PUZZLE BUT THERE ARE
OTHER THINGS I THINK WE CAN BE
DOING. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
DOCTOR WOULDN'T. DEFY CAN I
WANTED TO DRILL A LITTLE BIT
WITH AUSTRALIAN. MIGHT NOT BE
ABLE TO. GET THE- ON LOW. FOR
NOW. BUT I'M BEING TO. BY MY-
LOW. HOT AND TRAINING FACILITY
THAT- THEY NEEDED TO RIGHT SIZE
THE NUMBER OF. RESIDENTS THAT
THEY WERE TRYING. AND MY
CONCERN IS THAT THE SONG BROWN
MONEY THEY MAY HAVE RECEIVED
DIDN'T GO TOWARDS INCREASING
THE NUMBER OF NEW SLOTS. AND
PROVIDERS IN A MEDICALLY
UNDERSERVED AREA. AND WOULD
LIKE SOME ANALYSIS AND
TRANSPARENCY IF YOU CAN HELP TO
PROVIDE MY OFFICE WITH IT. TO
UNDERSTAND THE TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE THAT WAS ASSOCIATED
WITH THAT FUNDING. IS THIS
FUNDING THAT WAS FOR EXISTING.
RESIDENCY SLOTS THAT THEN GOES
TO BACK FILL THE CONTRIBUTION
COMING FROM THE HOSPITAL. OR
WAS THIS FOR A NEW SLOT THAT IS
BEING DESCRIBED. SINCE IT
SOUNDS AS IF THE FUNDING WAS
BRAIDED. FROM WHAT YOU
MENTIONED TO ME. IT LEADS ME TO
QUESTION AND REALLY WANT TO DIG
INTO THE DETAILS. REGARDING
WHETHER OR NOT WORK INCREASING
THE NUMBER OF SLOTS WITH THE
HUNDRED MILLION OLLARS THAT
WE- INCREASED AND SO. IF I MAY
ASK THE DEPARTMENTS TO FOLLOW
UP WITH MY OFFICE OFFLINE SO WE
MAY. DIG INTO SOME OF THE
DETAILS ON UNDERSTAND
REGARDING. WHAT WERE SOME OF
THE AWARDS BECAUSE IT SOUNDS AS
IF- SEE ARMS HE SHOULD HAVE
BEEN AWARDED NEW. POSITION AND
YET WHEN I ACTUALLY SO MORE PER
BE TRAINED WITH THOSE DOLLARS.
AND HAVE CONCERNS WE MAY NEED
FURTHER LANGUAGE TO ENSURE THAT
WE CAN HELP WITH OUR
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES WITH
THAT- WE WILL HOLD- ISSUE NINE
OPEN HAND THANK YOU GUYS FOR
YOUR PATIENCE WE WILL MOVE ON
TO OUR FINAL ITEM ISSUE SEVENTY.
TEARS WISHING MY FIRST DAY HERE
NOT AT ALL OKAY I KNOW WE DO
HAVE WE DO HAVE A WITNESS
COMING OUT FOR SMALL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- DOCTOR AMBULANCE.
THIS IS ITEM NUMBER SEVENTEEN.
AS A REPRESENTATIVE OF A
PRIMARILY RURAL DISTRICT AND A
MEMBER OF THE CALIFORNIA HEALTH
CARE HEALTH WORKFORCE
COMMISSION I'M ALL TOO FAMILIAR
WITH THE DIRE NEED FOR. AND
SHORTAGE OF PRIMARY CARE HEALTH
PRIMARY CARE HEALTH CARE
PROVIDERS IN CALIFORNIA THAT'S
WHY I'M WORKING WITH THE-
CALIFORNIA PRIMARY CARE
ASSOCIATION. AND THE CALIFORNIA
HOSPITAL ASSOCIATIONS CRITIC
CRITICAL BUDGET ITEM. WE ARE
REQUESTING NEW ONE TIME GENERAL
FUND INVESTMENTS INTO TOTALING
FORTY TWO POINT SIX MILLION
DOLLARS TO EXPAND PRIMARY CARE.
AND PSYCHIATRIC CARE RESIDENCY
PROGRAMS THIS ITEM IS
CONSISTENT WITH THE CALIFORNIA
FUTURE HEALTH WORKFORCE
COMMISSION RECOMMENDATIONS AND
WILL HELP GET MUCH NEEDED
SERVICES TO UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES. I'M COMMITTED TO
WORKING ON THIS ISSUE WITH THE
CHAIR AND MY CO SPONSORS. WHO I
WILL HAVE- MORE PROVIDE MORE
DETAIL AN ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
FOR YOU. SURE THANK YOU SOBRE
WETNESS CHAIRMAN. THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY. THIS PROPOSAL
MY NAME IS BETH ON ASKING WITH
THE DRIVE. OF AN AFFAIRS CALLED
PRIMARY SAYS. AT MISTER WHAT
OUTLINED. IN THIS COME. I'D
PRIMERICA INSIDE. RESIDENCY
INVESTMENTS SO THE MOST
PRESSING AREAS ACT. WELL THE
COMMISSION WELL AS IN OUR PORTS
FOR YOU OF HELP FORCED. HAVE
ACKNOWLEDGED THE- IN. THE STATE
HAS. A. RECENTLY TO ADVANCE PRY
CARE RESIDENTS EVE GREATER. ARE
NEEDED. AND AS YOU HEARD FROM
STATES. AND IS A MEMBER BEFORE
ME TODAY. THERE IS NEEDED
GREATER. ACROSS THE BOARD AND
WEARING. BY THE MENTAL AND SIR.
THE CALL FOR AND- TO. WE A- NAY
ONE TIME THAT OFTEN. TOTALING
FOR TWO SIX TO EXPAND PRIMARY
CARE AND PSYCHIATRY RESIDENCY
PROGRAMS. CONSISTENT WITH THE
COMMISSION AS NOTED BY SOME
REAL WOOD TWENTY POINT FOUR
MILLION WOULD BE GOING TO US
BUT FOR NEW PRIMARY CARE
RESIDENCY PROGRAMS. THOSE FUNDS
TO BE MINISTERED TO BY THE SONG
BROWN HEALTH CARE WORKFORCE
TRAINING PROGRAM. ADDITIONAL
EIGHT TWENTY TWO POINT TWO
MILLION TO A MUCH BETTER FOR
PSYCHIATRY RESIDENCY PROGRAMS
THESE FUNDS TO BE MINISTERED TO
THE PSYCHIATRY RESIDENCY GRAHAM
PRO. ESTABLISHED LAST YEAR'S
BUDGET. IS REFERENCED EARLIER
BASED MEMBER FONG. A CALIFORNIA
CENTERS ARE. LEADING THE CHARGE
IN EXPANDING PRIMARY AS IN AND
COMMUTE IS. AN ALL FEDERAL
FUNDING SUPPORT THI THE FUNDS.
TO UNDER. STATE INVESTMENTS
BECOME CRITICAL TO FOR THE
STABILITY AND EXT. OF THIS
MODEL. AS YOU MAY KNOW HER AS
TEACHING HEALTH GRAD MEDICAL
PER. BY GRANTS TO HELP SECTORS
THAT PROVIDES THE TRAINING OF
NEW FOR. ONE OF PART LEASE PRO.
PRACTICE DOES YOUR POPULATION.
AFTER READING THIS IS COMPLETED.
CAL IS HOME TO EIGHT EXIT. AND
TWO NEW DUTY SEE. THAT FUND
PRIMARY CARE AND ONCE LIKE HIDE
TRAINING PRO. HELLO THEY HAVE
ONE. RESIDENTS SLOTS ENDED
DELAYED THERE WERE. NEW HELLO
C. ZERO PRO THAT BE. A. TWENTY
TEN THE FUNDING RIGHT NOW IS
NOT THE TO SUPPORT FIRST
COAPORT. ANY UP TO YOU TO SEE
IT ARE ALSO INTERESTED IN. OUR
OWN GMAT GRANDMA OR- WITH THE
HOUSE OUR HOUSES AND THEIR- THE
SEEKS TO DO MORE IN GRADUATE
EDUCATION AND SO THAT'S WHY. WE
ARE LOOK FOR MORE FOR TODAY.
AGAIN THIS LACK OF TERM BY. NOT
ONLY IS UNDER HEALTH CENTER BUT
BROADER DELAY SO. AND JUST
UNDERMINING ALL PART IN THEIR
DESIRE TO SEE MORE TO. AND
MEDICAL EDUCATION FOR THESE
REASONS ROSE RESPECT REQUEST
ADVANCEMENTS THIS YEAR THANK
YOU FOR YOUR- THANK YOU MA'AM
WE WILL NOW TAKE PUBLIC. ON IS.
SEVENTY IS CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
BARBARA. WITH CAL HAAS IS SO.
PLEASED TO BE A COAST. OF PER.
WHICH IS. IN HAVE WAY I DID TO
A EARLIER PROPOSAL. THIS
PROPOSAL WOULD BRING US-
ADDITIONAL PRIMARY CARE
PHYSICIANS AS WELL AS
PSYCHIATRIC RESIDENCIES BOTH OF
WHICH WE DESPERATELY NEED.
THANK YOU MA'AM. FINESCALE ON
BEHALF OF THE CAL ACADEMY OF
FAMILY. GENERALLY SUPPORTIVE OF
THE EXPANSION OF SONG BROWN
PARTICULARLY SO MANY OF OUR
MEMBERS FIND IT CRITICAL TO BE
WORKING IN FEDERALLY QUALIFIED
RURAL HEALTH CENTERS AND LOOK
FORWARD TO HEARING MORE ABOUT
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THIS
PROPOSAL AND BEING A PART OF IT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MA'AM. IBM
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION VERY MUCH
IN SUPPORT OF NEW RESIDENCY
SLOTS IN THE ACCOUNTABILITY
THAT GOES ALONG WITH THAT
MAKING SURE THAT THE FUNDS
DON'T GET BRAIDED IN WITH OTHER
RESIDENCY SLOTS- AND OUR
SUPPLY. SUPPLANTING HOSPITAL
BUDGETS RATHER THAN CREATING
THIS ON. THANK YOU THANK YOU
MA'AM. WITH I WILL SEE NO FOR
PUBLIC. ON BRING IT TO THE
COMMITTEE IT'S KNOWS THE- ON A
BIG FAN OF. THIS PROPOSAL BUT I
DO WANT TO RECOGNIZE. YOUR LONG
HISTORY OF CHAMPIONING THIS AND
WORKING ON THE COMMISSION AND
SPENDING THE TIME TO. MAKE SURE
WE HAVE A HOLISTIC APPROACH TO
THIS- I HAD SOME QUESTIONS
INITIALLY REGARDING THE HEARSE-
T. SEED GM HE- TEACHING HEALTH
CENTER GRADUATE MEDICAL
EDUCATION. THE SLOTS THAT CAME
WITH THE ACA AND THINK IT'S A
GOOD THING FOR US TO CONTINUE
TO FIGURE OUT HOW WE CAN GET
SOME NEWLY ACCREDITED RESIDENCY
PROGRAMS WITH THIS. ONE TIME
INVESTMENT AND JUST WOULD. WANT
TO BE ABLE TO WORK WITH YOU IN
YOUR OFFICE REGARDING
SPECIFICITY TOWARDS. WHERE WE
CAN LOOK TOWARD SOME OF THOSE
PROGRAMS IN HIGH NEED AREAS AND
SO- WITH THAT AND SEEING KNOW
OTHER COMMENTS WE WILL HOLD
ISSUES SEVENTEEN. OPEN AND THAT
WILL CONCLUDE TODAY'S HEARING
OF THE STUFF. ONE BE FOR WE
CONCLUDE I AM NEED TO ASK ANY
COM ON ANY OF THE NON DISCUSS
ITEM. IF YOU HAVE IT PLEASE
COME FORWARD AND DISCUSS WHICH
ITEM IT IS ON THE AGENDA. SORRY
MISTER CHAIR I'M GOING TO BE
THAT PERSON. ON ISSUE NUMBER
NINETEEN M. SAYS B. C. P.
REGARDING IMPLEMENTATION OF SB
FOUR THIRTY EIGHT CALIFORNIA
PROFESSIONAL MAKING SUPERS OF
AFTER THE CALIFORNIA
PROFESSIONAL FIREFIGHTERS. CPF
I WAS A CO SPONSOR OF SB FOUR
THIRTY EIGHT AND WORKED WITH
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND DOCTOR
WOULD IN HIS CAPACITY AS A
CHAIR OF THE OF A POLICY
COMMITTEE. WHEN THAT BILL
PASSED LAST YEAR- THE POLICIES
CONTAINING AS BEFORE- OF
CRITICAL IMPORTANCE TO THE CPF
pDELIVERY SYSTEM AND WE DO HOPE.
THAT WITH THE REQUEST FOR
RESOURCES BY AM SO IN THIS ITEM
INDICATE THEIR SUPPORT FOR FIRE
DEPARTMENT. AND CALIFORNIA'S
FIREFIGHTERS AND SWORN
DISPATCHERS IN CALIFORNIA
SEEKING TO PROVIDE EFFICIENT
NINE ONE ONE CALL PROCESSING AS
WELL AS DISPATCH APPROPRIATE
RESOURCES TO RESPOND TO
EMERGENCIES AND MEET THE NEEDS
OF THEIR COMMUNITIES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MA'AM. GOOD EVENING
AM J. D. OUR BEHALF OF SCA CAL.
Y. TO AND REGISTER ARE SO. FOR
THE BCP'S. ISSUE TWENTY ONE. ON
HEALTH CARE DATA DISCLOSURE FOR
SB THREE FIFTY THREE FORTY
THREE. WE ALSO WOULD LIKE TO
REGISTER SUPPORT FOR B. C. P.
FOR ISSUE TWENTY FIVE FOUR
EIGHTY TO NINETY ON. THIRD
PARTY PAYMENTS. AND LASTLY
WOULD LIKE TO REGISTER SUPPORT
FOR ISSUE TWENTY SEVEN. FOUR
LARGE GROUP RATE REVIEW EIGHTY
SEVEN THIRTY ONE BCP THANK YOU
THANK YOU MA'AM. KELLY BEAM ON
BEHALF OF THE CAL MEDI
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF ISSUE
TWENTY FOUR TO IMPLEMENT OUR
SPONSORED BILL AB SEVEN FOUR
FOUR THANK YOU. THANK YOU MA'AM
SEEING NO FURTHER PUBLIC
COMMENTS ON NON DISCUSSION
ITEMS THIS WILL CONCLUDE
TODAY'S HEARING THANK YOU FOR
YOUR ATTENDANCE.